THE COMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD MORNING
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT NON
ESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY
THE MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ARE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
BOTH PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I ASKED
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AS BEING A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING OUR I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO THE
HEARING ROOM. TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS- 877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHT ONE EIGHT TWO
EIGHT ONE SEVEN FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING. AS IS CUSTOMARY
AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEDIAN SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HIRING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
TODAY'S HEARING WILL COVER
ISSUES RELATED TO THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS ALSO WE
OF WILL TAKE UP ITEMS ON THE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR. ALL VOTES
WILL BE TAKEN AT THE END OF THE
HEARING ONCE WE HAVE COMPLETED
ALL DISCUSSION AND PUBLIC
COMMENT. BEFORE WE BEGIN LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM DR FRANCIS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
RAZA HERE RAZA HERE SENATOR
GROW. SENATOR CORTESE FOUNDER
CORTESE HERE SENATOR NEWMAN
YOUR BANNER NEWMAN HERE. OKAY
QUORUM HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED
OKAY ARE NOW WE WILL BEGIN WITH
OUR ITEMS FOR DISCUSSION- THE
FIRST WE HAVE IS A JUDICIAL
BRANCH TO PRESENT ISSUE TWENTY
ONE REMOTE COURT PROCEEDINGS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US OF WE CAN GET STARTED.
MORNING MADAM CHAIRMAN IMUS'S
LOCK WITH YOUR GARBAGE- FROM
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL I'LL
BRIEFLY INTRODUCE OUR FIRST
<c.red>SSUE AS INDICATED ARE REMOTE</c>
THE COURT PROCEEDINGS TRAILER
BILL THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE-
AUTHORIZING TRUCK WHICH TO
CONDUCT ALL PROCEEDINGS IN
CIVIL CASES REMOTELY WHEN THE
COURT DEEMS IT APPROPRIATE AND
PRACTICABLE- THE- LANGUAGES.
INTENDED TO PROVIDE.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR TRIALS AND
EVIDENTIARY HEARINGS THEIR
LANGUAGE ALSO PROVIDES THE
INTENT THAT THIS AUTHORIZATION
BE INTERPRETED BROADLY TO
PROVIDE SAFE AND RELIABLE
ACCESS TO JUSTICE. ALSO
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET IS-
REMOTE LANGUAGE RELATED TO
INFRACTION CASES. THAT WOULD
ALLOW COURTS TO CONDUCT ALL
PROCEEDINGS IN INFRACTION CASES
REMOTELY UPON CONSENT OF THE
DEFENDANTS. WE HAVE JUDGED ON
TERROR DOES TO TELLS THEIR-
PRESIDING JUDGE OF THE ALAMEDA
SUPERIOR COURT TODAY TO PRESENT
TO YOU THE PERSPECTIVE OF THIS
THESE PROPOSALS ON CORE
OPERATIONS WE ALSO HAVE ROBERT
ROBERT- YOUNG. ARE CHIEF
OPERATIONS OFFICER FROM THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. TO RESPOND
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU OKAY. TOMORROW
MORNING AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
HAVING ME I AM JUDGE TARA DAYS
ARE TELLING THE PRESIDING JUDGE
OF ALAMEDA COUNTY SUPERIOR
COURT I AM ALSO THE VICE CHAIR
OF THE TRIAL COURT JUDGES
ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO SPEAK TO
YOU IN SUPPORT OF THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
AUTHORIZE REMOTE APPEARANCES
AND ALL CIVIL PROCEEDINGS TO
THE EXTENT PRACTICABLE AND
WOULD ALSO AUTHORIZE REMOTE
APPEARANCES IN INFRACTIONS
WHERE THERE IS THE CONSENT. OF
DEFENDANT. NOW IT WAS OVER A
YEAR AGO OF COURSE IN MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY WHERE OUR COURT
LIKE EVERYONE ELSE IN THE STATE
WAS FORCED TO DRAMATICALLY SHUT
DOWN. IN THE FACE OF THE CORONA
VIRUS PANDEMIC. WE STRUGGLED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WITHIN THE
FRAMEWORK OF THE THEN EXISTING
LAWS WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
POTENTIALLY. RE OPEN AND RESUME
SOMETHING CLOSE TO NORMAL COURT
OPERATIONS. HOW WE WERE
ULTIMATELY ABLE TO DO THAT. WAS
THROUGH ABOUT APPEARANCES. IT
WAS IN APRIL OF TWENTY TWENTY
THAT THE CHIEF JUSTICE AND THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA
ENACTED EMERGENCY ROLE NUMBER
THREE. GIVING LOCAL COURTS LIKE
OURS THE AUTHORITY TO MANDATE
REMOTE APPEARANCES IN DIFFERENT
CASE TYPES. WE TOOK ADVANTAGE
OF THAT AUTHORITY IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY AND WE ORDERED REMOTE
APPEARANCES IN ALL NON CRIMINAL
CASE TYPES AND WE AUTHORIZED
REMOTE APPEARANCES IN CRIMINAL
CASE TYPES WITH THE CONSENT OF
THE DEFENDANT. AS THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL HAD SUGGESTED. THE
RESULT WAS A TREMENDOUS
SUCCESS. IT WAS THE ONLY WAY
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO RE OPEN A
MIX SHELTER IN PLACE- NEXT
PANDEMIC SERVICES AND MAINTAIN
COURT OPERATIONS THROUGH OUT.
THIS TUMULTUOUS TIME PERIOD.
NOT ONLY WAS IT A SUCCESS BUT
IN VIEW OF THE FACT THAT WE HAD
ISSUED AN EMERGENCY LOCAL WILL
INITIALLY. THIS PAST YEAR OVER
THE LAST SIX MONTHS WE STARTED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT PERIODS IN
ORDER TO DETERMINE WHETHER A
NON EMERGENCY RULE PROMOTING
REMOTE APPEARANCES WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE AND AFTER
RESOUNDING WORDS IN SUPPORT OF
SUCH ROLE WE ENACTED OUR OWN
NON EMERGENCY RULE PROMOTING
REMOTE APPEARANCES IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT IT BECAME
EFFECTIVE. THIS PAST FEBRUARY
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. NOW WHAT
WE LEARN FROM THESE REMOTE
APPEARANCES SOME OF THE RESULTS
WE EXPECTED SOMEWHERE
UNEXPECTED. THE HUGE BENEFIT IS
ACCESS TO OUR COURTS REMOTE
APPEARANCES PROVIDED TIMELY
CONVENIENT COURT ACCESS TO
LITIGANTS WITHOUT THE NEED TO
TRAVEL TO A COURTHOUSE ACROSS
TOWN. ROSS THE COUNTY WITHOUT
THE NEED TO TRANSFER ON BUSES
OR BARTER DIFFERENT FORMS OF
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION WITHOUT
THE NEED TO TAKE TIME OFF OF
WORK OR SECURE CHILD CARE OR
DEPENDENT CARE WHICH IS
EXCEEDINGLY DIFFICULT DURING
THESE CHALLENGING TIMES THAT WE
HAVE BEEN FACING. IN ADDITION.
IT ENABLED ATTORNEYS TO APPEAR
IN MULTIPLE CASES IN MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE WITH REDUCED COSTS TO
THEIR CLIENT BECAUSE THEY TOO
DID NOT HAVE TO TRAVEL TO
DIFFERENT COURT LOCATIONS AND
DID NOT HAVE TO WAIT. IN COURT
ROOMS UNTIL THEIR CASES WERE
READY TO BE CALL. BUT THERE
WERE ALSO ON THE INTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. WHAT WE
DISCOVERED WAS IN HIGH CONFLICT
AREAS IN PARTICULAR AREAS LIKE
FAMILY LAW AND RESTRAINING
ORDERS REMOTE APPEARANCES
ACTUALLY REDUCED THE CONFLICT
LEVEL IT REDUCED THE LEVEL OF
TENSION. BECAUSE PEOPLE WEREN'T
AFRAID OF COMING INTO COURT
PHYSICALLY AND SITTING ACROSS
CAN'T BE AND AN AGGRESSOR
RENDON SALAS. NOW THERE'S BEEN
SOME SUGGESTION THAT REMOTE
APPEARANCES CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES TO PERSUADE OR
INFLUENCE WITNESSES ON
APPROPRIATELY. UNFORTUNATELY
THE REALITY OF COURT LIFE IS
THESE OPPORTUNITIES ALWAYS
EXIST NOW AS JUDGES WE ARE
TRAINED TO INVESTIGATE YOUR
WEEKEND TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
CORPORATE SEEDINGS ARE FAIR AND
SECURE FROM THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES. BUT WE CAN'T SEE
WHO'S DRIVING A WITNESS TO
COURT ON ANY GIVEN DAY WHETHER
OR NOT THERE'S AN INFLUENTIAL
PARTY WAITING FOR THEM OUTSIDE
OR OTHERWISE PRESENTING ANY
KIND OF THREAT DIRECTOR REPLIED.
IN FACT REMOTE APPEARANCES IN
CONTRAST WITH TELEPHONIC
APPEARANCES WHICH HAVE BEEN
AVAILABLE FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
PROVIDE A GREATER OPPORTUNITY
FOR COURTS TO SEE IF THERE IS
AN INAPPROPRIATE EFFORT TO
INFLUENCE A WITNESS. IN REALITY
THESE REMOTE APPEARANCES HAVE
GIVEN US TRUER TESTIMONY OR AT
LEAST AS TRUE TESTIMONY. AND
BOTH THE JUDGES THE ATTORNEYS
THE PARTIES AND HE LITIGANTS
HAVE CORRESPONDINGLY BENEFIT.
IN ADDITION IN PARTICULARLY
SENSITIVE AREAS THINGS LIKE
JUVENILE CASE TYPES OR
COLLABORATIVE COURTS WE'VE
DISCOVERED THAT REMOTE
APPEARANCES AGAIN IMPROVED THE
COR INTERACTION. THEY ENABLE
THESE MINOR CHILDREN THEY
ENABLE THESE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE GOING THROUGH THE TREATMENT
PROCESS TO MAINTAIN THEIR HOME
OR WORK OR TREATMENT SETTINGS
SO THAT THEY CAN KEEP UP AND ON
INTERRUPTED CONTINUUM OF CARE.
IN ADDITION FOR MANY WHO ARE
SUFFERING FROM MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES PSYCHOLOGICAL DISORDERS
OR POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS COMING
TO COURT ITSELF CAN BE A
TRIGGERING EXPERIENCE THAT CAN
SET BACK. IN THEIR RECOVERY
EFFORTS REMOTE APPEARANCES
REMOVED THAT TRIGGERING
EXPERIENCE BECAUSE IT BRINGS
THE COURT TO THE INDIVIDUAL. WE
ARE ABLE TO MEET INDIVIDUALS
WHERE THEY ARE IN WAYS THAT WE
WERE NEVER ABLE TO DO BEFORE.
AND FINALLY ONE ADDITIONAL
HUGELY IMPORTANT AREA. IS OUR
JURORS WILL LOVE IT. WE HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO REACH MORE JURORS
IN MORE AREAS OF THE COUNTY
BECAUSE THEY TOO DON'T HAVE
THEIR LIVES TO SUBSTANTIALLY
INTERRUPTED AS THEY TRAVEL TO
COURT REQUIRES THEM TO DO. THEY
WILLINGLY AND ACTIVELY
PARTICIPATE IN THESE REMOTE
JURY TRIALS AND IN FACT TALK
VERY FAVORABLY ABOUT THE
PRESENTATION OF EVIDENCE WHERE
EVERYBODY'S ON THE SAME PLAYING
FIELD ASSUMING A BASE
TECHNOLOGICAL PLATFORM. AND HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VIEW THE
WITNESSES AND THE EVIDENCE IN
THE SAME WAY SOMETHING THAT THE
LAY OUT OF OUR OLD PHYSICAL
COURTROOM SIMPLY DON'T AFFORD.
NOW WE ALL KNOW THE COURTS THE
LEGAL SYSTEM OVERALL IN THE
COURTS IN PARTICULAR CAN BE
SLOW TO IMPLEMENT CHANGE AND
THE CORONA VIRUS PANDEMIC
FORCED THIS IMPLEMENTATION AT A
MUCH MORE RAPID RATE. THAN ANY
OF US WOULD HAVE ANTICIPATED.
BUT THE RESULTS AS I SAY HAVE
BEEN TREMENDOUSLY SUCCESSFUL.
AND OUR PEOPLE THE MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY HAVE CONSISTENTLY
ASKED PLEASE KEEP THESE REMOTE
OPPORTUNITIES OPEN. BECAUSE OF
THE EXPANDED ACCESS TO JUSTICE
THAT IT AFFORDS. NOW THERE'S
SOME SUGGESTION AS TO WHETHER
OR NOT A PILOT MIGHT BE
APPROPRIATE OR SOME KIND OF LOS.
IN OUR POSITION. THIS PAST YEAR
HAS BEEN OUR PILOT. AND ANY
KIND OF PAUSE WOULD
UNFORTUNATELY NEGATIVELY AFFECT
THE LITIGANTS AND THE MEMBERS
OF OUR PUBLIC WHO WE ARE VERY
MUCH TRYING TO SEARCH YOUR
SERVICE IS ESSENTIAL TO IN
THESE VERY DIFFICULT TIMES. AND
SO IT'S FOR THESE REASONS THAT
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE AND LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD FURTHER PROMOTE
REPORT HE WON THE APPEARANCES
AND CONTINUE TO EXPAND THE
ACCESS TO OUR COMMUNITY THAT
THESE SERVICES PROVIDE. NOW I
THINK WE HELP ALSO BROUGHT.
WITH US TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON
THIS PAST YEAR. GOOD MORNING
I'M I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE I
THINK THE JUDGE DOES THAT TELL
FOR. ARM HER BACKGROUND BUT I
AM HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE
REGARDING THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. OKAY. WITH YES ARE
THE L. A- DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS. ANNUALLY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
SO IN LOOKING AT THE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE- WE DID THINK THAT
BEAT WE DID FIND THAT THE
EXPANSION OF REMOTE PROCEEDINGS
DOESN'T MERIT LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION BECAUSE OF THE
POTENTIAL BENEFITS RELATED TO
INCREASING EQUITY AND ACCESS TO
THE COURTS REDUCING LITIGATION
COSTS THAT USERS ARE GOING TO
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO PAY. AND
HELPING TO PROCESS CASES MORE
COST EFFECTIVELY HOWEVER- WE
DID NOTE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD WANT TO CONSIDER WHETHER
REMOTE PROCEEDINGS WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE FOR USE IN ALL CASE
TYPES OR PROCEEDINGS. OR
WHETHER STATE LAW SHOULD
INCLUDE CERTAIN MINIMUM
STANDARDS TO ENSURE THAT USERS
ACROSS THE STATE ARE. HAVING
SIMILAR EXPERIENCES. IN
ADDITION I WE FOR THAT PROPOSAL
LINE LACKS SPECIFIC AND USED TO
SIGNIFY EMPLOYEE. DETAILS TO
THE JUDICIAL. AND SO OF THOSE
KEEP ARE OUT ON HUGE. OF YOUR
AGENDA. REMOTE PROCEEDINGS OF
FOR EXAMPLE WOULD IT BE
REQUIRED OR NOT. ANOTHER
QUESTION IS HOW WOULD COURT
PROCESS THESE CHANGE SO WHAT
WOULD BE THE RULES FOR
PROVIDING NOTICE IF YOU DIDN'T
WANT TO IF YOU'RE REMOTELY WHAT
WOULD BE THE RULES FOR REMOTE
DURING TRIALS SIX CETERA. AND
THE THIRD QUESTION LAID OUT
THERE IS WOOD FAIRNESS EQUITY
PRIVACY AND PUBLIC ACCESS
ISSUES BE ADDRESSED AND IN WHAT
MANNER SO FOR EXAMPLE YOU KNOW
WOULD INDIVIDUALS BE ABLE TO
CHOOSE. HER SENTENCE OR WHAT
WITH THAT PROCESS LOOKS LIKE.
IN TURN BECAUSE THERE IS THIS
LACK OF IMPLEMENTATION DETAILS
IT ALSO MEANS THAT THE IMPACTS
ON TRIAL COURT OPERATIONS
PROCESSES AND COSTS ARE
CURRENTLY UNKNOWN BUT COULD BE
SIGNIFICANT. AND SO THE UNKNOWN
IMPACTS INCLUDE HOW MUCH
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME OR ONGOING
TECHNOLOGY RELATED COSTS WOULD
BE NEEDED. WHAT THE NET IMPACT
ON CORE OPERATIONS COST AND
WORKLOAD WOULD BE. THE NET
IMPACT ON CIVIL RELATED COURT
REVENUES THAT CURRENTLY SUPPORT
TRUCK OR OPERATIONS. AS WELL AS
THE IMPACT ON. FACILITY ONLINE
AND WHY OF THE WE HAVE RECORD.
OUR FIRST RECOMMENDATION AS WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECTS THE JUDICIAL BRANCH TO
SUBMIT A DETAILED PLAN FOR HOW
REMOTE PROCEEDINGS WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED BY CASE AND OR
PROCEEDING TYPE. THIS TYPE OF
PLAN WHICH WOULD ADDRESS THOSE
KEY IMPLEMENTATION DETAILS THAT
I BROUGHT UP WOULD HELP THE
LEGISLATURE DETERMINE WHETHER
AND. HOW TO MODIFY THE PROPOSED
LANGUAGE TO ENSURE THAT THE OF
HER CHRISSY WERE FOR WHAT PRIOR.
SUCH AS ON STANDARD. OR A USE
IN CERTAIN CASE TYPE OR- AND
PUTTING THAT IN STATE. THE
SECOND RECOMMENDATION IS IF THE-
WHY TO MOVE FORWARD. FOR ANY
PLAN IS RISK. UNDER THAT'S WE
WOULD RUN THAT THE LET. PILOT
REMOTE PROCEED FOR TWO YEARS.
AND THE LAST. CASE TYPES
PROCEEDING SO FOR EXAMPLE
INFRACTIONS ARE SMALL PLANES
AND REQUIRE AN EVALUATION BY
NOVEMBER FIRST TWO TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. AND SO THE PILOT
AND THE EVALUATION WITH THEN
INFORM LEGISLATIVE DECISIONS ON
WHETHER TO EXTEND EXPAND OR
MODIFY THE AUTHORIZATION ONCE
THE PILOT ENDS. AND SO THIS
TYPE OF APPROACH WOULD ALLOW
FOR IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES TO BE
IDENTIFIED AND RESOLVED IN
AREAS THAT HAVE LESS IMPACT ON
COURTNEY'S OUR LIVES BEFORE
BEING EXPANDED TO MORE COMPLEX
CASE TYPES. AND PROCEEDINGS AS-A MORE MEASURED APPROACH WOULD
HELP MINIMIZE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. AND COSTS. THE
FINAL COMMENT THAT WE WOULD
PROVIDE IS THAT WE ARE AWARE.
THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH OF LEGISLATIVE
STAFF ON THE LANGUAGE OVER THE
PAST COUPLE MONTHS SINCE
LANGUAGE HAS BEEN INTRODUCED.
AND SO DEPENDING ON LEGISLATORS
GOALS THERE ARE CERTAINLY OTHER
OPTIONS THAT COULD BE
CONSIDERED AS WELL SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF THE LEGISLATURE IS
CONCERNED THAT- THE
AUTHORIZATION WHICH IS
AUTHORIZED UNDER THE PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY ROLE WOULD GO AWAY
TOO SOON AND MORE TIME IS
NEEDED. THE LEGISLATURE
CERTAINLY COULD ENACT A STATUTE
TO TEMPORARILY EXTEND. ANOTHER
EXAMPLE IS IF THE LEGISLATURE
THINGS THAT MORE TIME IS NEEDED
TO DISCUSS THE INS AND OUTS
DETAILS OF THIS LANGUAGE
LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO DELAY
ACTING ON THIS LANGUAGE UNTIL
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT LATER INTO
THE SUMMER. AND SO WE WOULD
WHAT WHICH COMPUTER COMMENTS TO
SAY YOU KNOW WE'LL BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE ANY ASSISTANCE- AS A
LEGISLATURE CONTINUES. TO WORK
ON THIS ISSUE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- DEPARTMENT
FINANCE DO YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS. YOUR MIND FINANCE NOT
JUST IN GENERAL THE GOAL WITH
THE LANGUAGES FROM PROMOTE
MODERNIZATION WITHIN CORE
OPERATIONS AND FLEXIBILITY FOR
COURT USERS BY ALLOWING
TRAVELERS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
MAKE USE OF REMOTE TECHNOLOGY
ROLLED OUT DURING THE PANDEMIC.
WE VIEW THIS LANGUAGE IS A
STARTING POINT YOU WILL NEED TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
POTENTIALLY. REFINERY WHICH
THANK YOU. OKAY OF. ALL RIGHT-
QUESTIONS HERE MEMBERS YES
CENTER COURTESY. THE THINK
MINIATURE OF. I CAN SAY I HAVE
A QUESTION KIND OF FRAMED AND
IN MY OWN COMMENTARY AND- I
SUPPOSE IN A PERHAPS PRESIDING
JUDGE MIGHT BE THE BEST PERSON
TO RESPOND TO THEM- OR OR
SOMEONE FROM THAT SIDE. OF BUT
ANYWAY LET ME JUST SAY THIS
FIRST OF ALL- I WAS. AS THE
SOMEONE WHO- CAME HERE AFTER OF
BEING A COUNTY SUPERVISOR FOR A
DOZEN YEARS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
WHAT I'D ACTUALLY DONE WHAT WE
CALL REFERRAL AT ONE TIME TO.
EXPLORE THE POSSIBILITY OF. THE
VIDEO ARRAIGNMENTS- AND REALLY
JUST LIMITING FIVE TO THAT
AREA- MOSTLY BECAUSE THE COST
ESTIMATES IN TERMS OF MOVING
PEOPLE BACK AND FORTH JUST FOR
AGREEMENTS WHICH THOSE OF US
WHO PRACTICE NO IS BASICALLY-
YOU KNOW. MOST OF THE TIME NOT
ALL THE TIME BUT FEEL GUILTY
NOT GUILTY- YOU KNOW OR NO
CONTEST- ON THE ON THE CRIMINAL
SIDE. WAS ABOUT A FORTY MILLION
DOLLAR PRICE TAG PER YEAR- IN
IN THE IDEA OF COURSE WASN'T
NECESSARY TO TAKE THAT OUT OF
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM BUT TO
REINVESTED- IF YOU KNOW IN. IN
AREAS THAT. WERE DEFICIENT-
WHICH COULD BE ANYTHING FROM
COST OF DOING BUSINESS
PERSONAL- A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING I MEAN WHATEVER OR
JUST- YOU KNOW KEEPING THINGS
AFLOAT IN GENERAL- WE NEVER
COMPLETED THAT PROCESS BUT I.
REMAIN VERY INTERESTED IN IT OF
COURSE. AND I'M HERE IN THE
STATE SENATE SO I'M I'M NOT A
VOTING. NUMBER DOWN THERE
ANYMORE ANYWAY BUT I'M I'M
INTRIGUED BY WHAT ALL ME TO
COUNTY IS DONE. BUT I JUST
WANTED TO AGAIN MAKE A COUPLE
OF COMMENTS. I DON'T WANT TO
LISTEN TO THE L. A. O. IT
STRIKES ME THAT WHETHER YOU'RE
ON THE CIVIL SIDE OF THE
CRIMINAL SIDE- THE. THE
COMPLEXITY SHOULD NOT BE LOOKED
AT IN TERMS OF COMPLEXITY OF
THE CASE BUT THE COMPLEXITY OF
THE PROCEEDINGS FOR EXAMPLE YOU
CAN HAVE AN EXTRAORDINARILY
COMPLEX CRIMINAL CASE WITH THE
ARRAIGNMENT IS IT IS GENERALLY
AGAIN GENERALLY- IN EXTREMELY-
NON COMPLEX A PROCEEDING-
WHETHER THE CASES WHETHER THE
UNDERLYING CRIMINAL CASES IS. A
COMPLEX OR NOT YOU KNOW WHETHER
IT'S ALL ON THE SIDE- OR
MISDEMEANOR FELONY OR
MISDEMEANOR SO- ON THE CIVIL
SIDE SIMILARLY- AS SOMEBODY WHO
PRACTICED ON ON THAT SIDE FOR.
SEVERAL YEARS- AND I'LL JUST
I'VE NEVER SAID THIS IN PUBLIC
BUT I BOTH I ALWAYS CONSIDERED
THE CASE MANAGEMENT CONFERENCE
PROCESS TO BE A SORT OF AN
OBNOXIOUS- OFTENTIMES- PROCESS
THAT FELT LIKE. A WASTE OF TOO
MANY PEOPLE'S TIME TO GO DOWN
TO THE COURTHOUSE SUPPOSING ON
CIVIL MATTERS TO GO DOWN THE
COURTHOUSE. YOU KNOW
ESSENTIALLY SIT DOWN FOR A
COUPLE TWO OR THREE HOURS
WAITING YOUR TRN TO PRESENT.
OFTENTIMES FOR UNDER A MINUTE-
VERY IMPORTANT FOR THE JUDGES
TO HAVE THAT PROCESS SO PLEASE
DON'T TAKE THIS THE WRONG WAY-
THOSE THOSE ON THE JUDICIAL
SIDE. BUT NOT SO IMPORTANT FOR
SOMEBODY BE SITTING IN THE BACK
ROW FOR TWO HOURS BUILDING
THEIR CLIENT WAITING OR AN
OPPORTUNITY TO STAND UP AND
SAY- WERE TRYING TO REACH A
SETTLEMENT WE NEED ANOTHER TWO
WEEKS. I MEAN THAT CAN EASILY
BE DONE. REMOTELY HERE AND MUCH
LIKE THE FOLKS THAT COME IN AND
OUT OF OUR HEARINGS NOW UNDER
REMOTE PROCESS. YOU CAN SORT OF
TIME THEIR APPEARANCE FOR WHERE
THEY ARE ON THE DOCKET- WHICH I
THINK YOU KNOW. WHAT WOULD SAVE
CLIENTS MONEY GOOD GOOD
GOVERNMENT GOOD PUBLIC POLICY.
SO I SAID I WOULD ASK A
QUESTION IN THAT CONTEXT AND
THE QUESTION IS. YOU KNOW USER
IS THERE MAY BE. SOME SORT OF
MIDDLE GROUND HERE WHERE YOU
KNOW COUNTIES THAT HAVE
DEVELOPED THE CAPACITY LIKE
ALAMEDA AND THEY'RE ALREADY
SORT OF ROLLING ALONG HAVING A
GREAT EXPERIENCE WITH A MORE
EXPENSIVE VERSION OF REMOTE
COURT PROCEEDINGS- PERHAPS ARE
ALLOWED TO GO FORWARD THROUGH
ONE OF THESE MECHANISMS EVEN IF
THE SYSTEM EXTENSION OF- THAT
OF THE CURRENT. AUTHORITY BUT
IT FOR COUNTIES THAT HAVEN'T
YOU KNOW GOTTEN OUT FOR HE HAD.
MAYBE WE SHOULD BE LOOKING THAT-
SIMILAR TO THE L. A. O. SAID
BUT A LITTLE DIFFERENT- GETTING
INTO NON. I DO NON COMPLEX
PROCEEDINGS- WETHERBY ONE
MOTION OR CASE MANAGEMENT
CONFERENCES THOSE KIND OF IN
AND OUT PROCEEDINGS. THAT ARE
CURRENTLY TAKING UP A LOT OF
CAPACITY IN TIME FROM AN AWFUL
LOT OF PEOPLE OF SO THAT'S SORT
OF MY PREFERENCE I AM A LITTLE
LEERY ABOUT. YOU KNOW IN FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES TO SWOOPING IN
AND SAYING- EVERYBODY- HERE IT
IS PERHAPS SENDING THE MESSAGE
EVEN IF IT'S NOT IN THE STATUTE
ITSELF BUT SENDING THE MESSAGE
THAT- WE WANT YOU TO GO GO FAST
NO MATTER WHAT YOU FEEL YOUR
CURRENT CAPACITY IS. ALL THE
WAY INTO THE TRIAL STAGE IN ON
THE CIVIL CASES- I WOULD
RESPECT SOME DEGREE OF JUDICIAL
CONTROL AND LOCAL CONTROL SO TO
SPEAK- BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT I
COMFORTABLE YET JUST SORT OF
OPENING THAT UP KIND OF OPENING
THE FLOODGATE- I DO THINK THAT.
ON THE ON THE LESS COMPLEX. I
MEAN ON THE MORE COMPLEX- CDNS
THERE'S CONCERN BUT IF YOU JUST
LIMIT TO. INFRACTIONS IN EVERY
COUNTY OR A SMALL CLAIMS I
THINK THE PROBLEM THERE IS THAT
THERE'S SUCH A SMALL SUB SET OF
THE BAR IN THE BENCH THAT ARE
INVOLVED WITH THOSE CASES. THAT
THAT THE 90% OF THE ATTORNEYS
WHO WERE DOING- WHO ARE DOING
CIVIL LITIGATION MISDEMEANORS
FELONIES AND SO FORTH WILL
NEVER GET EXPOSED BECAUSE THEY
DON'T SHOW UP IN SMALL CLAIMS
COURT THEY DON'T SHOW UP- YOU
KNOW IT IN SOME OF THE PREVENT.
FOR INFRACTIONS YOU KNOW IN
MANY COUNTIES OF COURSE THAT'S
THE WHOLE POINT OF AN
INFRACTION THE SAID YOU KNOW
PEOPLE IN POVERTY AND OTHERS
DON'T REALLY HAVE TO LOOK. HE
KNOWS. NECESSARILY EVEN SEEK
OUT COUNCIL SO I DO THINK IF
WE'RE GOING TO RUN EITHER
PILOTS OR SOME LIMITED.
AUTHORITY HERE IT SHOULD BE IN
THESE AREAS WHERE. A MAJORITY
OF THE LITIGATORS- OR OR OR
PROSECUTORS AND DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS SORT OF HAVE TO SHOW
UP ANYWAY TO GET TO GET THE
EXPOSURE. OF AN TO WORK THINGS
OUT AND- YOU KNOW SORT OF RUN
THESE PILOTS AND REPORT BACK AS
TO HOW THEY WORK HOPEFULLY
EVERYBODY COMES BACK AND HAS
THE SAME EXPERIENCE OF. HIS
ALAMEDA BUT I DON'T KNOW. THAT
WOULD BE THE CASE AND IF ANYONE
WANTS TO RESPOND TO THAT YOU
KNOW THAT MY QUESTION IS
ESSENTIALLY IS DOES THAT SOUND.
REASONABLE WHEN YOU START
LOOKING AT THE STATEWIDE
CONTACTS IN. AGAIN I DON'T KNOW
IF THE JUDGE- WOULD BE WILLING
TO RESPOND TO THAT IF NOT
THAT'S FINE. I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO RESPOND AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS. AGREE WITH THEM
COMPLETELY AND I THINK YOUR
OBSERVATIONS ARE BOTH A STUDENT
VERY CONSISTENT. WITH WHAT OUR
CORE USERS HAVE EXPERIENCED
WHILE WE'VE BEEN IN A REMOTE
OPERATIONS AFTER HAVING BEEN IN
PERSON. IN TERMS OF CRIMINAL
ARRAIGNMENTS WE ACTUALLY FIRST
SET UP A REMOTE VIDEO
ARRAIGNMENT COURT. IN THE LATE
NINETIES SERU HARD LINE NOW
THAT WAS DISCONTINUED OVERTIME
IN AROUND TWENTY TEN. AND WAS
NOT REACTIVATED UNTIL WE
RECONNECTED THOSE HARD LINES
THIS YEAR WITH THE CORONA VIRUS
PANDEMIC. AND WE DID EXACTLY
FOR THE REASON THAT YOU STATED.
IT WAS SIMPLY UNSAFE TO
TRANSPORT INMATES FORTY FIVE
MINUTES TO AN HOUR AND A HALF
ACROSS COUNTY. FOR A THIRTY
SECOND ARRAIGNMENT WHEN THEY
COULD APPEAR FROM THE JAIL
REMOTELY AND IN FACT HAVE
GREATER ACCESS TO OUR RESOURCES
MUCH MORE EFFICIENT ACCESS THEN
AND THERE. SIMILARLY ON THE
CIVIL SCENARIOS IT AVOIDS
EXACTLY WHAT YOU TALK ABOUT.
THE LONG DELAYED WAIT FOR A
VERY SHORT COURT APPEARANCE. IN
TERMS OF. HOW THIS WOULD MANAGE
ON A STATEWIDE LEVEL THERE'S A
HUGE DISTINCTION IN THE
LANGUAGE OF THE TRAILER BILL
THAT MAKES THE DIFFERENCE NOT
ALL COURTS ARE SIMILARLY
SITUATED AND OF COURSE IN ORDER
TO MAKE REMOTE TECHNOLOGY WORK
YOU NEED TO HAVE THE BEST
TECHNOLOGY AVAILABLE. WE IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY WERE FORTUNATE
IN THAT WERE A RELATIVELY URBAN
ENVIRONMENT DEPENDING ON WHERE
YOU ARE IN THE COUNTY AND WE
HAVE FAIRLY CONSISTENT WIFI AND
INTERNET ACCESS. FOR ALMOST
EVERYBODY WHO USES OUR COURTS
AND WE PROVIDE ALTERNATIVES FOR
THOSE THAT NEED ALTERNATIVES.
RURAL AREAS MAYBE DIFFERENTLY
SITUATED. AND WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THE EMERGENCY RULES AS
EMERGENCY ROLE THREE
AUTHORIZED. EACH LOCAL SUPERIOR
COURT TO CREATE ITS OWN LOCAL
EMERGENCY RULES BASED ON THE
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY. IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY WE MAY PROMOTE
APPEARANCES AS I SAID MANDATORY
IN THOSE NON CRIMINAL CASE
TYPES BECAUSE IT WAS THE ONLY
WAY WE COULD OPEN IT WAS THE
ONLY WAY WE CAN SERVE THE
PUBLIC AND WE BELIEVED WE HAD A
PLATFORM AND THE ALTERNATIVES.
AVAILABLE TO MAKE IT HAPPEN.
NOT EVERYBODY IS SIMILARLY
SITUATED OR IS ABLE TO DO THAT.
THAT'S WHY THE TRAILER LANGUAGE
THAT WE HAVE HERE IS PERMISSIVE.
SO IT WOULD GIVE THE COURTS
THAT FLEXIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
ONLY THOSE THAT WERE READY TO
PROCEED. CAN CHRISSY. NOW I'M
NOT SURE THAT THAT ANSWERED ALL
OF YOUR QUESTIONS BUT I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER. OR FOLLOW UP IN AN
AREA THAT I MIGHT HAVE MISSED-
I JUST APPRECIATE THE I WAS
JUST LOOKING FOR EITHER
AFFIRMATION OR- REJECTION OF
SOME OF THOSE THOUGHTS AND IT
SOUNDS LIKE GENERALLY SPEAKING-
IT LEAST- FROM THE JUDGE'S
PERSPECTIVE- MY THOUGHTS ARE ON
TRACK BUT THAT'S- THAT'S ALL
EFFORT. I DON'T WANT TO. OVER
EXTEND THE HEARING- IN IN MADAM
CHAIR I CERTAINLY- YOU KNOW
DEFERRED TO YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND- WHATEVER THOUGHTS RISK
COMMITTEE HAS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SENATOR. THE NEWMAN THANK
YOU MEASURE SO IT APPRECIATE
THE DISCUSSION SO FAR MY
QUESTION KIND OF BILLS ON THAT
IS SPECIFICALLY AROUND A JURY
TRIALS DONE REMOTELY YEAH AND
MY UNDERSTANDING DID INTO MY
CORRECTED THIS IS PART OF THE
PILOT MIGHT ACTUALLY- INCLUDE
DURING DOING AT LEAST CIVIL.
JURY TRIALS ARE MELISSA CORRECT.
WELL I THINK. I SHOULD HAVE
SOMEBODY I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
I'M ON THE RIGHT- WHAT TE
LANGUAGE AUTHORIZES IS IT GIVES
THE FLEXIBILITY. FOR INDIVIDUAL
COURTS TO AUTHORIZE REMOTE
APPEARANCES IN DIFFERENT CASE
TYPES AND IN DIFFERENT
PROCEEDINGS BASED ON THE NEEDS
OF EACH COURT. TO THAT THAT
WOULD AT LEAST THEORETICALLY
AND INCLUDE THE POSSIBILITY OF
FUTURE PARTICIPATION MOMENT
CIGARETTE CORRECT AND IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY WE HAVE BEEN
OPERATING OUR CIVIL JURY TRIALS
REMOTELY FROM START TO FINISH.
INCLUDING THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
JURORS TO COME IN FOR THAT
FIRST APPEARANCE INSTEAD OF
PHYSICALLY AT THE COURTHOUSE.
THEY CAN APPEAR FROM THEIR HOME
LOCATION THEIR OFFICE WHEREVER
IS MORE CONVENIENT FOR THEM. SO
IT MADE IT REALLY IS
INTERESTING SO WE'VE ALL HAD
KIND OF ASSUME. THE CRASH
COURSE IN LIVING BECAUSE HIM.
AND SOMETHING'S TO CENTER
CORTESE'S POINT WORK EMILY
WELL. USING NO TECHNOLOGY IN
OTHER THINGS- YOU MIGHT ARGUE
ARE ARE INTRINSICALLY DIFFERENT
AND WHEN ONE OF THOSE THINGS
MIGHT BE JURY TRIALS RIGHT
WHERE THERE'S A LOT OF.
NONVERBAL COMMUNICATION WHERE
PHYSICAL PROXIMITY IS PROBABLY.
AT LEAST TRADITIONALLY BEEN
PART OF THE EXPERIENCE IN THE
BASIS THAT I THINK FOR BOTH
SIDES. WHAT'S THE STANDARD.
MOVING FORWARD WHETHER YOU KNOW
WE CAN ARRIVE AT CONSENSUS
WHETHER IT KIND OF WORKS OR
DOESN'T WORK. THE. ACROSS
DIFFERENT KOREJE. AND ANYBODY
ELSE ANY SO THIS IS. AGAIN THIS
IS ROBERT A YOUNG FROM THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. I'D ALSO LIKE
TO. RESPOND SENATOR CORTE-
QUESTION- AND I'M ACTUALLY GLAD
THAT YOU BROUGHT UP THE-
EXAMPLE OF THE- SANTA CLARA
ARRANGEMENTS BECAUSE WHEN THAT
ACTIVITY WAS HAPPENING I WAS
ACTUALLY THE CHIEF INFORMATION
OFFICER AT THE SANTA CLARA
COURT BY LOOKING AT HELPING TO
IMPLEMENT. VIDEO ARRAIGNMENTS-
AT SANTA CLARA AND I WAS ALSO
VERY DISAPPOINTED THAT THAT WAS
I'M NOT ABLE TO BE IMPLEMENTED
BECAUSE WE SAW THAT THERE WOULD
BE A HUGE BENEFIT AND IN DOING
THAT. I'M IN TERMS OF THE
READINESS OF THE COURTS AND-
THE L. A. O.'S- SUGGESTION
AROUND A PILOT AND THIS
DISCUSSION AS WELL. AROUND THE
A PILOT- IN FACT WE ALREADY
HAVE FIFTY FOUR COURTS TO HAVE
REMOTE PRECEDING CAPABILITY IN
AT LEAST ONE CASE TYPE ARE WE
HAVE ACTUALLY THIRTY EIGHT
COURTS MORE THAN HALF OF THE
COURT- HAVE REMOTE CAPABILITIES
IN ALL CASE TYPES AND SO. WE
THE EXAMPLE THAT CHURCH STATES
THAT TELLS- HAS. VERY
ELOQUENTLY- DESCRIBED IN
ALAMEDA IS A SITUATION IN MANY
OF OUR COURTS RIGHT NOW- AND SO
WE ARE PROVIDING SERVICE. TO
THE PUBLIC IN THIS MANNER- AND
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY
WITH INTERESTED PARTIES AND
GETTING THEIR FEEDBACK ARE
REGARDING WHAT'S WORKING WHAT'S
NOT WORKING IN ORDER FOR US TO
ENHANCE OUR PROCESSES TO
IMPROVE THAT OVERALL SERVICE. I
AM THE SUGGESTIONS THAT THE L.
A. O. HAS MAKE A REGARDING. THE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN QUESTIONS
THAT SHE HOMBRES THOSE ARE
ACTUALLY ALL QUESTIONS THAT
WOULD BE ANSWERED THROUGH OUR
STANDARD RULES MAKING PROCESS
SO THROUGH THE RULES OF COURT-
ALL THE QUESTIONS THAT THE L.
A. L. HAS RAISED- WE WOULD GO
THROUGH THAT PROCESS- WHICH
WOULD INCLUDE OUR- COMMITTEES.
AS WELL AS EXTENSIVE PUBLIC
COMMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE-
PROVIDING BALANCED. RULES THAT
ADDRESS ALL THE NEEDS OF THE
POOR. BUT IN- YOU KNOW FORM-
BOTTOM FIRST. MAKING THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING TO JUSTICE IN A VERY
SAFE AND EFFICIENT MANNER.
ANYMORE QUESTIONS CENTER NEW NO
OKAY- THEY HAVE THE HANDLE OKAY
BELIAU PLEASE CONSUME. I'M
ANNUALLY WITH THE L. A. S. SO-
A COUPLE OF PIECES OF TIME BACK
TO SENATOR NEWMAN QUESTIONS SO
THE FIRST ISSUE IS FROM THE
COURTS IN VERY QUICKLY DURING
THE PANDEMIC AND I AND I AND I
WON IT WAS LIKE THEY DID LOTS
OF THINGS WERE EMPLOYED. AND I
THINK THE CHALLENGE ON THAT ONE
IS DIFFERENT COURTS ARE DOING
THINGS IN IN DIFFERENT WAYS AND
THERE IS NOT A GREAT ASSESSMENT
OF WHAT THOSE SIMILARITIES AND
DIFFERENCES R. AS WELL AS SORT
OF A- OF HOW THINGS ARE GOING I
THINK THAT'S KIND OF ONE. PIECE
THAT I WOULD LAY OUT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND SO PART OF THE
CONCEPT IN TERMS OF THE PLAN OR
OR EVEN A PILOT SO UNDER
RECOGNITION OF PILOT IT IS
CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT COULD
BE TESTED AND EVALUATED ON A
MORE ROBUST BASIS TO THEN
INFORM DECISIONS MOVING
FORWARD. THE SECOND ISSUE IS-
YOU KNOW MISTER- AND MENTIONED
THAT THE JUDICIAL BRANCH IS
PLANNING ON DEVELOPING RULES OF
CORE IN FLUSHING OUT SOME OF
THOSE KEY IMPLEMENTATION
QUESTIONS I THINK IT'S
CERTAINLY TRUE THAT THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH WILL HAVE
QUESTIONS AS SORRY IT WILL HAVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT AND
VERY THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATIONS
OUR CONCERN IS BASICALLY THAT
THE LEGISLATURE AND THEIR ROLE.
WOULD LIKELY WANT TO HAVE IN
PLACE ON SOME OF THOSE KEY
IMPLEMENTATION DETAILS AND SO
IT IS A POLICY DECISION FOR
EXAMPLE ON WHETHER OR NOT THERE
SHOULD BE CERTAIN MINIMUM
STANDARDS TO ENSURE THAT THE
DIFFERENCES FROM COUNTY TO
COUNTY ARE NOT TOO EXTREME- AND
SO THAT COULD FOR EXAMPLE
INCLUDE JUST MINIMUM STANDARDS
RELATED TO TECHNOLOGY MINIMUM
STANDARDS RELATED TO RULES N
TERMS OF WHAT PROCEEDINGS THAT
IS APPROPRIATE AND ARE NOT
APPROPRIATE. FOR EXAMPLE SO I
THINK THAT THOSE ARE JUST A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS WE WANTED.
TO ADD SO THANK YOU. BUT SO
THANK MY WRITER. THANK YOU- I
AM- A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
BEFORE MY COM. A THE EMERGING
ROOM. AND THE TIME MEAN AROUND
THE RAY OF THE EMERGENCY RULE
MAYBE. OF WHOEVER THE L. A. O.
OR THE JUDICIAL BRANCH- COULD
EXPLAIN THAT BECAUSE WHAT WE DO
HAVE A RULE IN PLACE. AS AN
EMERGENCY RULE FOR A CERTAIN
LENGTH OF TIME- THAT HAS
ALLOWED ENOUGH FLEXIBILITY
BECAUSE OF THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC ON OUR COMMUNITIES- SO
IF SOMEONE COULD ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. YES SO THIS IS-
ROBERT A YOUNG FROM JUDICIAL
COUNCIL SO THE EMERGENCY RULE
RIGHT NOW- IS REMAINING WILL
REMAIN IN EFFECT. UNTIL NINETY
DAYS AFTER THE GOVERNOR
DECLARES. THAT THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY RELATED TO THE
PANDEMIC IS LIFTED. OR AND
CHILLED THE RULES IS AMENDED OR
REPEALED BY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL- AND THAT'S NOT TO SAY
THAT. ARE THE PROBLEM A STATE
OF EMERGENCY SHOULD NOT BE
CONFUSED WITH THE ELIMINATION
OF THE TIER SYSTEM THAT'S
COMING UP ON JUNE FIFTEENTH.
OKAY SO THERE IS NO CURRENT
DATE FOR THE OBVIOUSLY FOR THE
MERGES C. TO BE LIFTED. AND IT
WOULD BE NINETY DAYS AFTER
THAT. CORRECT SO. IT WOULD BE
UNFAIR TO SAY THAT WE HAVE AT
LEAST. SIX MONTHS NINE MONTHS
TWELVE MONTHS. IS THAT A. IS IT
UNFAIR TO COME UP WITH A ROUGH
DATE AS TO WHEN THIS COULD BE A
MERGING ZERO COULD BE LIFTED. I
WOULD BE VERY VERY HESITANT TO
GUESS AS TO WHEN THE GOVERNOR
WOULD DECLARE THAT THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY WOULD BE LIFTED YEAH
YEP YOU'RE RIGHT- WELL I AND I
THINK THAT THERE ARE. OBVIOUSLY
WE WERE ALL. SORT OF WRITING
THE NEW RULES AS WE WENT ALONG.
LIKE NOBODY SAID OKAY FOR THE
NEXT SIX MONTHS I KNOW THIS IS
GOING TO HAPPEN I KNOW WHAT THE
IMPACT IT'S GOING TO BE SO
LET'S DO IT THIS WAY. AND I BET
IT WAS AT TIMES ON A DAILY
BASIS AT TIMES ON A WEEKLY
BASIS. BUT THERE WAS THIS
CONSTANT HOW DO WE DO THIS
WE'RE DOING THIS GOOD THIS IS
NOT WORKING- AND THAT'S WHAT
SORT OF- MAKES ME HESITATE.
THAT THE EXPERIENCE HAS BEEN
DONE UNDER THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES
VERSUS THINKING ABOUT HIM ON A
PERMANENT BASIS. AND THE
DELIBERATE INVOLVEMENT AND
INTEGRATION OF A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDERS- THE EMPLOYEES WHO
WORK IN THOSE COURTS. THE
PEOPLE WHO USE THE COURT
SERVICES- WHAT IS A WE'RE STILL
DEALING WITH THIS WHEN IT COMES
TO EVERYTHING ELSE IN OUR LIVES
IS ACCESS TO CONNECTIVITY.
ACCESS TO THE DEVICES- AND I
THINK THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT CERTAINLY COME UP
BETWEEN RURAL AND URBAN AREAS
BUT EVEN WITHIN URBAN AREAS-
IT'S NOT LIKE ACCESS AND
CONNECTIVITY IS SO PERFECT NOW.
SO I HAVE SOME REAL CONCERNS
ABOUT USING THE EXPERIENCE.
THAT WE WENT THROUGH AS THE
EXCLUSIVE WAY TO DECIDE WHAT WE
SHOULD DO MOVING FORWARD
PERMANENTLY AND ALSO
ENCOMPASSING. THE WAY THAT IS
BEING- PROPOSED HERE- YOU KNOW
THERE'S ISSUES OF PUBLIC SAFETY
THE PRIVACY OF THE INDIVIDUALS-
YOU KNOW IF SOMEBODY'S BEEN
DECIDE OKAY TOLD YOU COULD DO
IT FROM HOME. WHAT KIND OF
PRIVACY DO YOU HAVE IF YOU'RE
DOING IT FROM HOME- SO- AND
THAT COULD LEAD TO THE SAFETY
ISSUES- SO I HAVE A SOME REAL
CONCERNS I DO THINK THAT. IT WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT A COMPLETELY
REVAMPING. THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
NOT THE LAWS THAT GOVERN THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM BUT HOW PEOPLE
RELATE TO THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
THE THEIR OWN PERSPECTIVE ON
HAVING ACCESS TO THE JUDICIAL
SYSTEM I THINK ALL OF THAT
WE'RE BEING ASKED AS THE
LEGISLATURE. TO COMPLETELY
REVAMP EVERYTHING. AND WITHOUT
HAVING HAD I THINK THE THOROUGH
CONVERSATION OF WHAT THAT MEANS
WELL WITH THE KIND OF A PLAN
THAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE TO DO
THAT- THERE'S IT'S LIKE. YOU
KNOW REMOTE LEARNING WHAT WE
FIND OUT ABOUT THAT- WHAT
WORKED AND WHAT DIDN'T HOW LONG
WOULD IT TAKE I MEAN WE'RE
STILL WORKING THAT IT BESIDES
MAKING A PERMANENT DECISION SO.
IDEA I WOULD- I PERSONALLY.
THAT THE IMPLEMENTATION A PLAN
SO THAT WE COULD DISCUSS OF THE
LEGISLATURE. IS IS THE BEST WAY
TO GO INCORPORATING THE
EXPERIENCES UP UNTIL NOW- I
THINK THERE'S JUST FAR TOO MANY
ISSUES THAT HAVEN'T BEEN
EXPLAINED AND PUT FORWARD- AND
I'M YOU KNOW COUNTY NON.
EMPLOYEES WHO MAKE THIS WORK I
GOT A LOT OF COMMENTS ABOUT ALL
THE ISSUES THAT COME UP FROM.
MORE REPORTERS- AND- THEIR
INABILITY TO DISTINGUISH WHEN
THERE'S A CAMERA MICROPHONE
DEPENDING ON WHERE IT'S PLACED
WE'VE HEARD FROM INTERPRETERS
WILL FIND HOW DIFFICULT IT IS
TO HEAR- SOMETIMES LAWYERS
TALKING OVER THEMSELVES I MEAN
THEY'RE ALL SORTS OF THINGS
THAT HAPPEN IN THE REAL WORLD
DAY TO DAY. THAT I THINK NEED
TO BE REALLY- ARE MUCH MORE
THOUGHTFUL BUT WE DECIDE ON
HAVING A PERMANENT AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS A PERMANENT AS-
THAT'S BEEN PROPOSED- CENTER
GROVE ANY. AUSTIN'S ARE
COMMENTS MADAM CHAIR I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
APOLOGIZE FOR BEING LATE I'M
KIND OF BOUNCING AROUND TODAY
AND COMMITTEES OF I THINK THAT
WE LEARNED A LOT FROM COLLUDED-
THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT WE
LEARNED THAT WERE VERY POSITIVE
AND SOME TINGS THAT WERE VERY
NEGATIVE THE IMPACT ON OUR
CHILDREN FOR INSTANCE WAS
NEGATIVE- BUT- YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU TAKE. M. VINO VIRTUAL VISIT
VIRTUAL VISITS FROM DOCTORS- TO
BE ABLE TO ASSESS SOME SOME
SITUATIONS WITH THEIR PATIENTS
IT. SEES THE PATIENTS FROM
TRAVELLING AND BACK AND FORTH
AND I THINK THAT APPLIES HERE
TO THE COURT SYSTEM. NGUYEN WE
CAN USE A VIRTUAL APPEARANCES
AND DO SOME VIRTUAL CHANGES AND
LEARN WHAT WORKED WELL IN THE
COURT SYSTEM FOR COATED. AND
APPLY THOSE PROCESSES MOVING
FORWARD I THINK IT'S A COST
SAVING MEASURE. IT'S A SECURITY
MEASURE THAT HELPS YOU'RE NOT
TRANSPORTING AN INDIVIDUAL
INMATES FROM. THE SYSTEM INTO
THE COURTHOUSE- THERE'S A LOT
OF THINGS THAT WE LEARNED FROM
CO BUT THAT WOULD BE GOOD- IF
IMPLEMENTED BECAUSE WE WERE
FORCED TO IMPLEMENT THEM UNDER
THE COVER NINETEEN RESPONSE
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAD- SO I DO
THINK THAT IS SOMETHING WE
SHOULD DEFINITELY LOOK AT WE
SHOULD DEFINITELY- IMPLEMENT
WHAT WAS GOOD. THATWE LEARN
FROM THIS COVERED SITUATION AND
THEN NOT IMPLEMENT WORKED IS-
YOU KNOW WHAT WOULD BE
TRADITIONALLY SOMETHING BAD.
THANK YOU FOR A MAKE A COMMENT.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT- SOMEONE
ELSE WANTS TO SPEAK OKAY. YOUR
OF IS THAT YOU DON'T START I
WAS LOOKING UP AT THE LIBERTY
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU'RE NOT USED TO FIFTH POINT
FOR THIS GOOD POINT OKAY YES
CENTER FOR DISEASE- THANK YOU
FOR ALL YOU. COM I THINK IT
THERE IS- SPOKE HUMAN CENTER
NEWMAN INDICATED WE'VE HAD OUR
OWN LEGISLATIVE EXPERIENCE
WITH. A LOT OF THINGS GOING
RIGHT AND THEN SOME THINGS. AND
I THINK INTERPRETERS HAVE BEEN
ONE OF THE EXAMPLES IT'S HARD
FOR. HER TO STEP IN AND SORT
THAT OUT SOMETIMES WHEN IT'S
REMOTES WILL BE INTERESTING TO
HEAR MORE ABOUT THAT ON SINCE
WORD THE BUDGET. COMMITTEE
BASICALLY- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WOULD BE. OF INTEREST TO
ME GOING FORWARD IN TERMS OF A
REQUEST FOR INFORMATION IS WITH
THESE THIRTY EIGHT COURTS THAT
HAVE GONE. ALL THE WAY SO TO
SPEAK IN IN IN EVEN THE FIFTY
FOUR. WHO ARE. NOT NECESSARILY-
ALL THE WAY- IF THAT WAS THE
RIGHT NUMBER BUT THE- THE
QUESTION IS. HOW THE- HOW WOULD
OF THE DONE WITH THE SAVINGS-
IN IT IN AB I FULLY UNDERSTAND
THAT THE COURT SYSTEM HAS HAD.
IT'S CHALLENGES ALMOST ACROSS
THE BOARD IN TERMS OF- BUDGET
THEIR OWN BUDGET IMPACT RATE-
IS THERE NEED FOR RESOURCES SO
I DON'T SUGGESTS. THAT THERE
THERE IS A PLENTY OF NEED I
JUST DON'T KNOW GIVEN ALL THE
NEEDS. YOU KNOW HOW SOME OF
THOSE COUNTIES- COURT SYSTEMS
MADE THE DECISION OR WHETHER
THAT WAS MADE YOU KNOW FOR ME
SOMEHOW AT THE STATE LEVEL. I
DON'T NEED AN ANSWER NOW. I
JUST THINK IT WOULD BE HELPFUL
FOR US AND YOU TALKED ABOUT-
WHAT HAPPENS IN TERMS OF-
WORKFORCE TRANSITION FOR
EXAMPLE- IN I THINK. AS WE ALL
KNOW FOR THE MONEY RIGHT IF
THAT WAS ADDRESSED WITH SOME OF
THE COST SAVINGS TO REDEPLOY
PEOPLE FOR EXAMPLE I THINK IT
WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR. US TO
KNOW THAT- BEFORE YOU KNOW ANY
KIND OF- TRAILER BILL OR
AUTHORIZATION GOES OUT THERE SO
IT'S THIS IS REALLY JUST A
REQUEST FOR INFORMATION IF
YOU'RE WILLING TO. ENDORSE
THAT- APPS- COMMITTEE STAFF CAN
ASSIST WITH THAT THANK YOU
ABSOLUTELY YES WE WILL. WE WILL
SEE TO FIGURE THAT OUT AND
GATHER THAT INFORMATION THANKS
OKAY IF THERE ARE NO MORE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SOMEBODY
ELSE HAD THEIR HAND. YES THIS
IS ROBERT A YOUNG PHARMACISTS
COUNCIL GO AHEAD. YOU ARE SO I
DID WANT TO ADDRESS A COUPLE OF
THE QUESTIONS FROM BOTH- THAT
YOU HAD MENTIONED SENATOR DRAWS
AS WELL AS A SENATOR. CORTESE
REGARDING- COST SAVINGS ACCOUNT
AT THIS POINT WE HAVE NOT
IDENTIFIED ANY COST SAVINGS ARE
RELATED TO REMOTE HEARINGS- IN
IN FACT BY THE COURTS REALLY
HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING AS YOU
HAVE MENTIONED. AS A RESULT OF.
THE 10% BUDGET CUTS OUT LAST
YEAR. AND THE FUNDING- THAT
THEY CURRENTLY HAVE. THAT'S WHY
WE REALLY ARE PUTTING A LOT OF
SUPPORT TOWARDS THE GOVERNOR'S
EXISTING- BUDGET PROPOSAL AS
AMENDED- WITH RESTORATION OF
THAT BUDGET AS WELL AS-
ADDITIONAL SEVENTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ONGOING SUPPORT.
FOR OPERATIONS- IN TERMS OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION AT EACH OF THE
COURTS ARE REALLY IT WAS A
PRACTICAL WAY IMPLEMENTING
REMOTE PROCEEDINGS WITH A
PRACTICAL WAY TO CONTINUE TO.
KEEP PROVIDING ACCESS TO
JUSTICE TO THEIR CITIZENS AND
SO- YOU KNOW THE BIGGEST DRIVER
WAS TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT- AND
IN FACT LAST YEAR WE DID
RECEIVE. A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AS PART OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE BUDGET FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OVER TWO YEARS-
AS PART OF OUR MODERNIZATION
FUNDING AND SO WE THE COURTS
WERE ABLE TO UTILIZE THAT
MONEY. IN ORDER TO DEPLOY-
VIDEO SYSTEMS ARE THROUGHOUT
THE COURTS AND SO. THAT IS A
LIMITED AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT-
DOES- IS ONLY AVAILABLE FOR TWO
YEARS- SO IF THERE ARE GOING TO
BE FUTURE BUDGETARY NEEDS HOW
WE WILL WORK THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS- TO REQUEST THOSE BUT
AT THIS POINT WE'RE NOT
REQUESTING ANY ADDITIONAL
FUNDS- AND WE'RE NOT SEEING-
SAVINGS IN PARTICULAR. ARE
REGARDING- PERSONNEL- WE HAVE
NOT HAD ANY JOB LOSSES RELATED
TO THE MOVEMENT TO REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS AND IN FACT WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN AS WE'VE SEEN. NEW
JOB OPPORTUNITIES ARISE AS WE
ADDED THESE NEW SERVICES SO FOR
EXAMPLE- HAS VIDEO COORDINATORS
ARE NEEDED- WE NEED PEOPLE. NOW
TO PROVIDE A TECHNICAL- SUPPORT
TO THE- AT YOU'RE USING MORE
AND MORE TECH. AND SO WE SEE
THERE'S A MORE. FOR PEOPLE AND
FOR STAFF AS WE DEPLOY ON THESE
NEW SERVICES. AND THEN GOING
BACK TO SENATOR DRAWS THOSE
QUESTION AROUND- A LITTLE BIT
OF HESITANCY. RELATED TO-
DRAWING FROM THE EXPERIENCE
FROM THE PANDEMIC FOR A LONG
TERM DEPLOYMENT- WE FULLY
UNDERSTAND THAT HOWEVER I VIDEO
REMOTE HEARINGS HAS BEEN ON OUR
ROAD MAP. AND ON OUR STRATEGIC
PLAN NOW FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND
SO WE HAVE ACTUALLY HAD- MANY
BEST PRACTICES WE ACTUALLY HAVE
A VIDEO REMOTE INTERPRETING
GUIDE- THAT HAS SOME GUIDELINES
AND RECOMMENDATIONS REGARDING.
VIDEO REMOTE INTERPRETING- WE
HAVE PUBLISHED ARE A PANDEMIC
CONTINUITY OF OPERATIONS-
RESOURCE GUIDE WHICH INCLUDES
SECTIONS ON REMOTE HEARINGS.
AND SO WE HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN
PLANNING AND LOOKING AT OUR
INCLUDING THIS SERVICE AS PART
OF THE STANDARD OFFERINGS ARE
FROM THE COURTS. FOR MANY YEARS
AND SO THE PANDEMIC WAS
ACTUALLY AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO ACCELERATE THE EXISTING
PLAN- THAT THAT WE ALREADY HAD
AND TO PROVE OUT SOME OF THE
CONCEPTS- AND SOME OF THE
PROCESSES THAT. WE HAD IN PLACE
ARE YOU ALSO MENTIONED SOME
CONCERNS AROUND- PRIVACY THINGS
LIKE THAT- THOSE TYPES OF
ISSUES ACTUALLY ALREADY
OCCURRENCE JUDGE THEY SETTLE
HAD ENTIONED. IN OUR IN
PERSON- PROCEEDINGS AND SO WE
DO HAVE AN EXISTING TRAININGS
REGARDING. DECORUM OUR PRIVACY-
CONFIDENTIALITY THROUGH OUR
WITKIN'S COLLEGE- THAT BE OUR
JUDGES MUST ATTEND AND SO WE
CONTINUALLY INVOLVED THAT-
CURRICULUM AND THE TRAINING
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO OUR
JUDICIAL OFFICERS. AS WELL AS
TO STAFF TO ENHANCE- THE COURT
OUR EXPERIENCE AND TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS- PRIVACY- AND-
OTHER- CONSIDERATIONS. ARE
TAKEN INTO PORT. THANK VERY
MUCH STERN. ANYONE ELSE. NO
MEMBERS REAL GOOD OKAY THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
ALL THE INFORMATION THAT YOU
PROVIDED FOR US TODAY. R. NOW
WE MOVE ON TO ISSUE TWENTY TWO
OUR RECIDIVISM REDUCTION
STRATEGIES THROUGH OUR
COLLABORATIVE COURTS. I THINK
WE HAVE JUDGE BLOODY ANNALS. WE
DO THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR AND- THANK
SUB COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE IN- BE IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY- I AM THE
CHAIR OF THE COLLABORATIVE
JUSTICE ADVISORY COMMITTEE
COPTERS AS COURTS OF ARCHERY
COMMITTEE TO THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL I ALSO HAVE THE HONOR
AND PRIVILEGE OF BEING A
JUDICIAL OUTREACH LIAISON FOR
THE- AMERICAN BAR ASSOCIATION
FOR REGION REGION NINE. AND
THIS IS A TOPIC THAT IS REALLY
EXCITING TO ME JUST BECAUSE OF
THE MOVEMENT IT WHERE WE ARE
WITH COLOR WITH COLLABORATIVE
COURTS- SO ONE THING WE REALIZE
WHAT AMERICA SUBSTANCE ABUSE
AND CLUBCORP STARTED AROUND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE- AS A DRIVER OF
MANY OF THE ISSUES THAT BRING
PEOPLE THROUGH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. I MEAN WE'RE
STARTING TO LEARN THAT THERE
ARE A LOT OF OTHER ISSUES
BEYOND SUBSTANCE ABUSE OR
MENTAL HEALTH IS ANOTHER ISSUE
THAT'S COME UP THAT IS HUGE IN
DRIVES THE BEHAVIOR THAT BRINGS
PEOPLE IN INTO OUR SYSTEM
HOMELESSNESS IS HUGE ON THAT
ISSUE COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL
ISSUES ARE ARE HUGE ON THAT
ISSUE. SO WE'RE STARTING TO
REALIZE IT AS AS A GROUP THAT
THAT THERE ARE ALL OF THESE
ISSUES OUT THERE THAT WE CAN
THAT WE CAN DEAL WITH- OUR CLUB
RECORDS WORK BUT CUTS ON USERS
OF THE COURT SUPERVISION
SUPERVISION AS PART OF
PROBATION COMMUNITY SUPERVISION
OR PAROLE TO DO AFFECTED THINGS
WITH INDIVIDUALS SO WE CAN DO
DIAGNOSTICS SO IS INDIVIDUALS
COME THROUGH THE SYSTEM WE HAVE
AN INCREDIBLE DIAGNOSTIC TOOL
SCREENING TOOLS AND ASSESSMENT
TOOLS. TO BE ABLE TO DIAGNOSE
WHAT THOSE INJURIES ARE AND WE
CAN ACTUALLY TAKE THOSE
INJURIES AND MOVE FORWARD WITH
THEM WITH REFERRALS AND THEN
YOU COMBINE THAT. WITH THE USE
OF ACCOUNTABILITY ON ON THE END
AS PART OF SUPERVISION- AND
THAT KIND OF STE CARRENTALS
TYPE OF AUTHORITY TO THE JUDGE
HOUSE IN THAT SUPERVISION MODE-
TO ACTUALLY EFFECTIVELY CHANGE
BEHAVIOR. I WILL TO REFER TO IT
AS WELL WE'RE DOING WHEN I'M-
WHEN I'M IN THERE THAT CORE. IS
E. R. DIAGNOSE THIS ISN'T. ROOM
AND WE'RE DOING E. ARE DYING.
DIAGNOSTIC TOOLS INDIVIDUALS
APPEAR BACK IN FRONT OF ME
MULTIPLE TIMES OVER ARE THERE
BECAUSE OF SOME INJURIES THAT
ARE IN THERE SO IF WE WANT TO
BE EFFECTIVE AND HAVE THEM.
HELP ME SUCCESSFUL MEMBERS AND
NOT COULD NOT COME BACK IN
FRONT OF THE COURTS WE NEED TO
DO THAT- THAT SCREEN ASSESS
REFERRAL TRIAGE- I KNOW A LOT
OF TIMES PEOPLE TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT CLUB OF COURTS IN THE SEA
IN THIS KIND OF. BOUGIE COURTS
WORK BUT WE'RE JUST FOR A SMALL
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS IN MAY BE
HAND PICKED FOR CHERRY PICKED
INDIVIDUALS OR SOME SOME OF
THE- CONCERNS WE GET SOME
SOMETIMES FOR LACK OF A BETTER
PHRASE. BUT THE NEW MODEL WHAT
WE'RE WORKING WE'RE WORKING
TOWARDS IT IS EXACTLY THE
OPPOSITE IN IN TERMS OF IN
TERMS OF DOING THAT- WE'RE
GOING TO NOT JUST SUBSTANCE
ABUSE BUT WARNING WE HAVE CLUB
OF COURSE DEALING WITH MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. YOU KNOW WHAT
HOMELESSNESS ISSUES DEAL WITH
VETERANS ISSUES DONALD PTSD- SO
WE ARE MUCH BIGGER THAN THAT
VISION. WAS AYE AND THERE ARE
SOME MODELS LIKE OUR MODEL
THERE ARE NO EXCLUSIONS WE
DON'T EXCLUDE PEOPLE FROM
COLLAPSING COLLABORATIVE COURSE
THERE IN THERE. ARE JOB AS PART
OF THAT SUPERVISION TOOL IS TO
DO THOSE DIAGNOSTIC TOOLS AND
WORK IN THE END BE AFFECTED- SO
FOR INSTANCE IN IN IN MY COURT-
WE DO A DIY COURT HERE IN SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY. IN WE HAVE FIVE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS GO THROUGH
MY DO YOU Y. COURT- IN SINCE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT- SO MORE
THAN FIVE THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND OR NAY. WE
WERE ABLE TO DOCUMENT THE
RECIDIVISM REDUCTION WE WILL
DOCUMENT A REDUCTIONS IN IN
COLLISIONS- AND SO IT'S THAT
SCENARIO WHERE EVERYBODY
EVERYBODY WINS SAFETY WISE
BECAUSE WE'RE GETTING AFFECTED
BEHAVIOR CHANGE- SO WE TRY TO
TAKE THE YEAH. WHICH WAS GLOBAL
WITH NO. AGAIN THIS DIED-
ASSIST TO EVERY- AND WE IT IN
THE ENTIRE CRIMINAL JUSTICE. SO
WE DESIGN A SYSTEM. AROUND THE
PROGRAM. PAROLE COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION REVOCATIONS- TO DO
THAT SCREENING ASESSMENT FOR
EVERYBODY WHO HAS HAD MORE THAN
MORE THAN ONE COME THROUGH
WE'RE GOING TO DO THE
DIAGNOSTIC THING ON THAT.
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH SINCE
TWENTY FIFTEEN MORE OR SIX ACTS
WHEN WE FIRST STARTED IT- OUR
P. R. C. S. VIOLATIONS THAT ARE
FILED BY PROBATIONER DOWN MORE
THAN SEVENTY PERCENT- WITH NO
FEWER BEING SENT TO US. SO THAT
SAME THING ON THE DIY SIDE WE
WENT FROM THIRTY THREE HUNDRED
FILINGS DOWN ELEVEN HUNDRED
FILINGS IN IN TEN YEARS. ON THE
REVOCATION CALENDAR WE'RE GONE
WE'VE GONE LITERALLY A 70%
REDUCTION IN THAT CALENDAR AS
WELL JUST BY USING THESE
DIAGNOSTIC. TOOL SO WHAT MAKES
THE CLIMATE OF COURSE WORK. IS
THE DAY YOU OF THAT THAT
POSITION OF THE COURTESAN AT
SUPERVISION POSITION WHETHER
IT'S PROBATION COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION OR PAROLE. THEY USE
THAT POSITION TO THEM BRING
BILLS EFFECTIVE TOOLS IN AND
ACTUALLY DO WHAT EVIDENCE BASED
ON THE DATA TELLS US- BUT WE
NEED TO DO IN TERMS OF IN TERMS
OF WORKING WITH AND- ALSO THE
OTHER TWO THINGS THAT I THINK.
REALLY MAKE THE MODEL WORK- IS
THE FACT THAT IT IS THE USE OF
DATA EVERYTHING WE DO IS DRIVEN
EVIDENCE BASED ON EVERYTHING WE
DO IS BASED ON RESEARCH. WE
EVALUATE OURSELVES WE- WILL
LEARN OURS OURSELVES AND WE
ADJUST BASED ON OUR EVALUATIONS
AND OUR NUMBERS. WHICH ISSUE
WHICH IS HUGE- AND MOST OF THE
A LOT OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
COMING THROUGH OUR ARE HOMELESS
SO WE'RE LEVERAGING- THE
COMMUNITY RESOURCES AVAILABLE
TO HELP INDIVIDUALS WITH FACT.
I WAS JUST TOLD THIS MORNING
THAT OUR MAYORS COMING IN TO
WATCH MY MENTAL HEALTH COURT ON
TUESDAY MORNING. AS PART OF HIS
APPROACH ON ON HOMELESSNESS
BECAUSE THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE COMING THROUGH ARE GOING.
TO BE THE INDIVIDUALS THAT NEED
THOSE RESOURCES AND STOP SO
IT'S ONE- THE ONE THING THAT I
THINK. A COURT DO- ON THAT
SUPER BY SIDE BRING EVERYBODY
DID YOU TAKE. AND GET EVERYBODY
TO WORK TO IN THE INTEGRATED
FASHION WHICH IS REALLY THE
KEY. THE KEY IS JUST EVERYTHING
WORKING TOGETHER IN AN IN A
SYSTEMIC IN INTEGRATED WAY THAT
MAKES US MORE MORE EFFECTIVE SO
THE STUDIES ARE OUT THERE. IN
TERMS OF THAT COST
EFFECTIVENESS WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE ONE OR DO YOU AYE COURT
COMING OUT IN ABOUT A MONTH. IN
TERMS OF THE COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS BUT WITH THE
RECIDIVISM REDUCTION TO COMES
THROUGH AND I MEAN YOU CAN TELL
JUST BY THE NUMBERS IN IN MY
COURT BUT I WAS ABLE TO GIVE
YOU ON HOW WE WERE ABLE TO
REDUCE THE WHY FILES HOW RATE
WILL BE REDUCED- PARIS YES
REPLICATE. REVOCATIONS THIS
CHANGE IN BEHAVIOR IS WHAT IS A
WAY TO REALLY DO IT I CALLED
THE COMMUNITY SUPERVISION
COURT- BECAUSE IF ONCE AN
INDIVIDUAL'S BEEN SENSOR ON
SUPERVISION IF YOU HAVE THIS.
THIS PART OF THE COURT. WHICH
DESIGNED TO EFFECTIVELY USE
THAT SUPERVISION- TO GET PEOPLE
GET RESOURCES TO PEOPLE GET
THEM CONNECTED TO KEEP THEM
FROM COMING BACK INTO THE
SYSTEM. IT'S THE EVERYBODY WINS
SCENARIO. SO IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S FUN AND I'M I'M REALLY
EXCITED TO BE ABLE TO TALK
ABOUT IT I THINK WE'RE KIND OF
ON THIS. TRAJECTORY RIGHT NOW
ARE MORE WE'RE LOOKING AT
REALLY DOING THINGS IN A MUCH
BIGGER WAY. I'M TRY AGAIN I
THANK YOU I THANK THE CHAIR ON
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO YOU AND
THEN I'LL BE HAPPY. TO
ENTERTAIN ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU JUDGE OF. ON I JUST A
COUPLE OF QUICK. AS IT IS.
BUDGET COMMITTEE- WHAT IS HOW
DOES THIS- ALL. HOW DO HOW DO
YOU GET THE FUNDS FOR THE
COLLABORATIVE COURTS COULD YOU
EXPLAIN THE WHOLE FUNDING
PROCESS AND I CAN ALSO- IF YOU
WERE TO EXPAND SINCE YOU'RE- UP
THE BIG ADVOCATE FOR IT WHAT
WOULD WHAT KIND OF INVESTMENT
WOULD YOU BE LOOKING AT. OR
WOULD YOU. BOB PROPOSE. I THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION IS
EXCELLENT ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROBLEMS IN THE COURT'S GOING
TO SCALE AND TO BE ABLE TO USE
THIS IS THEIR HOUSE BUT THERE'S
NO STABLE FUND FUNDING SOURCE
SO THERE WAS THE ORIGINAL DRUG
COURT DOLLARS- BIG BIG BIG CAME
DOWN OF COURSE OF COURSE
REFUSING TO GROW UP OR DOLLARS
WHEN THEY FIRST CAME DOWN- BUT
THAT GOT RE ALIGNED IN TWENTY
ELEVEN TWENTY TWELVE SOMEWHERE
AROUND THERE WENT TO COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND QUITE
FRANKLY A LOT OF COURTS DON'T
EVEN SEE THAT SO GOT ROUTED
THROUGH. COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND I HAVE TO DEAL WITH
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH WANTED
TO USE- THE MONEY FOR US FOR
OTHER STUFF ALL ALL THE TIME SO
IT WILL REALLY LOST A LOT OF
BELIEVE WITH THAT MONEY- WEIT
WAS REPLACED WITH FIRST
INNOVATIONS AND THEN RECIDIVISM
REDUCTION INNOVATION WAS ABOUT
I WAS ABOUT TEN TEN MILLION FOR
COLLABORATIVE COURTS OVER
COUPLE YEARS RECIDIVISM
REDUCTION NINE POINT NINE
SOMETHING LIKE THAT ON THOSE
GOT REPLACED BUT THOSE ARE
THOSE WERE TEMPORARY PILOT
FUNDING. AND THE PROBLEM THAT
YOU HAVE WHEN YOU WANT TO TRY
TO GET A COURT- TO GO TO SCALE
AND REALLY USE THESE PRINCIPLES
IS IT'S HARD TO GET PEOPLE TO
BUY INTO THAT WE AND OUR
FUNDING SOURCES GOING TO GO
AWAY SO WHAT HAPPENS IS WE HOW
WE DEAL WITH A LOT OF COURTS
AND I ACTUALLY WAS REALLY TO
BENEFIT SURE OF IT BECAUSE WE
USED A LOT OF MONEY TO THE
OTHER COURTS AT OTHER COURTS
WERE USING IN THE PROGRAM
BECAUSE THEY DON'T SEE THAT
STABILITY THAT LONG TERM-
SHORT. SO THE ABILITY TO HAVE
THAT STABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING
WOULD LET COURTS TAKE THIS
CONCEPT IN USE THIS SUPREME
COURT CONCEPT TO DEAL WITH THE
WORKLOAD MUCH MORE EFFECTIVELY
IN TERMS OF THE NUMBERS- STAFF
IS DONE A LOT OF TIME AND ALSO
OF OTHER COURTS- IN TERMS OF
WHAT THEY'RE WHAT THEY'RE WHAT
WHAT THEY'D DONE IN OTHER
STATES IN A LOT OF OTHER STATES
HAVE FUNDED ON THE RANGE WE GET
MY GLASSES. ARE HERE FOR A
SECOND SO I CAN GET THERE- YOU
KNOW. HOW OTHER STATES. IT WILL.
THE RECOUNT POPULAR. THE
ESTARá WOULD BE TO SIX MILLION
TO SIXTY FOUR MILLIONS I AM
THINK JUSTIN INVESTMENT OF WERE
THIRTY MILLION- PER YEAR WHAT
I'M PROBABLY REALLY EFFECTIVE
STATEWIDE IN TERMS OF GETTING
COURTS TO STEP FORWARD AND
REALLY USING THIS POWER THAT
QUITE FRANKLY WE'RE NOT USING
RIGHT RIGHT NOW. BECAUSE THE
TRADITIONAL IS YOU KNOW JUST
JAIL IS THE ANSWER TO THAT
RESOURCE IS THE TRADITIONAL
RESPONSE INSTEAD OF DOING THIS
INTEGRATED BEHAVIOR BASED THING
WHICH I THINK THE COURTS COULD
VERY EFFECTIVELY DO ACT THAT
THREE MILLION DOLLAR ANNUALLY A
YEAR AFTER YOU GET A LOT BETTER
YOU GET A REDUCTION IN JAIL
TIME YOU GET A REDUCTION IN
CASES COMING THROUGH IT'S
SOMETHING THAT I THINK WOULD
REALLY HELP. SO A QUESTION YOU
HAVE A FINAL QUESTION FOR ME. A
SHORT ANSWER IS HOW. DO YOU GET
FUNDED RIGHT NOW. EIGHT IT'S
MOSTLY GRANT PARK THE GRANT
FUNDING- SO NOW AND SOME COURTS
A LOT OF COURSE HAVE JUDGES
WRITING GRADING GRANTS I MEAN
THAT'S HOW HOW MUCH LITTLE
SUPPORT THERE IS OUT THERE BUT
IT'S MOSTLY GRANT FUNDING- BJ
SAM SURE WHAT WILL HAVE SOME
GRANT FUNDS FOR TREATMENT IN
THE JAIL HOUSE OF REPORT OR
STRUCTURAL BUT THEY'RE SHORT
THEIR LIMIT THERE WILL THERE
LIMITED TIME WISE TOO SO
THERE'S NOTHING THAT GIVES THE
SECURITY WITH THOSE GRANTS.
SURE YOU HAVE THOSE GRANTS-
RIGHT NOW AT INNOVATIONS JUST
ENDED SO WE- INNOVATIONS OUT
THERE SO WE DON'T HAVE A HOUSE
NO ANYTHING TO DO THERE WHAT
KIND OF RELYING ON THAT THE
DRUG COURT DOLLARS AND THAT
DEPENDS ON HOW GOOD YOUR YOUR
FUNDING IS SO I THINK YOU CAN
KIND OF SEE WHY EVERYTHING IS
SO LIMITED RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
THERE IS NO RELIABLE SOURCE OF
FUNDING THAT THAT WE CAN GO TO
SO FOR US. IT IS WE HAVE SOME
OF THE DRUG COURT WE WILL DROP
OR DOLLARS TO OUR BEHAVIOR
HEALTH BECAUSE WE'RE WORKING
WITH THEM WE HAVE BJ GRANTS- WE
DON'T HAVE ANY SAM SURE BRANDS
WE HAVE INNOVATIONS DOLLARS AND
THEN- ARGUE WHY COR IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF TRAFFIC SAFETY ON
WITH FEDERAL HIGHWAY SAFETY
DOLLARS BECAUSE THEY'VE SEEN
THE VALUE IN THE REDUCTIONS
THAT GO THERE BUT IT'S A VERY.
VERY DIFFICULT- PATCHWORK TO
PUT TOGETHER AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT PREVENTS A LOT OF COURSE
FROM BEING ABLE TO USE THOSE
RESOURCES THANK YOU- THE ALLEY-
HAVE ANY COMMENTS. LET ME TELL
YOU WHAT THE L. L. WE HAVE NO
COMMENT- THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SEVENTY COMMENTS. I JUST YOUR
MIND DEPARTMENTS FINANCE
NOTHING FURTHER TO ADD. OKAY
MEMBERS ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS
NO THERE ARE NONE OKAY JUDGE
VOLUME AS WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OFFER WHAT YOU DO
OBVIOUSLY THIS LOOKS LIKE IT
REALLY- HAS TREMENDOUS BENEFIT
FOR OUR COMMUNITY SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR PRESENTING TODAY.
NO THANK YOU. OKAY WE'RE MOVING
ON TO ISSUE TWENTY THREE THAT'S
ACCESS TO JUSTICE- FOR COURT
USERS. WE HAVE FOUR PANELISTS.
OUR REPRESENTING VARIOUS
SERVICE PROVIDERS- LET'S SEE WE
HAVE QUE MAR. EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY LEGAL AID
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
SANDRA LEVIN. OUR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY LAW
LIBRARY LESLIE. THE WORKSHOP
YOUR NAME OF HI MY OF. PERFECT
YES. OKAY REPRESENTING
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER CALIFORNIA
AND- LEVI SANCHES GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS ADVOCATE FROM SEIU
CALIFORNIA- THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH FOR BEING WITH US TODAY
AND I THINK WE'LL START WITH
KATE MARA. GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME- AS YOU SAID
MY NAME IS KATE MARTIN I'M
APOLOGIZING IN ADVANCE OF YOUR
DOGS OR CHILDREN IN THE
BACKGROUND- I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT COMMUNITY LEGAL AID
SO HOW. OUR PROGRAM IS PROVIDED
FREE LEGAL ASSISTANCE TO ORANGE
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY
RESIDENTS SINCE NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT I'M ALSO THE CO CHAIR OF
THE BOARD THE LEGAL AID
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AN
ORGANIZATION THAT IS DEDICATED
TO HELPING ENSURE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE FOR CALIFORNIANS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE REGARDLESS
OF WHERE THEY LEFT. AT MY
PROGRAM WE STRIVE TO PROVIDE
EQUITABLE COMPASSIONATE AND
EFFECTIVE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
SYSTEM FOR UNDERSERVED AND
UNDER RESOURCED COMMUNITIES.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR
CLIENTS LIVE AT OR BELOW 2100%
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LIMIT.
OUR CLIENTELE IS RACIALLY AND
ETHNICALLY DIVERSE AND A
QUARTER OF THEM SPEAK A
LANGUAGE OTHER THAN ENGLISH AND
MOST OF THEM HAVE CHILDREN
LIVING IN THEIR HOMES. MANY OF
OUR CLIENTS ARE SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR SOME OTHER
FORM OF DRAMA. WE HELP CLIENTS
WITH FAMILY LAW ISSUES HOUSING
IMMIGRATION CONSUMER DATA
PUBLIC BENEFITS HEALTH CARE
ISSUES AND REMOVING BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT. LIKE CRIMINAL
CONVICTIONS. WE HAVE A COMPLEX
LITIGATION UNIT THAT ENGAGES IN
SYSTEMIC ADVOCACY LIKE OUR
LAWSUIT AGAINST THE CITY OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH TO UPHOLD
STATE PORTABLE HOUSING LAWS AND
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS WE'VE
ALSO ADDED CASE MANAGERS TO OUR
TEAM WORK WITH CLIENTS AND
CONNECT THEM TO OTHER RESOURCES
OR SUPPORT. THAT THEY MEET. SO
AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW THE
INTEREST ON LAWYERS TRUST
ACCOUNTS. ARE THE BACKBONE OF
FUNDING FOR LEGAL AID IN
CALIFORNIA. FUNDING THAT IS
CRITICAL FOR THE OVER ONE
HUNDRED LEGAL AID ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE MINE THAT DO THIS WORK. IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THIS
INTEREST IN THE AGGREGATE WAS
FORTY SIX POINT FIVE MILLION.
FUNDING THAT WENT TO SUPPORT
CRITICAL LEGAL SERVICES FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES. AS THE COPING
CRISIS HIT AND INTEREST RATES
FELL SO DID I ALSO FUNDING.
FUNDING WENT FROM FORTY SIX
POINT FIVE MILLION IN INTEREST
IN. TWENTY NINETEEN TO ONLY
TWENTY SIX MILLION IN TWENTY
TWENTY THE STATE BAR IS
PROJECTING TWENTY TWENTY ONE
NUMBERS AT TWENTY FIVE MILLION.
SO JUST OER THE PAST TWO YEARS
WE LOST A CUMULATIVE FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING AND
THOSE ARE GRANTS THAT WE COULD
HAVE USED TO MAINTAIN SERVICES
DURING THIS CRITICAL TIME.
LEGAL AID PROGRAMS LIKE MINE I
WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR WE WERE
UNDER FUNDED TO MEET THE NEEDS
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC. WITH
ONLY ONE LAWYER FOR EVERY FIFTY
FIVE HUNDRED CALIFORNIANS WE'RE
LOOKING AT A DROP OF OVER
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR
FOR THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE.
BASED ON OUR EXPERIENCES DURING
THE LAST RECESSION IT WILL TAKE
A VERY LONG TIME FOR INTEREST
RATES TO RECOVER. WE HAD ONLY
JUST RECOVERED A DECADE LATER
ON THE IMPACT OF THE LAST
INTEREST RATE CRASHED ON THIS
CRUCIAL FUNDING FOR LEGAL AID.
ANOTHER CRITICAL SOURCE OF
FUNDING FOR LEGAL AID THAT
PEOPLE ACT EQUAL ACCESS FUND.
THE FUND IS AN INVALUABLE
RESOURCE AND A FOUNDATIONAL
SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA'S
LEGAL AID SYSTEM. ALL INCREASES
TO THE FUND MAKE AN ENORMOUS
IMPACT ON WHAT ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE MINE CAN ACCOMPLISH. AS
YOU MIGHT GUESS THE PROVISION
OF LEGAL AID HINGES ON A
DELICATE BALANCE. AT OUR
PROGRAM WE STRIVE TO PROVIDE IN
DEPTH SERVICES. TO THOSE MOST
IN NEED WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY
HELPING AS MANY CLIENTS AS
POSSIBLE. I ALSO AN EQUAL
ACCESS FUNDING BOTH MAKE THIS
EFFORT POSSIBLE BY UNDERWRITING
A RANGE OF LEGAL SERVICES FROM
LEGAL ADVICE TO FULL
REPRESENTATION. AND THIS ALLOWS
US TO PROVIDE CRITICAL LEGAL
SERVICES TO THOUSANDS OF
NEIGHBORS ANNUALLY. AT MY
PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY WE USE
EQUAL ACCESS FUNDING TO
UNDERWRITE OUR INTAKE AND
ASSESSMENT TEAM WHICH IS THE
POINT OF ENTRY FOR PROGRAM FOR
ALL OF OUR CLIENTS. THIS TEAM
CONDUCTS A COMPREHENSIVE LEGAL
SCREENING FOR EACH CLIENT TO
IDENTIFY AND TRIAGE THEIR LEGAL
ISSUES. I LEGAL ADVICE AND
REFERRALS TO THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO CALL OUR
HOTLINE OR COMPLETE AN ONLINE
AND- THEY ALSO CONDUCTS CLINICS
WORKSHOPS AND COMMUNITY
OUTREACH. OUR PROGRAM HAS ONE
OF THE LARGEST FREE LEGAL
HOTLINE IN THE UNITED STATES
AND IT'S A CRITICAL TOOL FOR US
FOR TWO REASONS. FIRST IT
ALLOWS US TO MEET IMMEDIATELY
HELP A HIGH NUMBER OF CLIENTS
STRUGGLING WITH LEGAL PROBLEMS.
MANY OF THE CLIENTS THE CALL US
WE'LL HANG UP KNOWING WHAT
THEIR NEXT STEPS ARE TO RESOLVE
THE PROBLEM AND DON'T NEED ANY
FURTHER ASSISTANCE. OUR STAFF.
TO FOCUS ON PROVIDING FULL
SCOPE REPRESENTATION FOR THE
MOST COMPLEX CASES. BEYOND FOR
CLIENTS WERE IN MOST NEED OF
HELP. OUR HOTLINE IS ALSO
POISED TO SERVE AS A REGIONAL
CALL CENTER IN THE EVENT OF A
DISASTER LIKE A WILDFIRE OR AN
EARTHQUAKE. ACCORDING TO CENSUS
DATA IN MY PROGRAM SERVICE AREA
ALONE THERE WERE OVER SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE ELIGIBLE FOR OUR
SERVICES AND TWENTY TWENTY.
THAT'S OVER 15% OF THE
POPULATION. WITH OUR LIMITED
RESOURCES WE WERE ONLY ABLE TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE TO JUST OVER
NINETEEN THOUSAND. OVER THE
PAST YEAR IN RESPONSE TO THE
PANDEMIC OUR PROGRAM WAS ABLE
TO SHARE WITH THE HELP OF
PEOPLE ACCESS FUNDING TO MEET
THE CHANGING NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITY ALL WHILE WORKING
REMOTELY. WE TRAINED OUR INTAKE
AND ASSESSMENT TEAM TO ASSIST
WITH UNEMPLOYMENT ISSUES AND
ADDED TO OUR HOUSING TEAM TO
HELP TENANTS UNDERSTAND THE
MANY OVERLAPPING COVERT RELATED
HOUSING PROTECTIONS AND
REPRESENT THEM IN COURT WHEN
THEY'RE LANDLORDS TRIED TO
EVICT THEM IN VIOLATION OF
THOSE PROTECTIONS. DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC CASES ARE INCREASING
PRECIPITOUSLY. AT THE END OF
APRILTWENTY TWENTY ONE WE HAVE
ALREADY CLOSED OVER HALF THE
NUMBER OF CASES THAT WE CLOSED
IN TWENTY TWENTY. AND WAIT
TIMES ON OUR HOTLINE I'VE GROWN
TO AS MUCH AS TWO TO THREE
HOURS. THESE FACTORS ILLUSTRATE
THE SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR HELP
IN THE COMMUNITIES WE SERVE.
OUR CLIENTS FACE MANY OF THE
SAME PROBLEMS THEY FACED BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC. FAMILY CRISES
HOUSING INSTABILITY FINANCIAL
AND SECURITY. BUT TODAY THEIR
SITUATIONS ARE MORE DIRE AND
MORE NUMEROUS THAN BEFORE AS
MANY GRAPPLE WITH THE FALLOUT
UNEMPLOYMENT. ILLNESS AND LOSS
OF LOVED ONES. WE ANTICIPATE
THAT OUR PRESSURE CASES WILL
GROW AS COURTS TURNED TO A MAN.
BACK OF CIVIL CASE. AND WE
CANNOT COME CLOSE TO MEETING
THIS GROWING NEED WITHOUT
SUFFICIENT FUNDING. SO I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE WE'RE NOT
REQUESTING MORE OVERALL FUNDING
AT THIS TIME BUT WE'RE ACTUALLY
HOPING IS TO USE THE EQUAL
ACCESS FUND TO BACK FILL THE
LOSS OF FUNDING FOR MY ALSO- WE
ALONG WITH OUR SISTER LEGAL AID
ORGANIZATIONS DEPEND ON THE
FUND'S. NOVEL CALIFORNIANS
ESPECIALLY WHEN OUR OTHER
FUNDING STREAMS DECREASE AS
IT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW WITH
MY OLD. EVEN PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
MEET THE NEED. AND THE DEMAND
FOR OUR SERVICES AND CERTAINLY
AT CURRENT FUNDING LET LEVELS
WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO SERVE
THE INCREASING NUMBER OF PEOPLE
IN NEED. ESPECIALLY IN THE COPA
NINETEEN CONTEXT SO FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE REQUESTING OR
ASKING AND URGING YOU. TO ADD A
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO
BE EQUAL ACCESS FUND AN
ADDITIONAL FIFTY FIVE MILLION.
OR- INFRASTRUCTURE AND
INNOVATION GRANTS TO BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ACCESS JUSTICE COMMISSION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. SANDER
LEVIN. THANK YOU AND I'M GONNA
TRAIN SURE MY SCREEN- HERE.
OKAY CENTRAL THE PRESS OF THE
COUNCIL OF HEALTH COUNTY LAWLER
FROM HERE REPRESENT COUNTY LAW
LIBRARY FROM A THE AS WELL AS
MY OWN ONLINE AND ANGELES.
COUNTY LOW LIBRARIES THE MOVE.
VULGAR INDIVIDUALS AND ARE- IN
A NORTH YEAR WE PROVIDE MORE
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND IN PERSON
JUST. HOPING TO WHO ARE
LITIGANTS AND ALSO THOSE WHO
ARE NOT GOING TO GET WITH OR
ISSUE. WHEN THEY CAN'T AND- ANY
SORT OF LEGAL. WE AS YOU WOULD
EXPECT FROM LIBRARIES PROVIDE
WRITTEN MATERIALS BUT WE ALSO
PROVIDE ONLINE ASSISTANCE HELP
SELF HELP GUIDES INSTRUCTIONAL
HANDOUTS CLASSES WORKSHOPS ONE
ON ONE ASSISTANCE. AND WE ALSO
PROVIDE REFERRALS TO OTHER
AGENCIES LIKE COURT SERVICES
LEGAL AID ORGANIZATIONS AND SO
ON. BASICALLY WE LISTEN TO
PEOPLE WHO ARRIVED TYPICALLY
VERY UPSET AND STRESSED APOLO
LIBRARY WHO COULDN'T FIND HELP
ANYWHERE ELSE AND WE HELP THEM
FIND A PATH FORWARD. IN FACT
THE IN LOS ANGELES THE MOST
COMMON RESPONSE WE RECEIVED FAR
OUT OUT TEN QUESTIONNAIRES. IS
NOW I HAVE HOPE YEAH THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE HOPE. BECAUSE
DON'T ANYWHERE TO TRY WE HOPE
WE NO ONE CAN WHEN AGENTS.
CAN'T PROVIDE SYSTEM MAYBE THE
PATRON DOESN'T. BASED ON MATTER
OR IN WE HELL IN EVERY WE NO
RISK. ON THE SUBJECT MATTER
WORK CAN GET HELP A. COUNTY LAW
LIKE. AND A REAL THAT THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE HOW REACHED
DOZENS DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
LETTER. FROM COURTS FROM JUDGES
SELF HELP- ORGAN. FROM LATER.
FROM VOLUNTEER ATTORNEYS ALL
OVER THE STATE THIS YEAR ASKING
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
COUNTY LAW LIBRARY. HOW DID GET
TO THE SO. WE'RE IN. WELL TONY
IS USED TO ABLE TO ENSURE HOW
LOLA REVENUE. THE AMOUNT OF
FIVE FEES THAT WENT TO COUNTY
LAW LIBRARY BUT THAT IN. TWO
EIGHT. TIME THE STATE FOR ON
FEES FEDERAL. WITH A NEW A NEED
SOURCE OF ADDITIONAL. HOW DO
YOU LAW LIBRARIES WHEN BE ABLE
MEET THERE ARE COSTS THIS WAS
BACK IN TWO EIGHT SINCE TIME
SHE KNOWS HAVE BEEN TAKEN TO
FOR THAT STABLES OF A RARE. NO
SIMPLE. FUNDING WAS PROVIDE FOR
A JACK. AND REVENUE PLUMMETED
FOR A JACK. SO YOU LOOK AT THE
YELLOW LINE ACROSS THE OF THIS.
BACK WHAT OUR REVENUE WITH LOOK
LIKE A IT HAD STAY THE SAME AS
IT WAS A TWO NINE. THE TOP LINE
THIS GREEN UP. LINE WHICH IS
WHAT OUR WOULD NAY TO LOOK LIKE
IF WANTED TO UP THE CALL OF LEE
MATERIALS. BUT OF COURSE WE
DIDN'T RECEIVE. THE NEXT ONE
DOWN IS ARE READ WILL HAVE HAD
TO LOOK TO KEEP UP WITH YOUR
THE CALL. OF YEAH. BUT THAT
WASN'T WHAT WE- I. WHAT WE- TO
THAT RAY LINE. A PLUMMET IN
REVENUE FOR A DECADE. IT JUST
KEPT GOING. AND. SO BY TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. SOMEHOW LAWLER
HAD. OTHERS WERE AT RISK OF
CLOSE. AND EVERYONE US HAD ME
DRUM. CUTS SO FOR THE FIRST
TIME MY HUNDRED TWENTY YEAR
HISTORY OF CASH WELL I. HELLO
PROVIDE HAD- SIMILAR. CHEN FUND
MONEY TO CARRY LAWLER IS TO GOT
SICK AND A HALF MEN STATE WHY.
IN OUR FISCAL YEAR NINE. WE
RECEIVE NO. IN FISCAL YEAR AND
WE WERE SEVERAL OLLARS. IN THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR TWO FILLED
FOR- MOSCOW GOOD LOSS FILINGS
STUDENT IN IN THE PRIOR YEAR.
THAT KEPT MANY OF. BY IT DIDN'T
COME. TO SOLVE THE- IN FACT
WITH THE PANDA WE SAW EVEN OVER.
IN OUR TO THE BLUE BAR IS THE
YEAR AND A AND FEBRUARY OF
THOUSAND NINE AS A KID. POINT
THE READING GREEN BARS THAT YOU
SEE THAT ARE A HUGE STEP DOWN
ARE WHAT WE- PREPAYMENT AND
NINE AND TWENTY YEARS ENDING IN
DECEMBER OF. DOES HE- AND THEN
YOU CAN SEE WHY HAPPENED IN THE-
IN THE PER BAR LOS SIGNIFICAN
MORE TO THE- WHERE. THE U.
ENDING IN TRAVEL OF TWENTY ONE.
WAS ONLY ABOUT PER. OF WHAT
COUNTY LAW LIBRARY HAVE REACHED
AND FINALLY FEES IN. TWO
THOUSAND NINE. AT THE SAME TIME
THIS PANDEMIC BECAUSE A HUGE
SURGE PUBLIC NEED AS BEEN
DESCRIBED BY OF MY COLLEAGUES-
THE HEALTH ISSUES DEPEND. OKAY
RISE TO A NEW FOR GUARDING AND
CONCERN. SADLY MANY MORE.
LEADING TO ACCESS TO BUT TO
HADN'T. A HUGE SURGE IN DEMAND
BY AND I REQUEST TO COUNTY LAW
LIBRARY SUITE WE SAW OF THINGS
EVERY OTHER ASIAN THAT WERE IN
THIS HAS. YEAH CAN HARD OF THE
PEN. AS YOU KNOW CALLED BECAUSE
CRISES HOW EVICTION. HOW
DIVORCE HIM- ED MANY MANY
PEOPLE TRYING TO NEW SMALL
BUSINESS AND THERE WILL FEW
RESTORE FOR THE WE HAVE- THE
MOST OFFER IT LONG AS WELL AND
AT THE SAME TIME PEOPLE FOR
FREE WAIVERS WHICH OF COURSE
MEANS LESS OF A HIGHLY REVENUE
ALESTRA NETWORK. RATES. SOURCES
AND CHALLENGES IN PROVIDING OUR
SERVICES SO THERE'S LESS OUT
THERE FOR THE PUBLIC TO RELY ON
EACH AND THEY'RE MORE DEPENDENT
ON THE CATCH ALL OF COUNTY LAW
LIBRARY. SO THIS HUGE LOSS OF
FUNDING IN COUNTY LIBRARY'S
CAUSED US TO HAVE TO REDUCE
LOCATIONS REDUCE SERVICE OUT
THOSE LOCATIONS WE MAKE CUTS TO
OUR COLLECTIONS WHICH REDUCES
ACCESS TO. CURRENT ACCURATE
INFORMATION FROM THE PUBLIC WE
HAD TO REDUCE STAFF WHICH
REDUCES HOURS AND WORK MEANS
LONGER WAIT TIMES FOR THE
PUBLIC. AND MORE LIMITED
LANGUAGE ACCESS. WE ARE
SUFFERING THROUGH SOME TRAILING
FACILITIES AND POOR
INFRASTRUCTURE ESPECIALLY AYE
SHE NEEDS WHICH THE PUBLIC IS
GREATLY DEPENDENT. SO WHERE
THAT LEAVES US NOW IS THAT.
PEOPLE NEED HELP WITH THEIR
LEGAL STRUGGLES NOW MORE THAN
EVER THE- THEY NEED IS DRAMATIC
AND IT'S ENORMOUS FAR MORE THAN
WHAT WE CANCER THEIR FINANCIAL
SURVIVAL YOUR EMOTIONAL AND
MENTAL WELL BEING THEIR DIGNITY
THEIR PHYSICAL HEALTH AND THEIR
FAITH IN THEIR JUSTICE SYSTEM
DEPENDS ON THE SERVICES AND THE
HELP. THAT WE ALL CAN PROVIDE
COUNTY LAW LIBRARIES ARE THE
SAFETY NET FOR THOSE WHO ARE
FACING THESE CHALLENGES WITHOUT
AN ATTORNEY WE'RE THE ONLY ONES
THAT HAVE NO RESTRICTIONS ON
WHO WE SERVE AND WHAT TOPICS
WILL COVER AND WE ARE AVAILABLE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE FOR
EVERYONE. AND THAT'S WHY WE ARE
AGAIN ASKING THAT. THE
LEGISLATURE HELP US IN
PROVIDING A- STABLE ADEQUATE
FUNDING SOURCE FOR COUNTY LAW
LIBRARY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF WE MOVE ON WITH
LESLIE HI MARK. THE SIDE RIGHT
RIGHT MOST AFTERNOON ABOUT FOUR
MINUTES AWAY FROM THAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY- I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER OF CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT EVERY CHILD IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM HERE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. SACRAMENTO AND
PLASTER WHICH GIVES US THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ALMOST HALF
THE CHILDREN IN THE STATE IN
CALIFORNIA'S CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM I AM ALSO HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF A COALITION OF
DEPENDENCY ATTORNEYS
REPRESENTING PARENTS AND
CHILDREN. AND ALMOST A 100% OF
THE STATE- WE ARE OF A GROUP OF
ATTORNEYS THAT MEET REGULARLY.
TO ADDRESS AREAS OF COMMON
CONCERN. WE HAVE A TWO PART.
TOM THAT IS BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY SO I'M GOING TO
SPEAK ABOUT THEM SEPARATELY
FIRST I'M GOING TO ADDRESS THE
THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR I'M GOING
REQUEST AND THEN I WILL TALK
ABOUT THE TEN MILLION DOLLAR
ONE TIME FUNDS REQUEST. I WAS
ALSO ASKED TO PROVIDE A LITTLE
BIT OF BACKGROUND IN HISTORY SO
I'LL START WITH THAT. WHEN
TRAVELER FUNDING WENT INTO
EFFECT IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR DECIDED THAT THE
DEPENDENCY COUNCIL FUNDING
WOULD REMAIN WOULD REMAIN THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE STATE.
AND AT THAT TIME HISTORICAL
ALLOCATIONS WERE MAINTAINED AND
CONTINUE TO BE MAINTAINED FOR
OVER TWO DECADES WHICH RESULTED
IN DRAMATIC INEQUITIES AND
DISPARITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
DEPENDENCY COUNSELING WHY IN
SOME COUNTIES. BEING FUNDED AT
A MUCH HIGHER PER CLIENT RATE
THAN IN OTHERS. BY TWENTY
FOURTEEN THIS HAS LED TO A
CASELOAD CRISIS WHERE THE
AVERAGE CASELOAD AROUND THE
STATE WITH THREE HUNDRED
CLIENTS PER ATTORNEY AND IN
SOME PLACES IT WAS AS HIGH AS.
FIVE HUNDRED CLIENTS ATTORNEY.
I THAT TIME OUR GOAL IS FOR IN
BEGIN TO WORK WITH RELIGIOUS.
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND THE
GOVERNOR'S ON STAFF. TO RECTIFY
THESE INEQUITIES AND A NEW
SYSTEM OF DISTRIBUTION WAS
CREATED WHICH INCLUDES AN
ANNUAL REALLOCATION TO ENSURE.
THAT AS CASELOADS CHANGE
FUNDING MATCHES THOSE CASELOADS
ACCORDINGLY. THANKS IN PART IN
LARGE PART TO THIS COMMITTEE
AND YOUR COUNTERPARTS IN IN
OTHER PARTS OF OUR- LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS THERE HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT ANGRY
PROGRESS RESULT REDUCING
CASELOADS AND ENSURING EQUITY
ACROSS THE STATE THROUGH THAT
ANNUAL RELOCATION PROCESS I
MENTIONED. HOWEVER WE ARE STILL
SHORT OF THE RECOMMENDED
MAXIMUM CASELOAD OF A HUNDRED
AND FORTY ONE CLIENTS PER
ATTORNEY. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
FEDERAL FUNDING POLICY CHANGE
ALLOWING STATES TO DRAW DOWN
FEDERAL MATCHING DOLLARS AND
ACCORDING THE DEPENDENCY
COUNCIL THE DEPENDENCY COUNCIL
BUDGET WAS INCREASED BASED ON
AN EXPECTATION OF FEDERAL
MATCHING DOLLARS. ABOUT TWO
FORTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE FIRST YEAR AND THEN FIFTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
CURRENT YEARS IN THE CURRENT
YEAR AND IN THE BUDGET YEAR.
HAD WE BEEN ABLE TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THOSE- INCREASES AND
ACTUALLY RECEIVE ALL OF THE-
PROJECTED FEDERAL FUNDS WE
WOULD HAVE FINALLY BEEN IN A
POSITION IN CALIFORNIA WHERE WE
WERE ABLE- TO ENSURE NO MORE
THAN A HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
CLIENTS HER ATTORNEY AND ALSO.
ENSURE ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR
OTHER- AUXILIARY EXPENSES AND-
BEST PRACTICES UNFORTUNATELY
THE ACTUAL CLAIMS IN YOUR ONE
AND THE EXPECTED CLAIMS THIS
YEAR AND IN THE BUDGET YEAR ARE
FAR SHORT. OF WHAT WAS
PROJECTED. IN YEAR ONE WE DROVE
WE WERE ABLE TO DRIVE DOWN
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH RESULT WHICH IS 53% OF
THE PROJECTION. THIRTY OUT OF
FORTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH IS INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET. THIS YEAR WE EXPECT
THAT AT BEST WILL BE ABLE TO
DRIVE DOWN 75% OF WHAT WAS
PROJECTED AND PERHAPS UP 280%
NEXT YEAR. THERE ARE A LOT OF-
THERE'S A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS WHICH
I WILL GO INTO AT THIS TIME-
THE FEDERAL RULES KEEP
CHANGING- UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE
BEEN PUT INTO A RETROACTIVE
BILLING SITUATION NOW TWO YEARS
IN A ROW WE HAVE. RIGHT HERE.
AND ALL OF THE FIRST YEAR WAS
BUILT RETROACTIVELY AS WELL WE
HAD MEAN RECEIVED REMAINING
WOULD BE AT THE VARIOUS
ATTORNEY GROUPS. ONLY JUST
RECEIVED THE RULES FOR CLAIMING
FOR THE CURRENT YEAR- A FEW
WEEKS AGO AND THEY HAVE THEY
HAVE YET TO BE COMPLETELY
FINALIZED I WAS ON A PHONE CALL
THIS MORNING WHERE CHANGES WERE
AGAIN. I'M BEING DISCUSSED AND
CLARITY SOUGHT AND CERTAIN FINE
POINTS PUT ON THE CLEANING
RULES SO WE WILL BE CLAIMING
RETROACTIVELY AGAIN THIS YEAR.
AND IN SOME SITUATIONS WILL BE
LEAVING MONEY ON THE TABLE
BECAUSE THE RULES AS I SAID THE
RULES HAVE CHANGED. AND THE
DOCUMENTATION THAT IS REQUIRED.
TO CLAIM FOR CERTAIN ACTIVITIES
IS NOT AVAILABLE BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T KNOW AND TELL THE PAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS THAT WE NEEDED
THAT DOCUMENTATION. YEAH THE
CLAIMING AND BILLING IT GOES
BACK TO JULY ONE AND WE CAN'T
RETROACTIVELY CREATE RECORDS
FOR EXAMPLE. TIME RECORDS THAT
DON'T EXIST. THESE AND- OF A
VERY. IMPACT ON OUR ABILITY TO-
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
WONDERFUL FEDERAL OPPORTUNITY.
THE SECOND OF. AND SO I WILL BE
IN LOOKING AT MY ORGANIZATION
AS AN EXAMPLE FOR THIS CURRENT
YEAR OF THE FIRST HALF OF THE
CURRENT YEAR WE ANTICIPATE THAT
OUR MATCH RATE IS ONLY GONNA BE
67% OF WHAT IS AVAILABLE TO US
ANOTHER SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM IN
OUR ABILITY TO TAKE FULL
ADVANTAGE IN CALIFORNIA'S
ABILITY TO TAKE FULL. IS THAT
WHEN THE PROGRAM. FIRST STARTED
THEY EXPECTED A 59% PENETRATION
RATE FOR THREE YEARS WE THEN
LATER LEARNED FROM- FROM THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THAT THAT HAD
BEEN ARONIE EASILY
COMMUNICATED- THROUGH THE
CONTRACTING PROCESS NOT NOT
THROUGH ANY FAULT OF JUDICIAL
COUNCIL THAT YOU CHANGES- AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL. AND IT THE
PENETRATION RATE IS ACTUALLY IT
WAS 59% THE FIRST YEAR 55% THE
SECOND CAR A YEAR AND WILL ONLY
BE 54% IN THE BUDGET YEAR SO AN
AUTOMATIC 5% REDUCTION IN THE
EXPECTED MATCH- THAT IS OUT OF
EVERYONE'S CONTROL.
ADDITIONALLY THERE ARE A LARGE
NUMBER OF ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
EITHER MANDATED BY STATE LAW OR
DRIVEN BY BEST PRACTICES THAT
DO NOT MEET THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR MATCHING AND
MANY OF THESE ACTIVITIES- ARE
ARE PRACTICES THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE. I HAVE- RECOGNIZE
AS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
SERVING FAMILIES AND CHILDREN
IN THE DEPENDENCY SYSTEM. FOR
EXAMPLE SOME OF OUR MOST
IMPORTANT PRACTICES AROUND
MULTI DISCIPLINARY
REPRESENTATION OF CHILDREN
WHO'VE BEEN VICTIMS OF
COMMERCIAL SEX TRAFFICKING WILL
NOT BE MATCH BALL SIMILARLY ARE
VERY INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE IN PLACE TO SERVE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN FOSTER CARE
WHO BEEN ARRESTED THOSE
ACTIVITIES WILL NOT BE MATCH OF
ALL THE USE OF PARA PARTNERS
AND HERE ADVOCATES WHICH IS. A
SHINING EXAMPLE OF- BUT A
PRACTICE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
LED THE WAY OF HAVING PEOPLE OF
LIVED EXPERIENCE WORKING
ALONGSIDE LAWYERS TO PROVIDE
BETTER SERVICES TO PARENTS AND
CHILDREN SOME OF THE ACTIVITIES
THEY ENGAGE ON A DAILY BASIS
WILL NOT BE MATCH OF ALL. SOME
OF OUR TRAINING IS NOT MAGICAL
I COULD GO ON THERE'S A BUS
UNFORTUNATELY A FAIRLY LONG
LIST OF ACTIVITIES THAT ARE NOT
MATCH OF ALL TIME TO AN
ATTORNEY SPENDS IN A STAFF
MEETING IS NOT MAGICAL. SO IT
IS BECAUSE BECOME
MATHEMATICALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
REACH THE MATCH THE SECOND VERY
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE THAT WE
HAVE REBATES BACK TO THE
RETROACTIVE BILLING PROBLEMS
AND THAT IS BECAUSE THE MATCH
ASSUMES THAT THE PRIOR YEAR'S
MATCH WILL ALSO BE MATCHED WE
HAVE TO SPEND IT TO MATCH IT WE.
HAVEN'T RECEIVED THE FUNDING AT
SO WE CAN IT SPEND IT SO WE
CAN'T MATCH IT. ONCE AGAIN. THE
DOMINO EFFECT WHERE IT WILL BE
A HOW. TO THE FULL FAT MATCH.
IN LAST GET A JUMP START ON THE
FEDERAL FUNDING STREAM BY
INCREASING THE STATE FUNDING AS
RECOMMENDED BY UP TO THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS EACH YEAR UNTIL
WE CAN REALIZE A GREATER SHARE.
OF THE AVAILABLE FEDERAL
FUNDING. I'LL NOW TURN TO THE
ADDITIONAL. ONE TIME TEN
MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST. WHICH
WE WOULD SAY AT THIS POINT- IS
A IS A CONSERVATIVE REQUEST AND
IT COMES FROM TWO PRIMARY AREAS
THE FIRST IS THE CASELOADS.
WHICH YOU MAY BE AWARE OF- HIS
BEEN REPORTED IN A VARIETY OF
VENUES AND IS IN THE MATERIALS-
THERE'S BEEN A 7% INCREASE. IN
CASELOAD IN THE DEPENDENCY
SYSTEM STATEWIDE AND 14% OF
THAT IS IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
THAT 14% INCREASE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY REFLECTS OVER
FIVE THOUSAND MORE CHILDREN.
THAN WE WOULD TYPICALLY HAVE IN
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM ON ANY
GIVEN DAY. AND EACH OF THOSE
CHILDREN COMES TO COURT
HOPEFULLY WITH AT LEAST ONE
PARENT SOMETIMES A VOTE SO WE
ESTIMATE APPROXIMATELY. TEN
THOUSAND ADDITIONAL CLIENTS
JUST A LOS ANGELES. THAT'S THE
EQUIVALENT OF SEVENTY
CASELOADS. AT IF THOSE
CASELOADS OF THE ATTORNEYS FOR
THOSE CASES WERE FULLY FUNDED
THAT WOULD BE AN ADDITIONAL
THIRTEEN POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS BASED ON THE FORMULA
THAT'S BEEN ADOPTED BY THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. ANOTHER WAY
TO LOOK AT IT IS IF WE LOOK AT
7% OF THE CURRENT TWO HUNDRED
AND FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
THAT IS PROJECTED IN THE BUDGET
THAT WOULD BE A FOURTEEN POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE.
ADDITIONALLY JUST ON MONDAY OF
THIS WEEK THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
RELEASED THEIR PROPOSED
ALLOCATION PER FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND AS
WE EXPECTED. THERE WILL BE A
SIGNIFICANT CUTS AROUND THE
STATE IF THERE IS NOT EDITION
ALL STATE FUNDING PUT INTO THAT
BUDGET. THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
IDENTIFIED A THREE MILLION
DOLLAR AGGREGATE. INCREASED
MEDIA- WHICH WILL TRANSLATE TO.
INCREASES AND ONLY SIXTEEN
COUNTIES AND SEVEN OF THOSE
INCREASES ARE UNDER TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS SOME ARE ONLY
A FEW HUNDRED DOLLARS AND ONLY
THREE. LOS ANGELES. FRESNO
ORANGE. I ORANGE WOULD ANY OF
THAN A- THOUSAND DOLLAR.
CONVERSELY WHEN IT IS ON. UNDER
THE- FORM THANK THAT GO THE-
STATE BUNNIES MANY OTHER
COUNTIES SOME WHO EXPERIENCED
INCREASES IN CASELOADS WILL
HAVE THEIR ALLOCATIONS REDUCED
OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS SO
THAT'S THIRTY NINE COUNTIES.
THAT WAS THE CUTS TO THEIR
DEPENDENCY BUDGETS EVEN THOUGH
THEY MAY NOT HAVE HAD A
REDUCTION IN CASELOAD AND IN
SOME CASES MAY HAVE HAD AN
INCREASING CASELOAD. COULD YOU
COULD YOU WOULD WRAP IT UP-
SURE I'M- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. THE LAST THING I'LL
JUMP TO THE END OF THE CALL
THAT IMPACTS- WEIGHTS IN THAT
THE JCC DID ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE HAS NOT BEEN SAVINGS-
BECAUSE EVERY MO CORE AND TO
THE COUNTRY TO THE DEPENDENCY
PROVIDERS KOPIN HAS COST US
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN RELATED EXPENSES
TECH PP BACKFILLING POSITIONS
FOR STAFF FOR AN FMLA LAPTOPS
FOR STAFF CREATING REMOTE
ACCESS FOR CLIENTS WHICH I WILL
ADDRESS LATER IF I CAN WHEN
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
ABOUT REMOTE COURT- AND NONE OF
THAT HAS BEEN. RATE HAS HAS
BEEN SUPPORTED BY ANY STATE
FUNDING SO UNLIKE THE
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES THAT HAVE
RECEIVED FOR EXAMPLE THE JCC
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
THE DEPENDENCY PROVIDERS HAVE
HAD TO ABSORB ALL OF THOSE
COSTS OF THE IMPACT OF COMBAT
HAS BEEN TREMENDOUS ONE
ORGANIZATIONS SPENT A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
INTERPRETERS ALONE. I'M AND I
CAN PROVIDE ADDITIONAL D. AS OF
THOSE IN IF THERE'S TIMELY OR
IN WRITING THANK YOU FOR YOUR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OF A- WILL
END LIBBY'S. FROM S. TELL. THAT
AFTERNOON MATTER CHAIR SAY ON
THE OF S. I. U. REP CORE
EMPLOYEE AND CO THROUGHOUT THIS
THANK YOU FOR THIS OP TO SPEAK
TO YOU TODAY I TO SEE BY.
MYSELF THE CALM MAY BY THE
OTHER PANEL TODAY AND
RECOGNIZING US YEAH YOU SUPPORT
FOR ALL OF THE BUDGET ASKS THAT
THEY HAVE PROPOSED I'D ALSO
LIKE TO SPEAK BRIEFLY ON THE
PROPOSAL WE HEARD IMMEDIATELY
PRIOR WERE GUARDING- THE-
SPECIALTY COURTS WANTED TO NOTE
THERE IS PRIOR PRECEDENTS FOR
THE LEGISLATURE ALLOCATING
SPECIFIC DEDICATED FUNDING TO
SPECIALTY COURTS SEIU IS A HUGE
FAN OF SPECIALTY COURTS BUT I
WOULDN'T BE A C. I. U. F. I
DIDN'T MAKE THE POINT. THAT ONE
OF THE MOST INTEGRAL COMPONENTS
OF SPECIALTY COURTS SHOULD BE
PROVIDING WRAP AROUND SERVICES
USING COUNTY PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES STAFF SO ANY PROPOSAL
TO ALLOCATE SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING FOR SPECIALTY COURTS WE
HOPE WOULD ALSO. INCORPORATE
THAT REQUEST- I'M HERE TODAY TO
REALLY SPEAK UP COURT EMPLOYEE
SPECIFICALLY REPORTERS AND- AND
WHAT HAS BEEN GOING ON IN OUR
WORLD IN THE COURTS MOST
RECENTLY. COURT REPORTERS PLAY
A VITAL AND INTEGRAL ROLE NOT
ONLY IN OUR JUDICIAL SYSTEM
GENERALLY BUT MORE SPECIFICALLY
IN ENSURING EQUAL ACCESS TO
JUSTICE COURT REPORTERS ARE
TASKED WITH PROVIDING THE
OFFICIAL VERBATIM RECORD OF
COURT PROCEEDINGS. TRANSCRIPTS
OF THESE PROCEEDINGS PRODUCED
BY COURT REPORTERS LITERALLY
MEAN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A
LITIGANT BEING ABLE TO FULLY
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHTS ON
APPEAL. OR THOSE RIGHTS BEING
ALL BUT ILLUSORY IN FACT THE
RIGHT TO A COURT REPORTER AND
EQUAL ACCESS TO JUSTICE IS SO
INEXTRICABLY LINKED. INDIGENT
LITIGANTS HAVE A GUARANTEED
RIGHT TO A COURT REPORTER
PURSUANT TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SUPREME COURT DECISION IN
JAMISON BE DESKTOP IT'S NOT
IMPORTANT NO TRANSCRIPT NO
APPEAL NO COURT REPORTER NO
TRANSCRIPT. BUT HERE'S THE
PROBLEM THERE'S BEEN A CREATED
CRISIS OF A LACK OF OFFICIAL
COURT REPORTERS IN THE COURTS
THROUGHOUT ALIFORNIA BORN VIA
A COMBINATION OF LAYOFFS
FURLOUGH DAYS EXPENDITURE ON
ELECTRONIC RECORDING EQUIPMENT
STAGNATING WAGES AND THE
STATUTORY TRANSCRIPT RATE WHICH
IS NOT SEEN AN INCREASE IN
THIRTY TWO YEARS. THAT'S RIGHT
OUR ONE HUNDRED AND FIVE YEAR
OLD STATUTORY RAPE BY WHICH
OFFICIAL COURT REPORTERS ARE
BOUND HAS ONLY SEEN ONE
INCREASE IN IT SINCE ITS
INCEPTION. AND I WAS THIRTY TWO
YEARS AGO. ORDERS ARE PAY INTO
WAYS THEY'RE SO AS EMPLOY FOR
THEIR TIME SPENT IN THE COURTS
TRANSCRIBING THE OFFICIAL
VERBATIM RECORD AND IS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS FOR
TRANSCRIPT PROCREATION
PRODUCTION. THE CURRENT
STATUTORY RATE HAS NOT KEPT
PACE WITH THE COST OF DOING
BUSINESS WHICH INCLUDES COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THEIR
TECHNOLOGICAL DEVICES COMPUTER
PROGRAMMING SYSTEMS PAPER
STORAGE AND EVEN POSTED. YES WE
HAVE INSTANCES OF COURT
REPORTERS OR SPENDING MORE
MONEY ON POSTAGE FOR TRANSCRIPT
THAN THEY ACTUALLY GET PAID FOR
THE TRANSCRIPT. THE UNFORTUNATE
REALITY IS THAT THINGS HAVE
GOTTEN SO BAD THAT THE
COMBINATION OF SALARY IN
TRANSCRIPT RATE STAGNATION BUT
IT IS BECOME MORE LUCRATIVE FOR
COURT REPORTERS TO WORK AS
FREELANCERS AS THEY CAN CHARGE
EIGHT TIMES THE STATUTORY RATE
ON THE OPEN MARKET. AND ALL
THAT DOES IS FURTHER WIDENED
EVER GROWING CHASM BETWEEN THE
TWO SYSTEMS OF JUSTICE ONE FOR
THE RICH AND ONE FOR THE POOR
WHERE WEALTHY LEAD AGAINST CAN
HIRE PRIVATE JUDGES AND
FREELANCE REPORTERS AND THOSE
OF LIMITED MEANS. WHO MUST RELY
ON COURT REPORTERS TO EXERCISE
THEIR RIGHTS UNDER THE LAW
DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE ACCESS TO
THE COURTS HAVE NOT BEEN
COMPLYING WITH JAMESON BE
DUSTED DECISION IN ANY REAL
WAY. THERE'S NO OBLIGATION
UNDER EXISTING LAW THE INDIGENT
LITIGANTS ARE ADEQUATELY AND
APPROPRIATELY INFORMED OF THEIR
RIGHTS UNDER THE LAW NOR IS
THERE ANY OBLIGATION THAT THEY
BE ADVISED OF THE CONSEQUENCES
OF THEIR RIGHTS UNDER APPEAL.
SHOULD THEY NOT HAVE A COURT
REPORTER. FURTHER THE QUARTER
NOT ON NOT HIRING FOR. SAID
THEY MAY BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH
AMOS AND THE COURTS HAVE SO
REDUCED THE NUMBER OF COURT
REPORTERS. VIA LAYOFFS FOR THE
DAYS AND FAILING TO RECRUIT
REPLACEMENTS THAT IT ALL BUT
IMPOSSIBLE TO COMPLY. JUST LAST
WEEK SEVEN COURT REPORTERS AND
THREE COURT CLERKS WERE LAID
OFF IN ALAMEDA COUNTY. UNDER
THE AUSPICES OF NECESSARY
BUDGET CUTS THE SAME KIND IT
COUNTY THAT WE JUST HEARD ABOUT
THE REMOTE REPORTING EXPERIENCE
AND JUDICIAL COUNCIL CLAIMS
THAT THERE BEEN NO LAYOFFS AS
IT RELATES TO REMOTE. RECORDING
PROCEDURES AND- AND
APPEARANCES. DESPITE OUR
BEGGING AND PLEADING WITH THE
COURT EXECUTIVE OFFICER TO
RETAIN THESE VITAL EMPLOYEES
AND DESPITE EVERYONE'S
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL BE PASSING A
BUDGET WITH COURT DOCUMENTATION
DOLLARS IN A MATTER OF WEEKS.
THESE ESSENTIAL PLEASE UPON
WHOM THE PEOPLE OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY MUST RELY TO EXERCISE
THEIR RIGHTS UNDER THE LAW.
UNCEREMONIOUSLY AND CRUELLY LET
GO. WE HAVE TWO BUDGET
PROPOSALS WE HAVE SUBMITTED TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES THE FIRST
IS A TWENTY EIGHT CENT PER
FOLIO INCREASED OF THE
STATUTORY TRANSCRIPT RATE. AT A
COST OF SEVEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR THE SECOND IS
A THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR ANNUAL
INVESTMENT TO THE COURTS FOR
THE PURPOSES OF HIRING AND
RETAINING. OFFICIAL COURT
REPORTERS FOR PURPOSES OF
COMPLYING WITH JAMESON BE
DESKTOP. NOW ON TO COURTS IN
THE TIME OF COLD IT ALSO AN
EXTRA BIG INEXTRICABLY LINKED
IS THE EXPERIENCE OF OUR COURT
REPORTERS WORKING IN THE COURTS
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND OUR
POSITION ON THE PROPOSAL. TO
MAKE PROMOTE PROCEEDINGS AND
APPEARANCES PERMANENT. OUR
COURT REPORTERS ARE NOT ONLY
TASKED WITH PROVIDING THE
OFFICIAL VERBATIM RECORD THEIR
LICENSES DEPEND ON IT. DURING
COVERT WE HAD A RAMPANT PROBLEM
STATEWIDE IN EVERY COURT IN
EVERY COURTROOM. WITH BEING
ABLE. TO DO OUR JOBS BECAUSE WE
SIMPLY HE COULDN'T HEAR. WE ALL
THE ON SAY. THE POWER YEAR
WORSE HAS. OR THEIR VOTE AS
MARC OR THEY GOT DROPPED OFF
ENTIRE. OUR REPORT EXTRA ALL OF
THAT AND MORE. THIS YEAR JUDGES
MUTING ARE FAILING TO MUTE-
LAWYERS PARTIES OR WITNESSES
PEOPLE TALKING OVER ONE ANOTHER
PEOPLE WITHOUT CAMERAS MAKING
IT IMPOSSIBLE TO DISCERN WHO
WAS SPEAKING AND WHEN- WE EVEN
HAVE ONE INSTANCE WHERE WE HAD
TWO OPPOSING SIDES LET AGAINST
AND ONE INTERPRETER- THE TO
LITIGANTS WERE NOT IN. ENGLISH
SPEAKERS AND THEY WERE ALL ON
ONE PHONE LINE AND OUR COURT
REPORTER WAS COMPLETELY UNABLE
TO DISCERN WHO IS SPEAKING OR
WHAT WAS BEING SAID. BUT THE
EXISTING TECHNOLOGY JUST DOES
NOT WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE IN
ORDER TO ENSURE EQUAL ACCESS TO
JUSTICE. THEY HAVEN'T REVIEWED
THINGS LIKE HOW DO PEOPLE WITH-
HEARING LIMITATIONS PEOPLE WITH
LIMITED ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY-
HOW DO THEY PARTICIPATE IN THE
SYSTEM EQUALLY AND GET EQUAL
ACCESS uJUSTICE.
CORTESE MADE A POINT ABOUT
REALLY LIMITING THE TYPES OF
PROCEEDINGS BUT EVEN WITHIN
THAT WHEN YOU DRILL DOWN THERE
ARE IMPLICATIONS THAT HAVEN'T
BEEN CONSIDERED YOU KNOW THERE
ARE- CRIMES OF MORAL TO.
TURPITUDE THAT ARE YOU KNOW ON
THE FEDERAL LISTS THAT ARE ONLY
INFRACTIONS BUT IF YOU PLEAD
DOWN FROM A MISDEMEANOR- THERE
ARE IMMIGRATION CONSEQUENCES TO
THAT SO WE CANNOT PUT ANYBODY
AT A DISADVANTAGE PARTICULARLY
THOSE. THAT ARE ALREADY SAYS
YOUR ECONOMICALLY
DISENFRANCHISED OR
DISENFRANCHISED IN ANY OTHER
WAY- SO WE STRONGLY URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO REJECT THE TBL- TO
EXPAND REMOTE FROM FROM BROKE
MARMO PROCEEDINGS AND
APPEARANCES AND MAKE THEM
PERMANENT AND INSTEAD REALLY.
TAKE A LONG HARD LOOK AT THE
EXPERIENCE OF COURT USERS AND
COURT WORKERS- DURING THE
PANDEMIC. ON IN CLOSING- THE
COURTS ARE YOU KNOW HAVE BEEN
DRAMATICALLY UNDERFUNDED BUT
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS WE REALLY
ARE SEEING IS THAT THE FUNDING
IS NOT BEING DEDICATED AND
DIRECTED BY THE LEGISLATURE. IN
SUCH A WAY THAT THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL IMMEDIATELY DISTRIBUTE
SET DOWN TO THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
ENSURE THAT CORPORATIONS CAN
CONTINUE. AND SO ANY ADDITIONAL
DATA DEDICATION AND DIRECTION
OF THE FUNDING ALLOCATED. TO
ENSURECOURT OPERATIONS AND
EQUAL ACCESS TO JUSTICE. IS
MOST APPRECIATED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE- OF THE- AND YOUR
CONTRIBUTION YOU ARE ON THE
GROUND AND WHAT YOU SAY HAS
ENORMOUS VALUE FOR ALL OF US-
MISS SANCHEZ JUST- COMMENTED.
ABOUT THE A PROPOSAL FOR
EXPANDING REMOTE COURT
PROCEEDINGS- I JUST WANNA ASK
MAYBE ONE OTHER MEMBER OF THE
PANEL MAYBE MISS. MARC COULD
YOU- GIVE A SHORT OF YOUR
OPINION AS TO THIS PROPOSAL TO
EXPAND REMOTE COURT PROCEEDINGS.
THANK YOU YES WE WOULD BE IN
SUPPORT OF THAT OUR- OUR STAFF
HAS BEEN ABLE TO FULLY
FUNCTION- I'M WORKING REMOTELY.
OBVIOUSLY IN SOME CASES- WE
WOULD PREFER IN PERSON AND LIKE
IN THE INSTANCE OF A JURY TRIAL
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT BUT-
GENERALLY WE DO SUPPORT REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS. OKAY- OKAY AND UP
YES MISS HI MARK. I THINK I'M
GETTING WORSE FOR PRONOUNCING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I DID ALSO
JUST WANT TO COMMENT ON THE
REMOTE COURT PROCEEDINGS-
QUICKLY WE SUPPORT THE
FLEXIBILITY THAT REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS OFFER BUT WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE LANGUAGE AS IT
IS IN THE TRAILER BUDGET BILL
AT THIS TIME- BECAUSE IT DOES
NOT PROVIDE ANY OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE LEAD AGAINST TO HAVE A SAY
IN WHETHER OR NOT THEY WILL BE
REQUIRED TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY WE THINK THE LANGUAGE
THAT APPLIES TO THE INFRACTIONS
IS MORE APPROPRIATE. THAN A
LANGUAGE THAT IS MUCH MORE
BROAD- A FOR THE CIVIL
PROCEEDINGS INDEPENDENCE WE
HAVE BEEN FULLY REMOTE
INDEPENDENCE A CART L. A.
COUNTY IN TWENTY EIGHT
COURTROOM SINCE JUNE SO WE HAVE
EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE WITH
pHAVE TO SAY THAT THE VIEW FROM
THE BENCH AT TIMES IS DIFFERENT
THAN THE VIEW FROM THE WELL-
AND THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THE REMOTE
PROCESS IS EXCELLENT IN OTHERS
WHERE IT IS RIGHT VERY VERY
CHALLENGING IT DOES NOT ALWAYS.
PROVIDE EQUAL ACCESS TO JUSTICE
EQUAL ACCESS TO THE COURT
PROCESS- AND PUTS LITIGANTS
ANDERSON EXTREME DISADVANTAGE
AND AT TIMES EVEN IN DANGER- OR
THEIR EMOTIONAL WELL BEING
ESPECIALLY IN THE DEPENDENCY
ARENA IS SERIOUSLY NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED BY THE REMOTE
PROCEEDING- AGAIN I WILL BE
PROVIDING MORE EXTENSIVE
WRITTEN COMMENT BECAUSE I KNOW
WE'RE SHORT ON TIME THEY DID
WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT WE
THINK THAT THEY CONCERNS RAISED
BY THE LA ARE SPOT ON AND THAT
IF THE LEGISLATURE DOES MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS ITEM THAT IT
SHOULD HAVE SOME- RESTRICTIONS
AND GUIDELINES AND ENSURE THAT
THE LITIGANTS HAVE THE ULTIMATE
ABILITY TO REQUEST IN PERSON.
OR A QUESTION ABOUT A REMOTE
AND IT NOT BE A 100%
DETERMINED- WITHOUT THEIR INPUT
AND THAT THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO
BE IN PERSON IF THAT IS WHAT
THE CASE DEMANDS. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MEMBERS
QUESTIONS ARE COMMON THEY JUST
WANT SEE THE MANAGER I JUST
WANNA SAY A- THE DIVERSITY OF
TESTIMONY HERE AND IT KIND OF
GIVES. READ IT'S TO WHAT YOU
WERE SAYING THAT- IN YOUR
EARLIER COMMENTS ON THE EARLIER
ITEM THAT. BUT THERE'S A LOT
HERE THAT NEEDS TO BE FLUSHED
OUT STILL IN AB JUST PARTED
ISSUES HEARING FROM EVERYONE IN
GETTING. ALL THE FACTS ON THE
TABLE I THINK- SOME OF THE
THINGS WE HEAR. S. CONCERNS.
AGAIN WOULD WOULD EXIST
REMOTELY OR IN PERSON- AND
WE'VE ALL FOR EXAMPLE I AM I'M
NOT PICKING ON EITHER WITNESSES
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT BECAUSE I
TAKE ALL THIS VERY VERY
SERIOUSLY- THE IMMIGRATION
ISSUE FOR EXAMPLE WE'RE ALL
FAMILIAR WITH AND YOU KNOW
SEEING THE CASES OF- YOU KNOW I
SEE JUST WALKING RIGHT INTO
COURT ROOMS- BEEN AND I'M NOT
SURE. IF YOU WERE HERE IN THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE AGAIN TO
REITERATE THAT THE POLICY
COMMITTEE BUT I. YEP YOU KIND
OF WONDER WHAT. WHAT IF YOUR
POLICY IT- GOAL IS PROTECTION
OF THOSE LITIGANTS- WHICH IS
BETTER AT EIGHT MAYBE IT'S
BETTER TO BE OFFSITE I DON'T
KNOW IF IT IS. ALL THAT NEEDS
TO BE THOUGHT THROUGH- A LOT
MORE THING FROM OUR STANDPOINT
SO- THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE'LL
HAVE TO DO THANK YOU THANKS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY GO. THANK YOU
SENATOR CENTER NEWMAN THANK YOU
MANAGER I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE- MISS CHANGES IS A
TESTIMONY WITH RESPECT TO. THE
COURT REPORTER ISSUE IN THE
CLEARLY THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT'S
GONE UNADDRESSED FOR. FAR TOO
LONG- BUT AS WE CONSIDER OTHER
CHANGES PARTICULARLY THE
IMPLEMENTATION TECHNOLOGY
CHANGES- THIS IS AN EASILY
ADDRESS PROBLEM ALL THINGS
CONSIDERED I MEAN AS FAR AS THE
BUDGET GOES SO THAT'S THE EASY
PART. THE HARD PART IS TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WITHIN THIS KIND
OF BROTH EVOLUTION TECHNOLOGY
WE TAKE THAT INTO ACCOUNT THAT
THE FIRST THING WE SHOULD DO IS
MAKE SURE THAT WE CERTAINLY PAY
FOR. THE NECESSARY TRANSCRIPT
ABILITY A PARTICULAR WHERE IT
CREATES. SERIOUS SERIOUS
PROBLEMS WITH RESPECT TO
APPEAL. AB SORRY I JUST WANT OF
SIZE THAT AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
WONDERFUL OKAY. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER. NO UP. OKAY WELL AGAIN-
I REALLY FOR. THE MEMBERS OF
THE PANEL THAT CAME FORWARD.
YOU GAVE US SOME. A LOT OF
INFORMATION AND CERTAINLY
THAT'S GOING TO BE VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TO- TO OUR BUDGET-
ARE BUDGET ISSUES SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOU. THANK
YOU. THE NEWS FLOW- WERE MOVED
ONTO ISSUE. TWENTY FOUR- AND
THIS IS SOME. DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE SPRING BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS OUR DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE- WHO IS GOING TO SPEAK
FIRST. I'M SURE THIS IS CHRIS
RYAN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE- WANT TO SAY THAT THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT OUR SPRING FINANCE
LETTERS THIS MORNING- ACTUALLY
THIS AFTERNOON- SO THANK YOU-
AGAIN WE HAVE TO BUDGET
PROPOSALS- SPRING BUDGET
PROPOSALS TO PRESENT TODAY THE
FIRST ONE IS THE BEER OF-
GAMBLING CONTROL AND THEN WE
ALSO HAVE THE- DIVISION OF
MEDICARE FRAUD AND ELDER ABUSE
A PROPOSAL- JOINING ME TODAY I
HAVE A YOU'LL LANDA MORE- WHO'S
ARE ACTING BUREAU DIRECTOR FOR
THE BUREAU OF GAMBLING. CONTROL
FOR QUESTIONS AND ALSO JENNIFER
YOU ARE WHO IS OUR CHIEF
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR
THE DIVISION ABOUT MEDICARE
FRAUD AND ELDER ABUSE- SO THE
PROPOSAL RELATED TO THE
GAMBLING CONTROL. DIVISION OR
BUREAU OF GAMBLING CONTROL I
REQUEST THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS AND TWENTY
TWENTY SIX POSITIONS-
SPECIFICALLY THE FUNDING WOULD
BE FOR TWENTY PERMANENT
EXISTING POSITIONS TO BECOME
PERMANENT AND- SIX POSITIONS
SIX NEWLY CREATED POSITIONS TO
PROVIDE ADMINISTRATIVE AND
OTHER SUPPORT FUNCTIONS- TO THE
OPERATIONS. OF THE BUREAU OF
GAMBLING CONTROL WITHIN THE DOJ
IS THE STATE LAW ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY WITH SPECIAL
JURISDICTION OVER GAMBLING
ACTIVITIES WITHIN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND IS THE ENTITY
THAT CONDUCTS BACKGROUND
INVESTIGATIONS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION. ON GAMING LICENSE-
AND WORK PERMIT APPLICATIONS- I
WOULD NOTE THAT THIS PROPOSAL-
AND IS A REDUCTION IN WHAT WERE
CONSIDERED TEMPORARY RESOURCES
AND THESE RESOURCES- PREVIOUSLY
WERE ALLOCATED IN THAT TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT AT
APPROXIMATELY FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS AND THIRTY TWO
POSITIONS. AND PROPOSAL IS
FIRST POINT FOUR MILLION. OUR
NEXT PROPOSAL RELATES TO THE
DIVISION OF MEDICARE FRAUD AND
ELDER ABUSE. AND THIS PROPOSAL
REQUEST- A TOTAL OF THAT
PRICING THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS. MOST OF THAT FUNDING
IS FEDERAL GRANT FUNDS AND THEN
THERE IS A STATE MATCH I
REQUIRED TO BRING THOSE FEDERAL
FUNDS TO CALIFORNIA- THEM THIS
FEDERAL FUNDS ARE TYPICALLY 75%
AND WITH THE STATE MATCH OF
TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. AND THE
FUNDS ARE UTILIZED FOR THE
PURPOSE OF. BASICALLY
INVESTIGATING- AND PROSECUTION
OF MEDICARE FRAUD IN BOTH
CRIMINAL AND CIVIL COURTS. AND
SO WITH THAT I WILL TURN T
BACK TO YOU FOR QUESTIONS AND
AGAIN WE HAVE STAFF AVAILABLE
THEY CAN ANSWER ANY OF YOUR
QUESTIONS. OKAY. THANK YOU
MISTER RYAN- THE L. A. O. HAVE
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. I
NEED TO LEAVE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
WE DON'T HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL BUT
ARE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU THANK YOU-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ANY
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS. THE CLERK
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND YOU HAVE NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS ON. OKAY MEMBERS ANY
QUESTIONS REMEMBERS. THE SIR
COULD I JUST HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS ON THE BUREAU OF
GAMBLING CONTROL. AND IF YOU
HAVE THIS OFF THE TOP BUT IF
YOU GIVE ME A ROUGH IDEA AS TO
THE PERCENTAGE OF CASES THAT
YOU HAVE RELATED TO OWNERSHIP
MANAGEMENT LICENSING UP- AND
THE- YOU KNOW EMPLOYEES OR
POTENTIAL EMPLOYEES CLEARANCE
FOR THOSE JOBS. READ EULA AFTER
A AND A LOT OF MORAL HAND
ACTING DIRECTOR OF THE BUREAU
OF GAMBLING CONTROL I AND I DO
HAVE THAT INFORMATION BASED ON
A FIVE YEAR AVERAGE OF
APPLICATIONS RECEIVED
APPROXIMATELY 23% OF THOSE
APPLICATIONS ARE OWNERSHIP OR
MANAGEMENT OF A CARD ROOM. I'M
IN 77% IS PROBABLY OUR- OKAY.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I
COULD SEE IF I GET THIS RIGHT
IN TERMS OF THE TABLE THAT YOU
PROVIDED THAT SOMEWHERE YOU'VE
GONE SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED- IN THE BACKLOG. TO
EIGHT HUNDRED FORTY TWO IS THAT
CORRECT IN MY READING THAT
RIGHT. I DON'T KNOW WHO'S GOING
TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION. A LOT
OF MORAL I BELIEVE AND IN THE
IN THE PROPOSAL YOU HAVE THAT
IS THE BACKLOG HOWEVER THE
CURRENT BACKLOG OF APPLICATIONS
ACTUALLY DOWN TO ORTY. I'M
SORRY SEVEN WHAT WAS THE NUMBER.
CURRENT BACKLOGS. FORTY EIGHT
FORTY EIGHT. OKAY SO IF THE
BACKLOG WHICH LOOKS LIKE YOU'VE
DONE AN INCREDIBLE JOB OVER
THESE LAST FEW YEARS I GUESS
WITH THE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
SO WHAT'S THE NEED- FOR
PERMANENT POSITIONS- IF THE
BACKLOG HAS BEEN. SIGNIFICANTLY
OF ALMOST TOTALLY ARE DEALT
WITH. I WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO MAKE THE PROGRESS IT
HAS ON THE BACKLOG WITHOUT THAT
I'M THIRTY TWO POSITIONS THAT
WERE OPERATE TEMPORARILY- THIS
REQUEST- AFTER WE DID A
REASSESSMENT WE BELIEVE THAT WE
STILL NEEDS PLENTY OF THOSE-
POSITIONS ONGOING AND
PERMANENTLY I'M TO CONTINUE TO
MAINTAIN THE BACKLOG AT THE
LEVEL IT IS NOW- HOPEFULLY
RESULT TOGETHER. AND PREVENT
FUTURE BACKLOG. OKAY. OKAY I
THINK THAT'S ABOUT IT- THANK
YOU ALL VERY MUCH FINAL NO MORE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OKAY WELL- I
APPRECIATE YOU ALL- WOMEN THEM
JUST LOCAL MORE TIME ON THE
MEDIC CAL- THE SAME THING JUST
ASK THE LAST QUESTION AGAIN
SIMILAR TO- THE- THE GAMBLING
CONTROL B. C. P. WHAT ABOUT THE
A MINUTE CAL FRAUD AND ELDER
ABUSE HOW DO YOU JUSTIFY. UN
INCREASE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS JENNIFER YELLER CHIEF
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL FROM
THE DIVISION OF MEDICAL FRAUD
AND ELDER ABUSE SO. DIVISION OF
MEDICAL PROBLEM ELDER ABUSE AS
MISTRANSLATED IS PRIMARILY
FUNDED BY A GRANT FUNDING FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. RIGHT
NOW THAT'S ABOUT FIFTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS UNFORTUNATELY
OUR STATE SPENDING AUTHORITY TO
HAS NOT KEPT PACE WITHOUT
AMOUNTS- LEAVING US ABOUT
THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS SHORT.
OF THAT WE'RE REQUESTING THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION FROM THE
FALSE CLAIMS ACT FUND- ADDRESS
OF THE FEDERAL GRANT THIS MONEY
WILL BE USED TO- PURCHASE
EQUIPMENT HARDWARE AND SOFTWARE
THAT BRINGS OUR DIGITAL
FORENSICS UP TO PAR UP TO SPEED
WITH- THE CHANGING.
CIRCUMSTANCES IN CHANGING
EQUIPMENT AND TECHNOLOGY AROUND
US BUT ALSO PROVIDE US WITH A
TECHNOLOGY FOR OUR
INVESTIGATIVE AUDITORS TO GO
THROUGH AND ANALYZE AND UTILIZE
THINGS LIKE BANK INFORMATION IN
PARTS FOR INVESTIGATION ALSO
KRITIS WITH FUNDS TO. EQUIP OUR
SPECIAL AGENTS WITH THE
PROPERTY AND EQUIPMENT THAT
THEY NEED TO- BE UP TO SPEED
WITH POST REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDING POST TRAINING THERE
ARE NUMBER OF THINGS THAT THE
DIGITAL VERSION HAS HAD TO HOLD
OFF ON. THAT BECAUSE OUR
SPENDING IS ALREADY HAS NOT
KEPT PACE WITH OUR FEDERAL
GRANT SO EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE
BUDGET HEAD FOR THE H. B. COURT
MAN OR THE HARDWARE THE
SOFTWARE WE'VE BEEN UNABLE TO
PURCHASE IN THE PAST BECAUSE WE
HAVE NOT HAD THE FINES SO THIS
WOULD BASICALLY BE. BRINGING
US- BACK IN ONLINE WITH WHAT WE
FOR. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALL RIGHT HERE NO MORE PRESS A
CALL THING TO VERY MUCH YOU- WE
MOVE ON- ISSUE TWENTY FIVE.
ISSUE TWENTY FIVE IT FALLS
UNDER THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS AND THIS
IS ON STRENGTHENING JAIL
OVERSIGHT- IS THAT MISS HOWARD.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR
DORADO MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS
KATIE HOWARD I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE B. S. C. C.
HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY TO TALK
ABOUT THIS SPRING FINANCE
LETTER E. C. P. THAT'S DIRECTLY
CONNECTED TO THE V. ASSISI'S
INSPECTION RESPONSIBILITIES ON
THE SAYS I AM VERY PLEASED TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO FOLLOW
UP ON THE CONVERSATION WE HAD.
DURING THE MARCH BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE HEARING ON THE TOPIC
OF OUR INSPECTIONS AND THE
RECENT REPORT FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND THIS B. C. P. TRULY HELPS
TO PROVIDE THE RESOURCES THAT
WE NEED TO FULFILL THE NEW
DIRECTION WE HAVE FROM THE
GOVERNOR TO STRENGTHEN JAIL
OVERSIGHT SO I WANT TO GIVE A
VERY VERY HIGH LEVEL SUMMARY OF
THE B. C. P. AND ON THAT OF
COURSE I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
THERE ARE TWO COMPONENTS TO
THIS B. C. P. PROPOSAL ONE IS-
THE ADDITION OF VERY- IMPORTANT
STAFFING RESOURCES SO THAT WE
CAN DO MORE WITH OUR JAIL
INSPECTION AND LOCAL DETENTION
FACILITY INSPECTION
RESPONSIBILITIES- IT'S FOURTEEN
POSITIONS EIGHT INSPECTORS AND
THEN SIX ANALYSTS AND MANAGERS
TO MANAGE ALL THE INFORMATION
DATA COLLECTION AND OTHER
ASPECTS OF OUR INSPECTION
FUNCTION. AND THEN THE SECOND
COMPONENT IS- A STATUTORY
CHANGE THAT MAKES IT CLEAR THAT
OUR INSPECTORS WOULD HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DO SOME OF OUR
INSPECTIONS UNANNOUNCED SO
THOSE ARE THE TWO COMPONENTS OF
THE PROPOSAL AND I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT WHAT WE BELIEVE THE
THIS BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL
WILL DO- THE BIGGEST CHANGES
THAT THE INSPECTIONS WILL BE
CONDUCTED ANNUALLY AT LEAST
ONCE EACH YEAR RATHER THAN.
OVER A TWO YEAR OR DANIEL CYCLE
ON THERE WILL BE SIGNIFICANT
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR THE
COUNTIES TO CORRECT ANY
COMPLIANCE ISSUES THAT ARE
IDENTIFIED AND TO WORK WITH
AGENCIES. TO DEVELOP RESPONSIVE
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS- IT'LL
ALSO ALLOW FOR MUCH MORE
REGULAR PUBLIC REPORTING AND
FOLLOW UP WITH OUR BOARD AT
PUBLIC MEETINGS ABOUT THE ITEMS
OF NON COMPLIANCE. AND THAT
INCLUDES DIRECTING AGENCIES TO
APPEAR BEFORE THE BOARD WHEN
ITEMS OF NON COMPLIANCE REMAIN
ON CORRECT UNCORRECTED- WE WILL
HAVE STREAMLINED PROCESS SEES
AND A FAR BETTER ABILITY TO
MANAGE ALL OF THE DATA AND
REPORTING. IN SUPPORT OF THIS
STRONGER COMPLIANCE FUNCTION
AND- AS I ALREADY MENTIONED THE
SPECIFIC AUTHORIZATION FOR
UNANNOUNCED INSPECTIONS SO WE
ARE- VERY PLEASED AND VIEW THIS
AS A BIG STEP TOWARD. MEETING
THAT DIRECTION THAT WE'VE BEEN
GIVEN TO STRENGTHENED JAIL
OVERSIGHT. HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE.
OKAY THANK YOU MISS HOWARD- L.
A. O. PLEASE GIVE YOUR COMMENTS.
IF K. O'NEILL. IT RUNNER NOW
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE OFFICE AND
STAFF ASKED ME TO PROVIDE A BET
A BRIEF SUMMARY OF OUR REPORT
ON THE BOARD'S STANDARDS AND
INSPECTION PROGRAM THAT WE
RELEASED IN FEBRUARY SO I'LL GO
AHEAD AND DO THAT UNLESS YOU
HAVE ANY OBJECTIONS MIND CHAIR-
AND THEN I WILL GET INTO OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE PROPOSAL
FOR YOU TODAY. UNDERFILL THERE
ARE ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
LOCAL DETENTION FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT ARE THESE ARE
OPERATED BY COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT'S INFORMATION
DEPARTMENTS AS WELL AS CITY
POLICE DEPARTMENTS AND THE
HOUSE. ADULTS AND JUVENILES IN
VARIOUS STAGES OF THE ADULT AND
JUVENILE JUVENILE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEMS. THE BSE C. IS
OVERSEEN BY THIRTEEN MEMBER
BOARD. SEVEN OF THE SLOTS ARE
DESIGNATED FOR LEADERS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES FOURTEENTH
OVER AT SIXTY FOUR OF HIM
OVERSEE FACILITIES THAT ARE
INSPECTED BY THE PROGRAM.
STATUTE CURRENTLY REQUIRES THE
SEC TO DO THREE THANKS ONE
REVISE THE STAIR CONSIDER
REVISING THE STANDARDS ONCE
EVERY TWO YEARS AND THE SEC
DOES THIS ESSENTIALLY THROUGH-
VOLUNTEER WORKING GROUP'S THAT
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
BOARD. TO INSPECT EACH FACILITY
ONCE EVERY TWO YEARS WHICH THE
FCC DOES THROUGH A- TEAM OF
ABOUT EIGHT STAFF INSPECTORS.
AND THREE TO SUBMIT INSPECTION
REPORTS TO LOCAL OFFICIALS AND
A SUMMARY REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE EVERY OTHER YEAR.
AND I ALSO WANT TO KNOW THE BSE
IS NOT AUTHORIZED TO ENFORCE
THE STANDARDS. IT DOES HOWEVER
PROVIDE SOME TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AS IT GOES ABOUT
ITS- INSPECTION ACTIVITIES
THOUGH IT IS NOT REQUIRED TO
STATUTORILY. IN THE BUDGET FOR
THE PROGRAM IS ABOUT TWO POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS CURRENTLY.
AND AS WAS MENTIONED- AB I MISS
HOWARD DAY GOVERNOR IN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY DIRECTED THE SEC
TO MAKE THREE CHANGES TO THE
PROGRAM AND CITING- CITING
INADEQUATE OR INSUFFICIENT
OVERSIGHT AND JAILS AS PART OF
HIS RATIONALE FOR THOSE CHANGES
AND THOSE ARE TWO ONE ALIGN
STANDARDS WITH BEST PRACTICE
YES YOU SEE INDICATES THAT
THEY'RE DOING THIS- BY
PROVIDING THE WORK GROUPS THAT
CONSIDER REVISIONS TO THE
STANDARD WITH. ADDITIONAL
MATERIALS TO REVIEW ON WHAT
MIGHT BE BEST PRACTICES- FOR
DIFFERENT LOCAL DETENTION
FACILITIES TO CONDUCT
ADDITIONAL INSPECTIONS AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AT
FACILITIES WITH A HISTORY OF
NON COMPLIANCE WHICH UP UNTIL
THIS- APRIL FINANCE LETTER
WHICH I'LL DISCUSS IN A MOMENT-
THE SEC HAD INDICATED IT WOULD
DO WITHIN EXISTING RESOURCES
WAS ESSENTIALLY GOING TO BE
STEPPING UP INSPECTIONS- DOING
SOME ADDITIONAL INSPECTIONS AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE- WITHIN
EXISTING RESOURCES BUT NOW IT'S
REQUESTING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO GO FURTHER. ESSENTIALLY- AND
THEN THREE TO INVITE LEADERS OF
NON COME AS A TO PUBLIC
MEETINGS TO DISCUSS THAT
REASONS BEHIND THEIR- NON
COMPLIANCE. AND SO MOVING INTO
OUR ASSESSMENT OF THE PROGRAM
AND IT'S REALLY VERY SIMPLE.
WHEN WE LOOK AT ANY PROGRAM WE
ASK WHAT IS THE MISSION AND
GOALS OF THIS PROGRAM IS IT
MEETING THOSE GOALS. AND IN
THIS CASE WE FOUND THAT THE
MISSION AND GOALS OF THE
PROGRAM ARE NOT CLEAR AND THAT
LEAVES DISCRETION TO THE
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE LIKE I
SAID THERE'S THREE PRETTY.
SIMPLE STATUTORY REQUIREMENTS
AND THAT THE PROGRAM MUST FILL
AND THERE'S A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT WAYS THAT A PROGRAM
COULD FULFILL THOSE- AND IN
TURN PURSUE A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT. GOALS IN DOING SO-
FOR EXAMPLE ONE CAN WRITE A
REPORT THAT'S GEARED TOWARD
PRIMARILY AN AUDIENCE OF-
CORRECTIONAL ADMINISTRATORS OR
ONE COULD WRITE A REPORT GEARED
TOWARD- MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
BOTH WOULD FILL THE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT BUT EACH WOULD
ACHIEVE A DIFFERENT GOAL- AND
SO THIS LACK OF GOALS. AND
CLEAR GOALS AND MISSION IN
ADDITION MAKING IT DIFFICULT
FOR US TO EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROGRAM
ALSO UNDERMINES LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT OF THE PROGRAM. SO AT
A HIGH LEVEL OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE TO
ESTABLISH A CLEAR MISSION AND
GOALS AND STATUTES FOR THE
PROGRAM. AND THEN TO ALIGN THE
MEMBERSHIP OF THE BOARD- I'M IN
THE PROGRAM STRUCTURE ITSELF
WITH THOSE MISSION AND GOALS.
AND OF COURSE THE LEGISLATURE
COULD USE ANY GOALS- THAT IT.
DESIRES BUT WE IN OUR REPORT
DIDN'T RECOMMEND AND CERTAIN
GOAL AND MISSION AND CERTAIN
GOALS. AND NOT RECOMMENDED
MISSION IS TO PROMOTE LEGAL
HUMANE AND SAFETY CONDITIONS IN
LOCAL DETENTION FACILITIES. AND
THEN THE GOALS- WE RECOMMEND
FOR SPECIFICALLY- TO SUPPORT
THAT BROADER MISSION. WE CAME
UP WITH THESE GOALS BY THINKING
ABOUT. BEST PRACTICE LOOKING
OPSEC CURRENTLY DOES TALKING TO
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS EXCITER
AND THINKING ABOUT WHAT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE FOR THE STATE TO DO
VERSUS OTHER. ENTITIES IN THIS
OVER OUR OVERALL KIND OF
OVERSIGHT ECOSYSTEM AROUND-
LOCAL JAILS- LOCAL DETENTION
FACILITIES AND THOSE GOALS WE
CAME UP WITH AND RECOMMEND OUR
ONE. HOPE LOCAL LEADERS
DETERMINE AND MEET LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS- AROUND DETENTION
FACILITY OPERATIONS THIS IS-
WHAT WE HAVEN'T COME TO
UNDERSTAND IT SEEMS IS BY AND
LARGE WHAT HOW THE S. THE
PRIMARY GOAL THAT THE FCC HAS
SORT OF BEEN FORMALLY OPERATED.
AND TOWARD IF YOU WILL AND THEN
VIEW BY AND LARGE WHAT PROPOSED
CHANGES CAN TO SUPPORT WHICH
I'LL GET INTO IN A MINUTE- BUT
WE RECOMMEND AND WE DO THINK
THAT'S A LOT OF- AN IMPORTANT
GOAL SO WE RECOMMEND.
ESTABLISHING THAT AS A GOAL WE
ALSO RECOMMEND ESTABLISHING AND
THREE MORE SAID THE SECOND ONE
BEING TO FACILITATE
TRANSPARENCY SO THAT LOCAL
LEADERS AND STAKEHOLDERS. CAN
HOLD FACILITIES ACCOUNTABLE
SHOULD THEY CHOOSE TO DO SO.
THREE TO PROMOTE EQUITABLE
PROVISION OF LEGAL HUMANE AND
SAFE CONDITIONS AND FOR TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND STATEWIDE LEADERSHIP TO
FACILITATE SYSTEMIC IMPROVEMENT.
AND WE RECOMMEND- LIKE I SAID
THAT THE LEGISLATURE- I AM
REVISED STATUTE TO CHANGE BOARD
MEMBERSHIP TO ALIGN WITH THESE-
GOALS BECAUSE WE FOUND THAT THE
CURRENT BOARD IS NOT ALIGNED
WITH THOSE FOUR GOALS. AND IN
ADDITION TO REQUIRE EIGHT
SPECIFICALLY WE FOUND THAT
THERE WAS A LACK OF- MEMBERSHIP
DESIGNATED SLOTS FOR PEOPLE
WITH PROFESSIONAL EXPERTISE. IN
AN AFGHAN ADVOCACY AND
OVERSIGHT OF DETENTION
CONDITIONS- AND THEN WE
RECOMMEND DIRECTING THE SEC TO
PROVIDE A PLAN TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND HOW IT WILL
ALIGN THE PROGRAM WITH WHATEVER
GOALS THE LEGISLATURE SETS- AND
IN. KEEPING WITH THE FOUR GOALS
THAT WE RECOMMEND WE CAME UP
WITH SPECIFIC ELEMENTS WHICH WE
DESCRIBE IN DETAIL MORE DETAIL
IN THE REPORT AND WE THINK THE
PLAN SHOULD HAVE- AND THESE
THESE INCLUDE- I PLAN TO CREATE
MORE SPECIFIC. STANDARDS
BECAUSE WE FOUND THAT THE
STANDARDS WE THINK ARE NOT
SPECIFIC ENOUGH- AS WELL AS A
PLAN TO ENSURE THAT THE
STANDARDS ARE EQUITABLE- AND IN
ORDER TO MAKE THESE CHANGES WE
THINK THERE NEED TO BE SOME
CHANGES TO THE MEMBERSHIP OF
THE WORK GROUPS. AND SO THERE'S
A VARIETY OF OTHER ELEMENTS OF
THIS PURPOSE- OF THIS PLAN THAT
SHE ALMONDS THAT WE THINK
SHOULD BE IN THIS PLAN- THAT WE
LAID OUT IN THE REPORT AND
HAPPY TO GO INTO MORE DETAIL IF
ANY OF THAT- MEMBERS WOULD LIKE.
BUT IN ANY OF TIME I WILL. AND
MOVE ON. I JUST WANT TO MAKE
AND FIRST OF ALL BEFORE MOVING
ON- RECORDS ON THE APRIL
FINANCE LETTER I DIDN'T WANT TO
KNOW WHEN. WHEN HE PIECE ABOUT
OUR REPORT IS THAT. ONE ELEMENT
THAT IS NOT- WE DO NOT
NECESSARILY RECOMMEND
EXPLICITLY BE INCLUDED IN THE
PLAN. IS AN ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM NBCC HAS MENTIONED
DOES NOT CURRENTLY HAVE AN
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM- THE
REASON WE DON'T. RECOMMEND
ADDING ONE NECESSARILY IS
BECAUSE THERE IS- CURRENTLY AN
ATTORNEY GENERAL OPINION
LONGSTANDING OPINION.
DETERMINING THAT THE STANDARDS
ARE NOT STATE I'M REIMBURSABLE
MANDATES BECAUSE THE FCC
DOESN'T HAVE AN ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM. SO OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE KEY
ELEMENTS THAT WE RECOMMEND THIS
PLAN INCLUDED ARE CRAFTED VERY
INTENTIONALLY- TO. USE
TRANSPARENCY AND TECHNICAL SUCH
ASSISTANCE AS MORE OF THE SORT
OF STEERING OF CHANGES APPROACH
AS OPPOSED TO ENFORCEMENT- IN
AN ATTEMPT TO M. INTENTIONALLY
TO AVOID A POTENTIAL MANDATE
BUT ALSO- MORE POSITION THE
STATE TO BE ASSISTING LOCAL
STATE STAKEHOLDERS- IN HOLDING
THEIR FACILITIES ACCOUNTABLE
RATHER THAN THE STATE DOING IT
THROUGH ENFORCEMENT- I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT. AND THEN
MOVING ON TO OUR COMMENTS ON
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU
TODAY. TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IT'S INTERESTED IN
TAKING OUR RECOMMENDATIONS- FOR
REFORMING THE BOARD. WE THINK
IT WOULD BE PROMOTE PREMATURE
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO EXPAND THE PROGRAM AT THIS
TIME GIVEN THAT ONCE IT HAS
THIS PLAN DIED AND WE RECOMMEND
IT. DIRECT THESEC TO PROVIDE
WE THINK IT WOULD BE IN A MUCH
BETTER POSITION TO ASSESS
WHETHER OR NOT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED FOR THE
PROGRAM. HOWEVER ON THE FLIP
SIDE TO THE EXTENT THE
LEGISLATURE CHOOSES NOT TO-
IMPLEMENT OUR RECOMMENDED
REFORMS THEN WE FIND THAT THE
PROPOSED EXPANSION IS
UNNECESSARY- AND THIS IS
BECAUSE- WE FIND THAT THE-
CURRENT PROGRAM AS WELL AS AND
THE PROPOSED EXPANSION WOULD BY
AND LARGE SEEM TO SUPPORT. THE
FCC'S CURRENT TERM INFORMAL
GOAL OF PROVIDING SERVICE TO
LOCAL AGENCIES IN THE FORM OF
HELPING THEM- DETERMINE MEET
LEGAL REQUIREMENTS AND- WHAT
WELL THAT IS ONE OF THE GOALS
WE RECOMMEND IT'S NOT. IT'S AND
WE DO RECOMMEND THREE OTHER
GOALS WHICH AND BY AND LARGE
THAT DOES SEEM TO BE THE AREAS-
WHEN WE LOOKED AT AT AT WHERE
THE PROGRAM WE NEED IT AND THE
BOARD AND THANK AND SUCH WOULD
NEED TO BE REFORMED. TO ME WE
DID NOT WE HAVEN'T HEARD- AND
THE SEC WAS NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE
EVIDENCE THAT LOCAL AGENCIES
ARE. DISSATISFIED. WITH THE
CURRENT LEVEL OF SERVICE THEY
RECEIVE. FROM BSE. AND THEN
FINALLY. SO JUST TO WRAP THAT
UP THAT HE SAID WE RECOMMEND
REJECTING THE PROPOSED STAFFING
AND ASSOCIATED RESOURCES-
BECAUSE OF PREMATURE IF THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS TO GO WITH
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS AND AN
UNNECESSARY IF THE LEGISLATURE
CHOOSES. NOT TO REFORM THE
BOARD- BUT THERE ISN'T THERE
ARE TWO SMALL PIECES WE DO
RECOMMEND APPROVING ONE IS A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
ANNUALLY ON GOING TO- SO THAT
TO FIND A CONTRACT TO ALLOW
INSPECTORS TO IN- INPUT DATA
ELECTRONICALLY WHILE THEY'RE
DOING INSPECTIONS WHICH WE
THINK. WOULD BE A USEFUL TOOL
FOR THEM. I AND THEN BUDGET
TRAILER LEGISLATION THAT WOULD.
ALLOW INSPECTORS TO DO
UNANNOUNCED VISITS BOTH OF
THESE TOOLS WE THINK WOULD BE
USEFUL UNDER THE CURRENT
PROGRAM OR A POTENTIAL LAND
REFORM PROGRAM IS WE RECOMMEND
SO WE RECOMMEND GOING AHEAD AND
IMPROVING DOES- AND THEN I'M
HAPPY TAKE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU- I HAVE OF MISS
HOWARD- OR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE RESPOND TO THE L. A.
O.'S COMMENTS. BUT EIGHT THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST NAMING
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I KNOW-
SEGNO MENTIONED THAT. THESE
RESOURCES ARE CURRENTLY
UNNECESSARY BUT WE REALLY DO
BELIEVE THAT IT'S- PROPOSAL
ACTUALLY DOES STRENGTH AND
BETTER OVERSIGHT OF COUNTY
JAILS IN CALIFORNIA- BY
PROVIDING MORE FREQUENT
INSPECTIONS AND HAVING B. THE
SEC DIRECT ANY- COUNTIES THAT
ARE FOUND OUT OF COMPLIANCE TO
APPEAR BEFORE THE BOARD. REALLY
DOES INCREASE OVERALL
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
BY ENGAGING THE PUBLIC IN THE
PROCESS- OF THE ANNUAL
INSPECTIONS AND WATER FOUND
THERE IN THOSE REPORTS
ADDITIONALLY THE RESOURCES
REQUESTED ANY ANALYTICAL STAFF-
WOULD HELP TO. KIND OF MORE
CONSISTENTLY AND REGULARLY TO
PROVIDE UPDATES AS IN ESTONIA
AGAIN MENTIONED AS FAR AS THE
TARGET AUDIENCE BY KIND OF
TRACKING CERTAIN TRENDS AND
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE- MORE
ACCESSIBLE REPORTS AND FINDINGS
OF WHAT THE SEC INSPECTORS FIND
WHEN THEY DO THE ANNUAL
INSPECTIONS. AND AGAIN JUST
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
INSPECTIONS WE THINK IT. IS A
MUCH BETTER USE OF RESOURCES
BECAUSE IT WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
BMCC INSPECTORS TO FIND
COUNTIES THAT ARE IN COMPLIANCE
AND- POTENTIALLY OUT OF IN
COMPLIANCE AND THEN AGAIN
REPORT TO THE BOARD AND THE
PUBLIC AT THOSE- OPEN HEARINGS.
TO KIND OF ENGAGE OUR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMUNITY AND VERY
STAKEHOLDERS SO WE SO WE ARE
VERY SUPPORTIVE AND DO YOU
THINK THIS PROPOSAL IS. IS VERY
ATTENTIVE TO INCREASING.
OVERSIGHT OF COUNTY JAILS.
THANK YOU. A MISS HOW WOULD YOU
LIE TO. ONLY JUST TO SUPPORT
WHAT MR EDELMAN HAS SAID- WE
THINK IT REALLY SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASES PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY
ABOUT WHAT OUR INSPECTION
PROCESS IS FINDING. THANK YOU.
I DO THINK OF THERE IS A
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM HERE. FOUR
NINE IN AUGUST THERE'S SOME
LEGAL ISSUES ABOUT THE BSE SEE
NOT BEING AUTHORIZED TO ENFORCE
OUR OUR STANDARDS AND SO DOING
THE INSPECTIONS AND TAKING
CERTAIN STEPS. OF SORT OF SEEMS
TO GO AROUND THE EDGES INSTEAD
OF RIGHT TO THE CORE OF THE
ISSUE- IF THE STATE LAW DOES
NOT AUTHORIZE I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S A WAY OF FIXING THAT.
BUT THERE'S GOTTA BE SOME MORE
DIRECT TEETH PUT INTO THIS IT
SEEMS TO ME THEN THE WAY THAT
HAS BEEN DONE BECAUSE- OF WE
CAN GO ON AND GIVE MORE AND
MORE RESOURCES. BUT WHERE IS
THAT NON COMPLIANCE GOING TO BE
RESOLVED. AND HOW'S IT GOING TO
BE RESOLVED. I THINK TO ME
THAT'S A THAT'S A BIG ISSUE OF.
MEMBERS QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CENTER CORTESE. YEAH I WOULD
AGREE WITH YOUR COMMENTS OF
UNITY GUARDING. THE I CALL THE
DILEMMA OF NOT HAVING
COMPLIANCE IT IT ALMOST SEEMS
LIKE- YOU KNOW ALTHOUGH WE- I
THINK ALL US HERE PRESENTAR-
VERY MUCH BELIEVERS IN
TRANSPARENCY WITHOUT THE
COMPLIANCE PIECE IT ALMOST
SEEMS LIKE IT'S CREATING A ROAD
MAP. OF FOR LITIGATION SO THAT
YOU KNOW WE'RE POSTING
ESPECIALLY PETE BEST IN THE-
THE REAL TIME CONTRACT FREE FOR
YOU KNOW IT'S A MODEST AMOUNT
BUT HOW ARE WE ARE WE
CONTRIBUTING- TO TRANSPARENCY.
FOR THE WORLD WHICH
FUNDAMENTALLY IS A GOOD THING
BUT WITHOUT ANY WAITED TO- TO
REMEDY THE PROBLEM ON OUR OWN
WHICH- I'M HEARING YOU SAY BUT
I'M SURE OF. IT ALL IN TO TRY
TO HEAD OFF BECAUSE SOMEBODY
HAVING TO BRING- LITIGATION A
PRIVATE PARTY OR ATTORNEY
GENERAL DOCTRINE OR. TOO MUCH
THERE BUT IT IT DOES CONCERN ME
AND- IT CONCERNS ME THAT IF WE
KEEP GOING IN THAT DIRECTION
WITHOUT COMPLIANCE WORDS
INVESTING IN AN INFORMATIONAL
SYSTEM. THAT THE- I GUESS
SOMEONE CAN SAY TO WHAT END YOU
KNOW TO WITHIN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THIRTY SEVEN
ANYTHING ELSE. OKAY WELL I DO
THINK WE HAVE SOME- SOME
SERIOUS ISSUES- AT THIS POINT-
WERE HOLDING OPEN- WE'RE
HOLDING OPEN THE ISSUE THERE
WILL BE NO VOTE TODAY. OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH FOR BEING WITH US THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK- I THINK NOW
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT. I
HAVE A RIGHT. CAN I THINK THE
PUBLIC THEN IS ON IN OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE'VE TAKEN UP FOR
ANY OF THE VOTE ONLY A MOTIONS-
SO LET'S SEE- MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AGAIN. ON ANY OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE DISCUSSED
OR ANY OF THE VOTE ONLY MOTIONS
NOW IS THE TIME. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO WISH TO COMMENT AS DIRECTED
BY THE CHAIR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO YOUR PHONE PRESS ONE ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE YOU WILL BE
QUEUED UP TO MAKE YOUR COMMENT.
AND A T. T. OPERATOR WILL
ACCESS YOUR ONE OUTSIDE OF THE
CONFERENCE AND PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR MIND NUMBER. FOUR THREE.
WE WILL NOW GO TO MY- THIRTY
SIX. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES OKAY
MY NAME'S KATIE VAMPANEZE AND
I'M A SPANISH INTERPRETER
WORKING IN ALAMEDA COUNTY AND
I'D LIKE TO SPEAK TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWENTY ONE I'VE BEEN
WORKING REMOTELY FOR JUST ABOUT
A YEAR NOW AND I WANT TO GO
WITH THE COURT REPORTER
COMMITTEE I USE THAT ABOUT THE
MULTIPLE PROBLEMS ENCOUNTERED
THAT IN SEVERELY INTERFERE WITH
THE L. A. P. COURT USERS
ABILITY TO. MEANINGFULLY IN
HEARING AND TO ENJOYACCESS TO
DOCTORS AND SHE PEOPLE THINK
OVER ANOTHER ARE THERE CANNOT
BUT BREAK UP WE ARE I NEED TO
TELL IF WE NOW ARE BRING UP NOT
BEING HEARD IN CUSTODY GRANT
PLATE YOU AND THERE'S NO WAY
KNOW IF THERE HEARING ON YOUR-
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE TO AND
THERE'S NO TO TELL IF THEY CAN
HEAR PEOPLE APPEAR TO BE A- AND
CAN BE OR HEAR OF THE SPEAKING
ONLY THE IN. NORTH CAN BE HEARD
BY THE PARTY NAME IS OF THE
ISSUE I COME UP AND IN THE PAST
YEAR. I WOULD SAY THAT. MAYBE
PERCENT THE TIME. THERE'S I'M
MEANINGFUL ACTORS TO JUSTICE IF
NOT AND NOT ABSOLUTELY. I SO I
REALLY WANT TO MAKE THE LEAD TO
COULD NOT ADOPT TRAILER UNDER
HERE BUT INSTEAD TAKE THE TIME
TO WITH THOSE US WHO ARE IN THE
OF WE CAN- IN A VERY ON RUSH
MANNER THE IS- ISSUE MANY MAY
AT YOUR THAT WE'VE COME AGAIN.
THANK YOU. IS. 877-226-8152 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT ONE
EIGHT TWO. EIGHT ONE SEVEN OF
DO THE CONSTRAINT REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING UP
PROTOCOLS WE'RE GONNA LIMIT THE
TESTIMONY TO A MAXIMUM OF ONE
MINUTE. I'M GOING TO ASK EACH
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC PROVIDING
COMMENTS PLEASE KEEP YOUR
REMARKS WITHIN ONE MINUTE. AND
THAT IS SO WE GIVE IT- OTHERS
WHO WANT TO SPEAK- SO MODERATOR
WE CAN CONTINUE. WITH OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE.
FORTY SIX. YES GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES THANK YOU.
COUNSEL RICHARD PAN AM OF
INTERPRETER ALSO IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY WHERE A GREAT DEAL OF-
VIDEO REMOTE COURT HEARING HAVE
BEEN HELD FOR THE LAST YEAR
AND- ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES WE'VE
BEEN WORKING THAT WAY FOR ABOUT
A YEAR AND- IT- IT'S WONDERFUL
TO PROTECT- THE WORK AND SOME
OF THE PUBLIC FROM- AROUND. I'M
GRATEFULHAVE BEEN A TO STAY
WITH MY AS I HAVE ONLY HAD TO
GO- OCCASIONALLY AND FIRST TO
THE CORE. HOWEVER I MEAN HOW
PEOPLE WHO THIS THAT THE
SPANISH IN TERMS. ARE HAD A
MUCH LESS ANOTHER GAS HAS
WIDENED FOR THEM ONE CAN'T
ENTER FOR THEM PERSON WHEN
WARRANT. WOULD. MAKE IT
ANNOUNCED- HMM NOT. CALENDAR IN
WHICH THE JUDGE AND THE
ATTORNEYS ARE VERY PRESSED FOR
TIME AND THE OTHER PROBLEM IS
THAT A GREAT DEAL OF THE TIME
WE INERPRETERS ARE UNABLE TO
ESTABLISH COMMUNICATION AT ALL
WITH THE PERSON WHO NEEDS THE
INTERPRETING BECAUSE THEY THE
PERSON DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO
ACTIVATE THE MICROPHONE-
THEY'RE ONLY USING A TELEPHONE
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE SAID. YOU'RE
NOT ABLE TO SEE THINGS THAT ARE
NOT- IT FOR THE MOST PART TECH
SAVVY OF COURSE THERE IS DAMAGE
SPEAKERS MIDDLE CLASS WELL-
SOME COURT YOU OR VERY GOOD AT
THEIR- A DIFFICULT- JUST AS
WHEN IT'S COLD IT HOW IT HAS.
THE COMMUNITY DISTRICT- IN THE
SAME WAY VIDEO REMOTE COURT IS
HAVING A VERY NEGATIVE EFFECT
THE TIMES THAT I HAVE GONE
PERSONALLY TO THE COURTHOUSE I
ALMOST ALWAYS HAVE SPANISH
SPEAKING USERS OF MAIENSCHEIN
HOW DO I GO TO THEY TOLD TO GO
TO TODAY. AND AT THE DEPUTIES
WON'T BUT ME IN- YOU NEED TO
USE THE COMPUTER YOU TO USE
THAT- THAT I DON'T HAVE A GOOD
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO THAT- ON MY
TELE THANK YOU. HEARTBREAK
THANK YOU YOU FOR IN. MONTEREY
CAN YOU BE GIVE ME TOTAL P.
WAIT TO TEST. MONTEREY ARE YOU
THERE. MADAM CHAIR PARDON ME
I'M SHOWING THAT WE HAVE AT
LEAST TWENTY SEVEN. OKAY PLEASE
R. REMEMBER THE MAXIMUM OF ONE
MINUTE YOU CAN DO IT IN LESS
TIME WE WOULD REALLY APPRECIATE
IT. CONTINUING. FORTY FIVE.
HELLO HELLO I'M FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY HI MY NAME
IS CAMILLE CHIYODA JUST LIKE
THE TO LOCK BUT ALSO ON ITS OWN
COUNTY COURT. WHERE WE'VE BEEN
AND- ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY OR OR-
THE BUS WAS OF THE BMW HAS BEEN.
REMOTE DURING COLD- I HAVE
ADMIT THAT I WINGING IT HERE AS
MOST OF US ARE BECAUSE THIS
CAME AS A TO US. THERE WAS MUCH
IN THE WAY OF OUT RECHARGE THAT
WAS NONE AND WE JUST OUT OF
THESE THE NOW. I IT'S QUITE
IRONIC THAT NOBODY IS OF
INTERVIEWING INTERPRETER WERE
ACTUALLY DOING THE WORK BEFORE
THAT REMOTE INTO AS WELL FINE
IT IS OF NOT I ALSO THINK IT'S
QUITE A THAT NOBODY IS AND THE
IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE HOPING TO
RELY ON WE AND TURN FOR ACCESS
TO OUR CALL THANK YOU PRESHOW
THANK YOU MUCH. AS UP AND OF MY
TIME YES THANK YOU FIND. THANK.
EIGHT YES GOOD AFTERNOON- MY
NAME MELISSA I HAVE INJURED AND
A. CORKER FORTY YEARS AND
WORKING WORK NOW FOR THE PAST
YEAR AND I JUST GOING TO RE
ENTER. THE ONLY THING MY CALL A
CALL HAS. AND IT STILL KNOCKED
I'M GRATEFUL THAT I'VE BEEN TO
DO BUT I'M FOR IT NOT WORKING
AND FRANKLY IN MY HOUSE ONE- TO
THE- JUST CAMPAñA IT. AND- IT.
NO ACCESS TO GET. FOR THE ONLY
T. L. AND I THE PRESENCE STATE
IT'S WORKING AND NEED YOU CAN
WITH US THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHY. FIFTY ONE. HI NAME IS
NAOMI ALSO ALSO AN ALUM COUNTY
SPAN CORE INJURY AND I WANT TO
REPEAT WHAT THEY HAS SAID. THIS
IS NOT ME LANGUAGE ACCESS FOR
LIMITED. SPEAKER THIS IS
PRECISELY THE POPULAR THAT DOES
HAVE INTERNET SIR THE HAVE THE-
IN IS GET ON. ACT TO CHEN AND A
RESULT. AND ALL I WILL LIKE TO
PUT OUT THAT THOSE THAT ARE
SAYING THE THIS IS TOTALLY
EFFECTIVE WORK ARE NOT THE RISK.
OF THE INTER SIR NOW THE OR THE
INTER PER THE SERVICE. WE HAVE
COURT REPORT AND IN. SAYING
THAT IS NOT WORKING. THAT'S
BECAUSE IT IS NOT WORKING AND
THEY'RE THE ONES WHO DO THE
WORK THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE
VOTE NOW THANK YOU. LINE THIRTY
FOUR. SH HI CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
YES HI YES MY NAME IS GABRIELLE
MORE THERE I AM- CERTIFIED
SPANISH INTERPRETER- WORKING IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY I HAVE BEEN
WORKING REMOTELY FOR
APPROXIMATELY THE PAST YEAR AND
I WANT TO ECHO AND AGREE WITH
THE COMMENTS THAT ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE MADE TO THIS
POINT I'M CALLING TO URGE YOU
TO NOT ADOPT THE TRAILER BILL
ON ABOUT HEARING I APPRECIATE
THE REMOTE INTERPRETATION. HAS
BEEN PUT IN PLACE TO SAVE LIVES
IN DURING THIS EMERGENCY HEALTH
CRISIS HOWEVER THE TECHNOLOGY
THEY'RE ABOUT TECHNOLOGY AND
THE PRACTICE IS FOR USING IT
PERCENT MANY MANY PROBLEMS MANY
OF WHICH HAVE BEEN DELINEATED
BY MY COLLEAGUES IN INDIA- THAT
COMMENT PROCEEDING MINE SO I
WON'T ELABORATE- BUT I DO JUST
WANT TO URGE A NO VOTE AND-
THANK YOU. AND PROGRESS MADE
AND THEY HEARD FROM THE TALK TO
AS WELL AS- THE RECIPIENTS AND-
AND ADEQUATE- THANK YOU NOT A
TEENAGE IT FIND. NINE FIFTY.
HELLO MY NAME IS MONICA AND MY
IS. IN THE COUNTRY SUPERIOR
COURT AND I IT WILL DIE TO ECHO
IN RETURN EVERYTHING COLLEAGUE
SENATE. I ADOPTING BILL TRAILER
BILL REMOTE HEARINGS ARE THIS
WAY THEY- RUSHED IT WITHOUT
REALLY IN. FROM THE MOST
SOURCES ON HOW DID YOU. WITH
ARE BEING TERM. INVESTIGATE THE
ACTION ANDTO DO IT IN THE BEST
WAY POSSIBLE BECAUSE THAT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF ANY PEACE NOT
HAVE THE ACCESS TO JUSTICE R.
V. FROM EVERY ANGLE YOU LOOK AT-IT AND WE ARE NOW COVERING
BASICALLY EVERYTHING. FROM
COURT CIVIL CRIMINAL EVERYTHING
WITH REMOTE. INTERPRETING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BASELINE. FOUR
FIND FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JANET
CHECK I AM AN INTERPRETER WITH
MATURE SUPERIOR COURT AND I'M
HERE BEFORE YOU TO TALK TO YOU
AND TO URGE EVERYBODY PRESENT
NOT TO ADOPT A TRAILER BILL FOR
REMOTE HEARINGS- I THINK
INTERPRETERS COURT REPORTERS
AND A LOT OF THE COURSE STAFF
SO THE FOREFRONT. WE ARE THE
PEOPLE ON THE FRONTLINE I CAN
TELL YOU REALLY WHAT'S GOING
ON. ACTUALLY GOING FOR WITH THE
BILL LIKE THIS WITHOUT TALKING
TO WORK WITHOUT ACTUALLY
KNOWING WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON
IS VERY DETRIMENTAL TO ANYBODY
IN ANY COURT. I MEAN OFTENTIMES
CONTRIBUTORS WE KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON HE WAS GOING ON WHEN
YOU SEE THE CARPOOL WITH THE
DIGITAL. WHEN SHE HELD IN
CUSTODY OUR PEOPLE WITH.
APPEARING REMOTE OF A LOT OF
THE KIND THERE. MUSIC THE HAWK
THE RIGHT TO BE HEARD AND
PARTICIPATE HEARING KERR JUST
TAKE AWAY THANK YOU NOBODY IS
THERE HELP ON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOT HAVE TO LYING HAD
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS JACK I AM
SECULAR DIRECT OF THE CAL ACT
TO JOBS. COMMISSION ARE LIKE TO
WITH ONE. SHE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. TAXES I SEE THERE ARE
BENEFITS TO REMOTE TO SEE. LAST
YEAR WE A REPORT I TO ACCESS
CAN REMOTE SEATING AND WAYS TO
MITIGATE. AND AVOID THEM WE
THINK THAT REMOTE BECAUSE K. DO.
AND CAN BE MET. AND AVOID BY
TEN THE CURRENT I. I'M TWENTY
THREE THE CANNOT ON THE IS I
THINK FUNDING CAN BE USED IN
PART FOR THESE. INFRASTRUCTURE
FUND CAN BE USED BY LEGAL AID
ORGAN. TO WILDLIFE AND OTHERS
TO CREATE REMOTE SIDE WITH THE-
TECHNOLOGY. TO HELP US WITH
ACTUAL WITH THE DO GOT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LINE. TWENTY
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON I'M HERE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LIAM
GRIFFIN WITH AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES COUNCIL-
CATCHING ON ISSUE TWENTY ONE
WANTED TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH THE PREVIOUS TESTIMONY BY
US YEAH YOU AND THE CONCERNS
THEY RAISED ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT AMOUNT
PROCEEDING AND IN OPPOSITION TO
THE TRAILER BILL ACCORDING
PLEASE- PROVIDED SIMILAR
FEEDBACK. TO US THANK YOU THANK
YOU. BLIND SEVENTEEN. HI THIS
IS JAN SCHMIDT AND THE DIRECTOR
OF THE STANISLAUS COUNTY LAW
LIBRARY I'M JUST CALLING TO
REMIND YOU OF THE BROAD
LEGISLATIVE AND COMMUNITY
SUPPORT BECOMING LAW LIBRARIES
HAVE HER VITAL ROLE AND I URGE
YOU TO PROVIDE A STABLE
RELIABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING WERE
A VITAL PIECE OF ACCESS TO
JUSTICE AND WE'VE BEEN BROKEN
FOR A VERY LONG TIME AND WE
DON'T WANT TO BE A CASUAL PIZZA
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION I
BELIEVE WE'VE SUBMITTED A
TRAILER BILL FOR YOU TO LOOK
AT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU WINDS.
FIFTEEN HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS LAUREN KLEIN AT THE LEGAL
AID ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
I'D LIKE TO THINK ABOUT IT YOU
TWENTY THREE FIRST I WOULD LIKE
TO UNDERSCORE THE IMPORTANCE OF
PROVIDING ONGOING FUNDING FOR
THE EQUAL ACCESS FUND THAT
INCLUDES THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR SATISFIED THAT THE
MENTION FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS WHICH ARE CRITICAL AT
NONPROFIT THE BEN FORCED UNDER
INVEST IN INFRASTRUCTURE OVER
THE YEARS THE FUNDING SHOULD BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ACCESS TO JUSTICE COMMISSION AS
AN ENTITY THAT'S READY TO COME
TO GO PURPOSES ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THOSE NOT ALREADY
FUNDED BY THE STATE BAR. I
CAN'T I WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
FEDERAL FUNDING FROM THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN CAN AND
SHOULD BE USED TO FUND LEGAL
SERVICES BUT THOSE FUND THEIR
POSITION TO SUPPORT SPECIFIC
SERVICES NAMELY SERVICES FOR
TENANTS AS WE HEAD INTO AN
UNPRECEDENTED ELECTION CRISIS
THAT CAN BE DONE AS WE LAID OUT
IN THE COMPLETE BILL FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN THE FEDERAL FUNDS
ARE NOT HOWEVER THE PENSIONS
ARE FLEXIBLE ENOUGH TO FUND THE
FULL RANGE OF LEGAL SERVICES
NEEDED BY LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS AND THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO BE NEEDED AFTER THE
PANDEMIC THANK ME LITTLE BLACK
THAT CAN. GET THAT. THANKS VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. WHY. THIRTY
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS KNOW AT BOTTOM ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR REQUEST ISSUE TWENTY
THREE PER LEGALLY BINDING OUR
RURAL LOW INCOME FARMWORKER
COMMUNITIES ARE DEVASTATED BY
THE COLBERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC
THERE ARE IN NEED OF LEGAL HELP
CONSOLE NO YOU'RE RIGHT
INDIRECT SERVICES. SO THEY CAN
ACCESS HELP LABOR INCOME RELIEF
EDUCATION HOUSING AND EVICTION
OF THEM ALONG WITH THE
INTERSECTION OF IMMIGRATION.
CONSEQUENCES THAT PUBLIC CHARGE.
OUR RURAL FAMILY. PASSED TO NOT
FORGET THEM. SECONDLY THE EARLY
FOUNDATION SUPPORTS THE NEEDED
FUNDING FOR THE TRANSCRIPT
REIMBURSEMENT FUND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU FOR CALLING. LINE SIXTY PRE.
MY NAME IS CARMEN RAMOS I'M A
QUICKLY TEMPERATURE WITH THE
SHOCKING SUPERIOR COURT AND I
AM URGING THE LEGISLATURE TO
VOTE NO ON LINE ITEM TWENTY ONE
THE TRAILER BILL- IT HAS BEEN A
DISASTER. TO BE ABLE TO PERFORM
COURT INTERPRETATION- THROUGH
V. V. R. I. B. TO REMOTE
CALIFORNIA ANY TYPE OF MOLD
PROCEEDING. RT SERVICE TO THAT
PEOPLE WHICH ARE THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY IN MY COUNTY AND I
BELIEVE- WOULD BE DISASTROUS TO
PARK. THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MODERATOR. PARDON ME MADAM
CHAIR LINE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND I APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT MIND FORTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO GUN
LINE FIFTY NINE. A LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS THE YOUNG MALE
SEAL I AM A CERTIFIED COURT
INTERPRETER FOR MANDARIN IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY I THINK WE ARE I
HAVE NOT WORKED VERY WELL
INDEED IT'S VERY POORLY IN MY
EXPERIENCE BY MYSELF AND
INTERPRETER HAVE NOT HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO PERFORM AT MY BEST
LEVEL DUE TO LIMITATIONS IN THE
SYSTEM AND MY CLIENT YEAH YOU
CAN HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO.
PARTICIPATE AS FULLY AS ENGLISH
SPEAKERS IF THEY FELT
INTIMIDATED PEOPLE OF THE
PANDEMIC THEY EVEN MORE SO NOW
HAVING TO OVERCOME TECHNICAL
OBSTACLES IN ADDITION TO
WHATEVER DIFFICULTIES THEY HAVE
ENCOUNTERED BEFORE WE ARE NOT
AFRAID OF TECHNOLOGY TECHNOLOGY
HAS A LOT OF LIVES DURING THAT
CONDEMNING THE BILL LET'S NOT
RUSH INTO THINGS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR CALLING. LINE.
FOR THREE. PARDON ME WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO LINE. THIRTY
FIVE. HELLO MY NAME IS CURTIS
DRAPES AND I'M A SPANISH
INTERPRETER AN EMPLOYEE OF THE
ALAMEDA SUPERIOR COURT THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY ONE
AND REITERATE THE CONCERNS OF
MY COLLEAGUES IN OPPOSITION TO
THE TRAILER BILL ON REMOTE
HEARINGS IN MY EXPERIENCE THEY
CREATE SERIOUS PROBLEMS THAT
THAT AFFECT THE ABILITY OF
ELLIE PIECE TO PARTICIPATE
MEANINGFULLY. MEMBERS PLEASE
TALK TO THOSE OF US WORKING ON
THE GROUND SO WE CAN EXPLAIN
HOW REMOTE HEARINGS ACTUALLY
IMPEDE LANGUAGE ACCESS I
RECENTLY DID A PATERNITY
INQUIRY INTO REMOTE DEPENDENCY
HEARING AND THE TERRIBLE AUDIO
QUALITY MADE IT IMPOSSIBLE TO
INTERPRET THE MOTHER'S
TESTIMONY. IT JUST DOESN'T WORK
WE NEED THESE PEOPLE TO BE IN
THE COURTROOM WITH US IN PERSON
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU. NINE SIXTY SEVEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS MICHAEL FERREIRA HE-
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF INTERPRETERS
LOCAL THIRTY NINE THOUSAND I'M
ADJUSTING LINE ITEM TWENTY ONE
FOR THEM TO SIT THERE AND SAY
THAT THIS IS WE I. IS REALLY
NOT TRUE AS A MATTER OF FACT
IT'S JUST A HODGEPODGE OF
PLATFORMS- AND GET. IT AT A
MACARONI SET UPS THEY DO NOT
ADDRESS- REAL MEANINGFUL
LANGUAGE ACCESS- THIS IS JEFF
IT. WHAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT. WHAT WE IN OUR
DIFFERENT- BARGAINING POWER AND
WE DEFINED AS THERE ARE USUALLY
CAN BE ARE INVOLVED AND- TO THE
JUDGES WANT TO DO IT- DOING IS
SAYING YES WE DO WE WANT THIS
WE WANT THOSE BUT YOU HAVEN'T
SOLVED ANY OF THE PROBLEMS WERE
STILL IN THE MIDST OF THE SORT
OF THING SO I THINK IT'S VERY.
VERY RESPONSIBLE GO FORWARD
AND- PUT THIS THING ON TO THAT
BILL- YOU KNOW PUT THAT RIGHT
ON BIG YOU HAVE TO CONSULT THE
PROBLEM YOU HAVE A GOOD LOOK AT
THE PROBLEM THANK YOU VERY
LARGE THEY ARE STILL IN THE
MIDST OF THIS. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LINE. FIFTY SIX. ZERO ZERO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THNK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME MY NAME IS CAROLYN
GASPARE I'M A RETIRED COURT
REPORTER FROM LOS ANGELES UNDER
NUMBER TWENTY THREE THE
TRANSCRIPT RATE INCREASE LAST
WEEK I DID THIS YEAR WE NEED TO
INCENTIVIZE COURT REPORTERS TO
JOIN THE COURTS WORKFORCE OF
THE COURTS AND COMPLY WITH
JAMISON VERSUS DASTAAN
PROVIDING A VERBATIM TRANSCRIPT
AS WELL AS THE ALLEGATION THAT
TO THE TRANSCRIPT REIMBURSEMENT
AND IS PRESSING AND I TO BE A
BIG SAID MORATORIUM IN JUNE ON
JUNE THIRTIETH. AND NUMBER
TWENTY ONE PLEASE DO NOT ABOUT
THAT TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WE
NEED A LEGITIMATE WORKING
GROUP'S REMOTE PRECEDING FAILED
FOR THE ELDERLY AND INDIGENT
LITIGANTS YOU DO NOT HAVE
COMPUTER ACCESS AND IS ONLY AS
GOOD AS THE WORST INTERNET
CONNECTION. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BLIND SIXTY EIGHT. YES WE
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR THE TO-
IF YOU REMEMBER THEY SHOW NOT
I'M TALKING ABOUT- IMPAIR
REMOTELY YES MARCH THE MARCH
UNITS IN KOREA WHERE A TO SAVE
LIVES BUT THAT DOESN'T THAT IS
THE WAY THAT WE WANT TO PERFORM
ON THE PHNOM PENH MAKE EMPIRE.
YES THANK YOU FOR SAVING US OUR
LIVES AND I'M FOR KEEPING US
SAFE DURING THE AND THAT MAKES
BUT THAT IS NOT. A WAY TO- HELP.
WHO GET ALLOW PEOPLE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO JUSTICE JUST LIKE
PEOPLE SAY I'M NOT GUILTY. AND
PEOPLE SAY I'M NOT RESPONSIBLE
THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO SAY I'M
NOT A COP. YOU KNOW DURING A
PROCEEDING I THINK THAT IN
PERSON IN THE WAY TO DO THINGS
CORRECTLY SO EVERYBODY CAN HAVE
ACCESS TO JUSTICE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LINE. FORTY SEVEN.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
THAT'S- YES I HI I'M REX AND
THE CARDINAL FROM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY- I'M ONE OF THE
INTERPRETERS MORE THAN A YEAR-
I WILL GO STRAIGHT TO WHAT I
WANT TO SAY WHICH IS. WE HAVE
EVEN PRIVATE FIRST OF ALL THAT
THE VIDEO REMOTE PLATFORMS WE
USE THEIR THE PROBLEM THERE IS
A DISASTER- AND PART OF IT IS
BECAUSE NOBODY EVER TALKED TO
US ABOUT HOW TO DO IT OR HOW IT
GETS ADJUSTED BROWN HOW TO DO
THAT THE BEST WAY POSSIBLE FOR
INTERPRETERS. SECOND PRIVATE
ATTORNEYS YET PRIVATE ATTORNEYS
GOING TO APPEAR BEFORE THE
COURT WITH NINE SEVEN SEVEN
EIGHT WHICH MEANS THEY
PREFERRED TO BE BEFORE THE
COURT PRETENDING AS IF THE
CLIENT IS NOT EVEN PRESENT AND
REFUSING TO REVIEW THE REMOTE
INTERPRETER RATHER THAN YOU THE
JOKE OF THE PLATFORMS THAT WE
ARE WORKING WITH THE LOS
ANGELES WE EVEN HAVE A TURN AND
WE DIDN'T HAVE JUDGES COMING
UP. BUT THEY REFUSED TO USE
REMOTE INTERPRETERS THANK YOU
I'M REALLY SORRY THAT YOU'RE
AFFECTING OUR LDP'S THE WAY IT
IS THANK YOU- APPRECIATE YOU.
THANKS FOR CALLING. PLYING
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON NUMBER
AND CHAIRED MANY IS TINA ABOUT
THE QUESTIONS MY PROPERTY AND A
FORMER LEGAL AID. AT WESTERN
CENTER WE ANTICIPATE THE LEGAL
NEEDS FOR CALIFORNIANS WILL
SUBSTANTIALLY INCREASE AS A
RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC BUT YOU
GOT THE LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE
THE EAF FUND AS WELL AS
TRANSCRIPTION BERSANT BIND AND
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO THE
COURT SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE AN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS TO THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK. THANK YOU.
BLIND. SIXTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS DON KNAPP
LANCASTER I AM ALSO A COURT
HEARD A FIGHT INTERPRETER FOR
SPANISH PRIME AN INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR WORKING IN AN
ACCOUNTING- HOW LARRY AND THEN
LOOK AT ALL MY OTHER. AND I
ALSO WANT TO JOIN MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE MENTION ABOUT OUR- HE
THAT ARE NOT TECH SAVVY THEIR
ELDERLY THEY'RE INDIGENT SOME
OF THEM DON'T EVEN HAVE A CELL
PHONE. THEY SHOW UP AT THE
COURTROOM THE COURT HOUSE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO I'VE HAD TO FIND
PEOPLE ON ON MY OWN PERSONAL
PRIVATE CELL PHONE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE HALLWAY SO THAT
THEY CAN HAVE ACCESS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THEIR HEARINGS
THIS IS NOT WORKING IT IS JUST.
A MATTER AND IT'S TIME FOR
EVERYTHING TO GO BACK TO WHAT
IT USED TO BE AND ALLOW PEOPLE
TO HAVE THE RIGHT TO ACCESS TO
JACK AT ALL PEOPLE. DO THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THE LINE SIX
NINE. HELLO THIS IS OUT OF
FAMILY JOINING IT I'M CALLING
FROM SOME OF MY COUNTY I WORK
HERE WE ARE WORKING HERE FOR
MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS AND I
DEFINE SAY THAT REMOTE-
INTERPRETING IS NOT WORKING AT
ALL I'LL BE THERE ARE
SITUATIONS WHERE- YOU KNOW WE
TRIED TO INCORPORATE AND
SOMETIMES THE JUDGES WILL NOT-
IF WE'RE DOING TRYING TO THE
CONSECUTIVELY. THEY WILL STOP
BY- SOMETIMES MAY DELAY MORE
SOME TIME BUT WHAT HAVE YOU- OR
OR IF WE ROUTE FOR REPEAT
EXAMPLE COMES YOU DON'T A
REPEAT FOR- WE DON'T HAVE TIME
SOMETIMES FOR- FOR INTERPRETING
WE DON'T GET TO. GET THE TIME
IT IS SEVEN EIGHT IT HASN'T
WORKED OUT FOR US- THE PEOPLE
THAT USE OUR SERVICES.
SOMETIMES I IN THE DARK THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HECK
HAPPENED SOMETIMES WHEN THEY
ASK WHAT HAPPENED THEY'LL JUST
KIND OF LIKE OKAY I'LL EXPLAIN
IT TO YOU LATER. WHICH REALLY
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE IT NEEDS TO
BE EXPLAINED WHEN THEY ARE
THERE I MEAN THEY HAVE A RIGHT
TO. HEAR WHAT IS BEING SPOKEN
TO THEM THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO
SEE WHENEVER THEY THEY FEEL
LIKE THEY HAVE- THANK THE RAINY
BELIEVE THEIR VOICE. THANK YOU
HAND. OUT LOVE. THANK YOU.
BLIND HI THIS IS GRAHAM
CERTIFIED COURT INTERPRETER
ALSO WORKING IN CINEMA COUNTY
AND JUST TO REITERATE- SPEAKING
ON ISSUE TWENTY ONE I URGE YOU
TO VOTE NO ON THE TRAILER BILL
REMOTE HEARINGS- AND REALLY
CONDUCT THE APPROPRIATE
RESEARCH TO SURVEYS- RESEARCH
WHAT OTHER WHAT OTHER COUNTRIES
ARE DOING FOR AT REMOTE
HEARINGS AS IT IS RIGHT NOW IT
DOES NOT WORK THERE'S BUDGETARY
CONCERNS WHEN WE'RE DOING
HEARING SOMETIMES ON THEIR OWN
WHICH IS WHAT OUR COURT USES WE
SPEND HOURS TRYING TO GET THE
FUNCTION IT TO WORK AND THEN.
OTHER OTHER HEARINGS ANOTHER
DEPARTMENT THEY'RE BEING CALLED
NINE SEVEN SEVEN BECAUSE
THERE'S N INTERPRETER
AVAILABLE TO RUN VER TO THE
OTHER HEARING SO IT REALLY IS
PROBLEMATIC I URGE YOU TO VOTE
NO ON AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. LINE.
FIFTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ALEXANDER BELL TRAN-
AND BETTER CERTIFIED
INTERPRETER I'M A CONTRACTOR.
RIGHT RIGHT. CALIFORNIA DID NOT
STOP THE TRAILER. HEARING ALL
MY COLLEAGUES THAT THAT WORKING
AT A VERY PROBLEM THAT WE ARE
NOT RANKING. THE PATIENT. LEGAL.
WHAT. WHAT THE BALL GOING.
MANDATE BY THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
AND- WHAT. THE CONTACT. AND
THAT'S THE PART THAT WE PLAY A
ROLE IN THAT RIGHT. YOU GOT IT
UP. THANK YOU. PINE FOUR. A
NUMBER CAMERON IN WE
DISSOCIATES OR COUNTY THIS
REGARDING THE ROLE REMOTE
ACCESS- YOU KNOW WE YOU
CONSIDER THE COURTS RECORD WITH
TECH. WE SUGGEST YOU TREAD LIFE
WHEN CAN EXPANDING AND DORM THE
PERMANENT OUR CLIENT COULD NOT
RECEIVE PAIN FOR YOU BY THE
COURT. REGARDING THE CAR ON THE
NEW OPPORTUNITY THAT CREATES
HAVEN'T SEEN THOSE WITH IN
ORANGE COUNTY IN FACT ACCORDING
POLICE STILL BEING FURLOUGHED
ONE DAY A MONTH WE SUPPORT THE
INCREASE FOR THE COURT
REPORTERS AND WE ALSO SUPPORT
THE INCREASE- FOR TRIAL COURT
POPULATION FINDING IMPACT
CONSIDERING- YOU'RE SITTING ON.
THE DOLLARS IN EXCESS REVENUE
YOU CAN CERTAINLY FIND THE
COURTS ABOVE AND BEYOND WHAT IS
PROPOSED TO ME COULD YOU DO.
THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
CALLING. FIND SIXTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MATTER CHAIR MEMBERS
ACROSS YOUR HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COURT
REPORTERS ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
INTERPRETERS AND I DID PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES ON ITEM TWENTY ONE WE
URGE YOU TO REJECTED THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE- THE
LANGUAGE FOR REMOTE I HEARINGS
IS JUST TOO MUCH TOO SOON
WITHOUT PROPER DISCUSSION AND
LISTEN TO THE WORKERS WHO ARE
THEIR DAY TO DAY AND ALSO THE
USERS- IN COURT TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE PROBLEMS ARE- THAT ARE
OCCURRING. LET ME REMIND YOU
THAT IT BELIEVES THREE DAYS AGO
WAS THE FIRST TIME THAT USUAL
COUNCIL OFFICIALLY OUT OF FOR
SOME OF OUR REPRESENTATIVES TO
SHARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS SO
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE BUT THREE
YEARS AGO THERE WAS A SURVEY
RESPONDENTS. ARE USING VIDEO
REMOTE INTERPRETING AND EACH
ARE THE INDIVIDUALS USE THEIR
VIDEO REMOTE INTERPRETING ABOUT
40% OF THE DEATH THE RIGHTS
WERE NOT PROTECTED IN THE USE
OF VIDEO REMOTE I'M ALSO MAY
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA TERMS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE EVEN THOUGH
THE BE- TRAILER BILL I'M JOINED
BY CIVIL MARC STERN SCHOOL OF
SAMPLERS IN THE STATE IS NOT
WORKING AND THEN WE ALSO
SUPPORT ITEM TWENTY THREE FOR
THE G. R. F. AND B. TRANSCRIPT
RATE INCREASE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. LINE. FORTY NINE. HI MY
NAME'S SANDY WALTON MEMBER OF
SEIU OF THE CORE REPORTER AND
ALSO PAST PRESIDENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION H ALSO WOULD LIKE
TO ECHO COMMONSENSE MANY OTHERS
AND ASK YOU TO REJECT THE
LANGUAGE FOR THE TRAILER BILL
RIGHT NOW AND- ALLOW IT TO BE
ANALYZED AND STUDIED FURTHER AS
THERE'S MANY PROBLEMS WITH IT
AND I ALSO- SUPPORT THEIR
TRANSCRIPTS INCREASE BEING
SPENT OVER THIRTY YEARS SINCE
WE'VE HAD AN INCREASE. AND ALSO
TO SUPPORT FUNDS GOING TO THE
TRF THANK YOU. SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WINDS
FORTY. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
YES. MY NAME IS CHRISTINE
ARAMBULA SPANISH INTERPRETER IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY WHERE WE HAVE
HAD REMOTE HEARING FOR THE MOST
PART OF THE PANDEMIC- WE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS WAS A
TEMPORARY MEASURE DUE TO THE
CRISIS OF GOOD- DISEASE- AND
BECAUSE WE'RE COMING TO THE END
OF THAT ERE YET AND I VERY
MUCH OPPOSE AS MY COLLEAGUE-
THE ADOPTION OF THE TRAILER
BILL- THIS IS NOT A MATTER OF
THROWING MONEY INTO. ONE OF THE
MANY DIFFERENT PLATFORMS BETTER
BE UTILIZED ACROSS THE STATE
THERE IS NO ADEQUATE TECHNOLOGY
AS MEDICARE HAS ALREADY
DETERMINED DEMONSTRATED THAT B.
R. I. IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE FOR
THE MAJORITY OF JUDICIAL
HEARING- AND THE ADDICTION
CRISIS- THAT IS GOING TO JUST.
EXPLODE IS AN EXAMPLE OF WHY
WE'RE HEARING ARE NOT- IT'S NOT
A QUESTION OF CONVENIENCE BY
HOLDING THINGS REMOTELY WHEN
PEOPLE ARE LITERALLY- AT WORK
OR IN DRIVING CARS OR BUSES
TRYING TO ATTEND- THEY ARE
HEARING THAT IS NOT. ACCESS TO
JUSTICE IT IS I'M JUST AND I
ALONG WITH ALL MY IT-
COLLEAGUES DEMANDED THE
INTERPRETERS B. CONSULTED IT
WOULD BEFORE ANYTHING IS-
ADOPTED. ON THE SUBJECT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK MADAM CHAIR
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE THEY DON'T
BUT THEY PUSH TO SPEAK. OKAY
CAN YOU OF WHAT WE CALL OUT
MORE PLEASE. IN CASE SOMEBODY
THREE GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO HAVE
A COMMENT AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. WE DO HAVE
AT LEAST TWO PEOPLE WHO
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE.
FIFTY FIVE. AND PARDON ME LINE
FIFTY FIVE IS NOT AVAILABLE
JUST A MOMENT WILL HAVE ONE
MORE PERSON. LINE. THIRTY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS OF A LAND WHERE I MAKE A
SPANISH INTERPRETER I WORKED IN
A FACTORY COUNTY MEDICAL
MEDICAL EVERYTHING THAT MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE CHECKED I DO
BELIEVE WE SHOULD BE CONSULTED
BEFORE THEY SET UP. SO I REALLY
HOPE THAT YOU WILL KNOW. AND
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING. THE
TEMPLE LINE FIFTY FIVE
GUIDELINES OF THE FIVE YEAR ONE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MARIA
CRUZ I'M THE SPANISH
INTERPRETER IN OUR- SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WE WERE NOT ALLOWED TO
STAY HOME SO I EXCEPT FOR A FEW
WEEKS SO WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH OUR REMOTE INTERPRETER. IN
COURT. THE PLATFORM WE USE THIS
TEAM. THERE ARE MULTIPLE ISSUES
WITH MY COLLEAGUES HAVE ALREADY
VOICED BY AB I HAVE PERSONALLY
EXPERIENCED. INTERTECHNOLOGY
BEING SO BAD THAT I HAVE HAD TO
WALK AWAY AND INFORMED THE
JUDGE I'M SORRY YOUR HONOR I
MUST DISQUALIFY MYSELF BECAUSE
I AM ABLE TO HEAR AND THAT
WOULD BE THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
THE DEFENSE ATTORNEY OR
WITNESSES. THE RECORDERS THAT A
COURT REPORTERS HAVE ALSO HAD
TO DO THE SAME THROW THEIR
HANDS UP IN THE AIR AND SAY I'M
SORRY YOUR HONOR I CANNOT.
PROCEED BECAUSE I CANNOT HEAR.
IT'S A BIG PROBLEM THAT YOU
HAVE ALREADY HEARD SO PLEASE DO
NOT GO AHEAD WITH THIS TRAILER
BILL IT NEEDS TO BE STUDIED
FURTHER. YES THERE IS- A PLATE
OR REMOTE INTERPRETING BUT IT
MUST BE UNDER THE RIGHT
CIRCUMSTANCES WITH THE RIGHT
TECHNOLOGY. NOT THAT WITH THIS
CURRENT- CROSSWORD PUZZLE OF
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE HAVE IN THE
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR CALLING WE DO
HAVE ONE LAST COMMENT AND THAT
WILL COME FROM LINE SEVENTY
THREE. HELLO BY. HELLO EVERYONE
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES GO AHEAD-
HI THANK YOU MY NAME'S LAW IS
THE REASON I'M AS A SPANISH
CERTIFIED COURT INTERPRETER
HEARING ON THE MEDIA COUNTY AND
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT
ARE COOPER WITH ALL MY
COLLEAGUES ALL THE COMMON THAT
ARE THE HEARING FOR THESE CALL
WE'VE BEEN FORCING YOU TO BE
HERE REMOTE INTERPRETING SINCE
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY. AND ALL I
CAN SAY IS THAT WE'VE BEEN
STRUGGLING WITH THE SCRAMBLING
AND WE'VE BEEN JUST MANAGING AT
THIS POINT WHERE THE- KEEPING
UP WHERE IS IT WITH THE BUT NOT
WITH A TECHNOLOGY THAT WAS
GIVEN TO US WOULD BE DOING OUR
BEST BY RELIVING ENCOUNTERING
MANY NOT ONLY AGES WITH THE
PHONE LINES ARE BAD CONNECTION
INCLUDING CONNECTIONS- LOSING
PATIENCE FROM. IT JUST JUST
TRYING TO GET CONNECTED AND
HELP THE FAMILIES THAT SO
NEEDED SPECIALTY NOT ALL THAT
THEY CAN JUST- APPEARING IN
PERSON AND GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT'S GOING
ON I'M MAINLY A TRYING TO DOING
ON CHANGES AND WE'RE DOING THAT
PENSION SCHEMES WHERE WHERE
CHILDREN ARE BEING REMOVED AND
THE PARENTS ARE NOT THERE-
THERE'S A LOT OF INFORMATION
THAT IS NEEDED JUSTICE BECAUSE
OF NOT BEING ABLE TO HAVE MORE
TIME. WITH THE PARENTS TO
EXPLAIN WHAT'S GOING ON AND
AGAIN OUR PARENTS ARE AT WORK-
THERE'S NOT CONNECTIONS AND
THEN SAYS JUST OVERALL
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE-
CONSULTED WITH NATURE BETTER IS
THAT WE ARE ON THE FRONT LINES
AND KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING
ON THE FOR THE- PAST THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. CALL
FOR. OKAY I THANK YOU MY OF
VERY MUCH YOU TO EVERYONE WHO
CALL IN WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE-
BUT TO VOTE ON THE VOTE MOTION-
I WILL NOTE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD OPEN. ISSUE THREE. WE'RE
NOT GOING TO VOTE ON ISSUE
THREE AND WE'RE GONNA TAKE
THREE SETS OF VOTES ON THE
REMAINING ITEMS. THE THREE SETS
OF BOTH WILL BE TO ADOPT THE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS. THE
FIRST VOTE WILL BE FOR ISSUES.
ONE TWO. FOUR THROUGH SEVEN
NINE THROUGH. TWELVE FOURTEEN
TO SIXTEEN AND TWENTY. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION FOR THESE ISSUES.
OKAY WELL DR FRANCIS PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL- CENTER TO
RUSSELL I ENTERED AROUSAL BY
SENATOR GROWTH. SENATOR CORTEZ
HE OKAY SENATOR CORTEZ III
SENATOR NEWMAN HI CENTER NEWMAN
I. WE WILL PUT ON HOLD. OKAY
PUT ON HOLD HERE OF THE SECOND
VOTE WILL BE FOR ISSUES EIGHT.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TO
HAVE A MOTION FOR THESE ISSUES.
DR FRANCIS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ALSO I CENTER DORADO
AYE SENATOR GROWTH. SENATOR
CORTEZ HE RIGHT SENATOR CORTEZ
THE BY AND CENTER NEWMAN HI
CENTER NEWMAN I WILL KEEP THAT
ON ON CALL RIGHT IN THE THIRD
VOTE WILL BE FOR ISSUED
THIRTEEN. TO A MOTION FOR THIS
ISSUE MOVE. DR FRANK PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR RAZA I
ENTERED THE WRONG HI CENTER
GROVE. SENATOR CORTEZ HE
SENATOR CORTEZ III CENTER
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT SENATOR NEWMAN
HI. WE'RE GONNA HOLD ON THOSE
THREE VOTES FOR A FEW MORE
MINUTES AND- FOR NOW- RESHAPED
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION AND THANK YOU TO
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFIED TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE
YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU AGAIN
TO EVERYONE AND WE. APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION WE'RE GONNA
GO BACK ART THE OF MOTIONS THAT
WERE MADE OF THE FOR VOTE- WE-
COOL. RESUME ON IS. THE HAVE
THE BEST. THIS OKAY I DON'T
WANT SO ARE THE ISSUE ARE ONE.
637-921-2142. SIXTEEN. OUR
INTERACTIVE FRANCE. TWENTY
FOUR. TWENTY I'M SORRY FOURTEEN
TO SIXTEEN AND TWENTY WE HAD A
MOTION FOR THIS DOCTOR FRANCIS.
PLEASE IS IT OKAY IF I SEPARATE
OUT THIRTEEN. OKAY IF I
SEPARATE OUT THIRTEEN THE ISSUE
THIRTEEN HAS BEEN SEPARATED OUT
ALREADY HAS TO WORK WE'RE GOING
TO GO IN ORDER OKAY I'M SORRY I
MISUNDERSTOOD NO WORRIES I
APOLOGIZE OKAY GO AHEAD- SELL
BOOKS OPEN THE ROLE OUR CENTER
GROVE. I HAVE BEEN A GROVE HI
OKAY WE CLOSE CLOSE CLOSE WELL
AND WHAT'S THE VOTE VOTE WAS
FOR EYES AND- NO ZERO OKAY
THANK YOU BOB THE SECOND VOTE
IS ISSUES EIGHT SEVENTEEN.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. WE HAD A
MOTION FOR THIS DOCTOR FRANCIS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL CENTER
GROVE NO CENTER GROVE NOW. SIZE
THREE KNOWS ONE OKAY SENATE
PASSES THE THIRD VOTE WILL BE
FOR ISSUE THIRTEEN WE HAD A
MOTION DR FRANCIS PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FEDERAL. GROWTH NOT
VOTING. I FIVE THREE KNOWS AND
ONE NO LOADING OKAY THE CLOSE
VOTE ON THAT YES AND WE'RE DONE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR THE
MEDIA KIND Q. ALL RIGHT THANKS
EVERYBODY.